This is the 99% of visible breakdown of the power broker. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elliot Cailin. So today we're continuing part seven, The Loss of Power, chapters 42 through 46, that's pages 984 through 1081. And later in this episode, our special guest is Brennan Lee Mulligan. Brennan is a comedian and host with Dropout TV where he's the creator of Dimension 20. It's a show that features incredibly complex and fun and dynamic Dungeons and Dragons campaigns with improv actors and special effects. And as the dungeon master, Brennan leads these stories.
这是《权力掮客》99%可见度拆解。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是埃利奥特·凯林。今天我们继续第七部分“权力的丧失”，第42章到第46章，也就是第984页到第1081页。在本期节目稍后，我们的特别嘉宾是布伦南·李·穆里根。布伦南是Dropout TV的喜剧演员和主持人，也是《Dimension 20》的创作者。这是一个以即兴演员和特效呈现极其复杂、有趣且充满活力的《龙与地下城》战役的节目。作为地下城主，布伦南引领着这些故事。
And I know that might sound completely unrelated to the power broker, but one season of Dimension 20 features a villain that all of you listening would be very familiar with, but in a very different context. To my understanding, Mr. Moses is a powerful form of undead. Robert Moses is a powerful historical figure. Never elected, but was part of a lot of government boards, had a lot to do with the building and infrastructure of New York, specifically a lot with the building
我知道这听起来可能与《权力掮客》完全无关，但《Dimension 20》有一季出现了一个反派，所有听众都会非常熟悉，只是背景截然不同。据我所知，摩西先生是一个强大的不死生物。罗伯特·摩西是一位强大的历史人物。他从未当选，但曾任职于许多政府委员会，对纽约的建筑和基础设施建设有很大影响，特别是与建筑
of roads and highways. Mm-hmm. Causing interference in the magical world. So last time on the 99% visible breakdown of the power broker, Robert Carroll went into incredible detail about how Robert Moses refused to include mass transit as part of his transportation plans and it doomed New York to a future choked with cars
道路和高速公路有关。嗯。在魔法世界中造成了干扰。所以，上次在《权力掮客》99%可见度拆解中，罗伯特·卡罗极其详细地讲述了罗伯特·摩西如何拒绝将公共交通纳入其交通规划，这注定了纽约未来将被汽车
and traffic and really explicit detail about how awful different railroads were. It was very vivid. But we also saw how an assortment of activists were starting to recognize the serious issues with how Moses was running his slum clearance programs and the public housing construction projects. So that was a little bit of a glimmer.
和交通堵塞所困，并非常明确地描述了各种铁路是多么糟糕。非常生动。但我们也看到，各种各样的活动人士开始意识到摩西在推行贫民窟清理计划和公共住房建设项目时存在严重问题。所以那是一点点曙光。
There were rumors, rumors of rumors. And so on this episode, we'll be covering chapters 42 to 46, that's pages 984 to 1081. And this is a delightful collection of chapters. Eliot. These are, especially after the last chapters, which were so gloomy and doomy, this is going to be a nice, yeah, this is a nice change of pace
有传言，传言的传言。所以在这期节目中，我们将涵盖第42到46章，也就是第984页到第1081页。这是一组令人愉快的章节。埃利奥特。特别是经历了上一章那些阴郁沉重的章节之后，这将是一个不错的，是的，这是一个很好的节奏变化
because Robert Moses is on the dissension, rather than the ascension. And it's going to happen in ways that are not entirely satisfying in terms of the scale and scope of the crimes he's being hoisted on. The petard he's being hoisted on is not the petard we hoped it would be, but there's something fun about that and Robert Caro is clearly having fun writing about it and that really comes through.
因为罗伯特·摩西正处于衰落而非上升期。而且，就他所犯下的罪行规模和范围而言，他被自己所设的陷阱困住的方式并不完全令人满意。他被困住的陷阱并不是我们所希望的那种，但其中有一些有趣的地方，罗伯特·卡罗显然在写作时乐在其中，这一点确实体现了出来。
And by the end of today's episode, Moses will have been hoisted by his own petard. There's no other way to put it. There's no other way to put it. Yeah. It's a petard hoisting. It's a classic petard hoisting. And as you were saying, we're gonna pass the thousand page mark in this episode, which is very exciting. That's a lot of pages, and we'll have to take
到今天节目结束时，摩西将被他自己的陷阱所困。没有别的说法了。没有别的说法了。是的。这是一次陷阱困人。这是经典的陷阱困人。正如你所说，我们将在本期节目中跨越一千页大关，这非常令人兴奋。那是很多页，我们得花点时间
a moment to pop some champagne. Really, really reminisce about the pages that brought us here, but it's gonna be exciting, it's gonna be exciting. So we start here with chapter 42, Tavern in the Town, which chronicles probably one of the lesser crimes of Robert Moses, but still makes a good story. So how does it begin?
开瓶香槟庆祝一下。真的，真的要回味一下带我们走到这里的这些页面，但这会很令人兴奋，会很令人兴奋。所以我们从第42章“镇上的酒馆”开始，这一章记录了罗伯特·摩西可能犯下的较小的罪行之一，但仍然是一个好故事。那么它是如何开始的呢？
It makes a great story, and it's also, I'll just say this before I even start, Roman, this will be an annoying, unnecessary little tangent. 42, as anyone who's read the Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy series knows, is the answer to the question of life, the universe and everything. And in this chapter, we get finally the answer to what will it take to really break away
这是一个很棒的故事，而且，在开始之前我只想说，罗曼，这将是一个烦人且不必要的题外话。42，正如任何读过《银河系漫游指南》系列的人所知，是关于生命、宇宙以及一切终极问题的答案。在这一章中，我们终于得到了答案，即要真正打破
the reputation Moses has as the great guy, the Parksman, the man who can get things done for the people. It's in this chapter that what he does is, seems so incredibly trivial and yet reverberates through so much. So it begins talking about how this is gonna be the Battle of Central Park. Carol reminds everybody how in 1934,
摩西作为伟人、公园建设者、能为人民办实事的男人这一声誉，需要什么。在这一章中，他所做的事情看起来极其琐碎，却产生了巨大的反响。所以它开始讲述这将是中央公园之战。卡罗提醒大家，1934年，
Robert Moses, he refurbished and renovated Central Park. He replaced the sheep meadow, which previously had been full of inbred mutant sheep that had been there for generations. He replaces the sheep meadow near Central Park West and 67th Street with a restaurant, Tavern on the Green. Regular listeners will know that's where my dad proposed to my mom before they got married.
罗伯特·摩西翻新并改造了中央公园。他用一家餐厅“绿茵酒馆”取代了羊草地，那里以前世代居住着近亲繁殖的变种羊。中央公园西侧和67街附近的绿茵酒馆。经常收听的听众会知道，那是我爸爸向我妈妈求婚的地方。
Ghostbusters fans will know it as the restaurant where Rick Moranis is finally overtaken by the terror dog. And I guess eaten, you know, in plain view of the diners at the restaurant. And he cut a road extension into the park and a parking circle into the park that serves the restaurant. And what's funny to me here is that Carrow
《捉鬼敢死队》的粉丝会知道，那是里克·莫拉尼斯最终被恐怖犬袭击的餐厅。我想是被吃掉了，你知道，在餐厅食客的众目睽睽之下。他在公园里开辟了一条道路延伸段和一个服务于餐厅的停车圈。对我来说有趣的是，卡罗
is using the sheep as a symbol of the pastoral world that was shunted aside for the restaurant. And what's funny to me here is that Karo is using the sheep as a symbol of the pastoral world that was shunted aside for the restaurant and its parking circle. When, back when Karo was talking about those sheep, previously they were monsters. They were just like, they were implied as disgusting, something you needed to get rid of. But now Karo is kind of having it both ways and he's like, what was once a bucolic sheep meadow? It's like, oh, all right, there's different ways to look at sheep, I guess. So the year is 1956. Let's place ourselves in time. We are now in 1956, and local families have come to depend on this little tree shaded Glen between 67th and 68th streets in the park as a place for their kids to play.
把羊作为田园世界的象征，而这个世界为了餐厅而被排挤。对我来说有趣的是，卡罗把羊作为田园世界的象征，而这个世界为了餐厅及其停车圈而被排挤。然而，当卡罗之前谈论那些羊时，它们是怪物。它们被暗示为令人作呕的东西，是你需要摆脱的东西。但现在卡罗有点两头兼顾，他说，曾经那片田园诗般的羊草地？就像是，哦，好吧，我想看待羊的方式有很多种。所以时间是1956年。让我们把时间定格。我们现在处于1956年，当地家庭已经依赖公园里67街和68街之间这片树荫下的小峡谷作为孩子们的游乐场所。
They're using it the way parks have been intended by Moses to be used as community spaces for people to play in them. And the the way parks have been intended by Moses to be used, as community spaces for people to play in them. And the local mothers, they find the space especially precious. It's somewhere very close to their apartments. Their kids who live in apartments and have no outdoor space of their own. And these are middle class, upper middle class kids. These are kids who have resources. These are not slum kids, but they still don't have outdoor space of their own. They don't have yards. So this is a place they can run around. The moms can talk.
他们像摩西预想的那样使用公园，作为人们玩耍的社区空间。而当地的母亲们觉得这个空间特别珍贵。它离她们的公寓非常近。她们的孩子住在公寓里，没有自己的户外空间。这些是中产阶级、中上阶层的孩子。这些孩子拥有资源。他们不是贫民窟的孩子，但他们仍然没有自己的户外空间。他们没有院子。所以这是一个他们可以四处奔跑的地方。妈妈们可以聊天。
It is a very important little place in their lives, a place that carries a lot of meaning and emotion for them. Until one day on April 9th, 1956. What happens on that day, Roman? Well, one of the moms, Roselle Davis, she sees these surveyors with blueprints looking over her bucolic Glenn. And when they break for lunch, they accidentally leave the blueprints behind. And she reads on the title, detailed map of parking lot. And this is the plans to replace
这是她们生活中一个非常重要的小地方，一个对她们承载着许多意义和情感的地方。直到1956年4月9日的那一天。那天发生了什么，罗曼？嗯，其中一位妈妈，罗泽尔·戴维斯，她看到这些带着蓝图的测量员在查看她那田园诗般的峡谷。当他们午休时，他们不小心留下了蓝图。她读到标题，“停车场详细地图”。这就是用
the Glenn with a parking lot to serve Tavern on the Green, which is just like a movie scene. It's incredible. Yeah, literally that it's like a parking lot here because they found these papers. And this is the kind of thing that if you saw it in a movie, you'd be like, come on, but it happens in real life all the time. I forget what Civil War Battle it was
停车场取代峡谷以服务绿茵酒馆的计划，这就像电影场景一样。太不可思议了。是的，字面上就像这里的停车场，因为他们发现了这些文件。这就是那种如果你在电影里看到，你会说，得了吧，但这种情况在现实生活中一直发生。我忘了是哪场内战战役了
where they literally found the Confederate plans wrapped around a cigar. And they're like, oh, okay, now we know what's gonna happen, you know? And this is something that, it's not necessarily important, but the last few chapters in the last episode felt very much like data, data, data. Like I'm giving you hard information
他们真的发现了包裹在雪茄里的南方联盟计划。他们就像，哦，好吧，现在我们知道会发生什么了，你知道吗？这并不是说它一定很重要，但上一集中的最后几章感觉非常像数据、数据、数据。就像我在给你提供关于
about this urban transportation issue. And here it feels like Caro has shifted much more into reporter storyteller mode. He is telling a story, and this section is very dramatic, cinematic, in a very fun way. But that also sort of describes why this fight, unlike other fights that involve a lot of data, or a lot of real problems that Moses has caused,
这个城市交通问题的硬信息。而在这里，感觉卡罗已经更多地转向了记者讲故事的模式。他在讲一个故事，这一部分非常戏剧化、电影化，而且非常有趣。但这在某种程度上也解释了为什么这场斗争，不像其他涉及大量数据或摩西造成的许多实际问题的斗争那样，
don't gain traction, whereas this one with this nice story of these nice moms and their upper middle class life really does take hold in newspapers, which is really the big deal with this one. Yes, it shows you the importance of a story, as we'll see, like the importance of a narrative that it is hard to convince people with a lot of numbers, but it is much easier to convince people when you've got moms and kids versus bulldozers, as we'll see. And so, Davis, she tells another mom, Augusta Newman, and Augusta Newman is the wife of Arnold Newman,
获得关注，而这个关于这些好妈妈和她们中上层生活的好故事确实在报纸上引起了轰动，这才是这一事件的重点。是的，它向你展示了故事的重要性，正如我们将看到的，叙事的重要性，即用大量数字说服人们很难，但当你拥有妈妈和孩子对抗推土机时，说服人们就容易多了，正如我们将看到的。所以，戴维斯告诉了另一位妈妈，奥古斯塔·纽曼，而奥古斯塔·纽曼是阿诺德·纽曼的妻子，
who's a well-known photographer. And I think this is one of the differences we had kind of talked about in previous episodes between what happens here, what happened earlier, is these are people who have access to media. These are people who have access to professional assistance These are people who have access to professional assistants or are professionals themselves in a way that the people of East Tremont,
他是一位著名的摄影师。我认为这是我们在之前几集中讨论过的，这里发生的事情与早期发生的事情之间的区别之一，就是这些人能够接触到媒体。这些人能够获得专业协助，或者他们本身就是专业人士，这与东特雷蒙特的人民，
the people of Harlem just do not have access to. And so they write up a petition and they try to get it signed by many of the well-known artists and writers who live on the block. Like a name that comes up a lot is the novelist Fanny Hurst, who I've not read any of her work, but I've heard the name before. Carol mentions playwright and screenwriter Samson Raffelson,
哈莱姆区的人民根本无法接触到的资源不同。所以他们写了一份请愿书，并试图让住在街区上的许多著名艺术家和作家签名。比如经常出现的一个名字是小说家范妮·赫斯特，我没读过她的任何作品，但我以前听过这个名字。卡罗提到了剧作家和编剧萨姆森·拉斐尔森，
and he refers to him as Samuel Raffelson for some reason, but I don't, unless I'm getting the names mixed up, I don't know if there is a Samuel Raffelson, but Samson Raffelson is a well-known, you know, is a classic playwright and screenwriter. So this might be the third error I've ever found in the thousands of pages of Caro's work. And one of the other errors is just him getting the name of a movie slightly wrong in one of the Lyndon Johnson books. So I'm not that mad about it. But this is like Ludwig Bemelmans, the author of Madeline, lives here. Like Pearl Lang the dancer, May Murray, this former silent movie star lives there. And there are these other names that I'm sure were more well known when the book came out,
他出于某种原因称他为塞缪尔·拉斐尔森，但我不知道，除非我把名字搞混了，我不知道是否有塞缪尔·拉斐尔森，但萨姆森·拉斐尔森是一位著名的，你知道，是一位经典的剧作家和编剧。所以这可能是我在卡罗数千页作品中发现的第三个错误。而另一个错误只是他在林登·约翰逊的一本书中把电影的名字写错了一点。所以我对此并不生气。但这就像《玛德琳》的作者路德维希·贝梅尔曼斯住在这里。比如舞者珀尔·朗，梅·默里，这位前默片明星住在那儿。还有其他一些名字，我相信在书出版时更广为人知，
but would have to be researched by modern readers. But in the end, they have this petition with just 23 names on it. We've seen petitions with thousands of names get knocked aside. In the Park Department, they're like, yeah, 23 name petition? I'm ignoring this. We don't want to deal with this. And the newly installed deputy mayor tries to arrange a meeting and is told off by one of Moses' secretaries over the phone. But here's the difference. One of the moms, she signs it. She is not just a person with access to the newspapers. She is a person who is married to a Herald Tribune reporter. So, Roman, this time is personal.
但现代读者必须去研究。但最终，他们这份请愿书上只有23个名字。我们见过成千上万个名字的请愿书被驳回。在公园部门，他们就像，是的，23个名字的请愿书？我无视这个。我们不想处理这个。新上任的副市长试图安排一次会议，但在电话里被摩西的一位秘书训斥了。但区别就在这里。其中一位妈妈，她签了名。她不仅仅是一个能接触到报纸的人。她是一个嫁给《先驱论坛报》记者的人。所以，罗曼，这次是私人的。
That's right. But it's so funny to me how this starts with Moses being completely disdainful because he has been so used to this for so long. 23 moms versus like the thousands and thousands when it came to the one mile section, we have the 5,000 moms of Manhattan town, 4,000 moms of Lincoln Center, nobody cares. Preston loves them.
没错。但我觉得这开始时摩西表现得完全不屑一顾非常有趣，因为他长期以来一直习惯了这一点。23位妈妈对抗像一英里路段时的成千上万，我们有曼哈顿镇的5000位妈妈，林肯中心的4000位妈妈，没人关心。普雷斯顿爱她们。
Everything is just going his way at this point. But just the amount of time and really, it's the constituency of the people who are upset that really, really changes things. Yes, but he's so complacent about it. And there's a, Carol sums it up, he's refusing to meet with them. He sends them a letter that says like,
此时此刻一切都顺着他的意愿发展。但真正改变局势的，确实是那些感到不安的人的选民身份。是的，但他对此太自满了。卡罗总结道，他拒绝与她们会面。他给她们发了一封信，说像
let's talk about it, but his plan is he'll letter that says, like, let's talk about it. But his plan is he'll just start tearing up the Glen before they talk about it. That's just what he does. And he sends them this letter, and Carol writes, His letter would not placate the mothers, of course, but that would no longer matter. By the time they read his explanation of why it was necessary to destroy the Glen they were fighting for,
让我们谈谈，但他的计划是，他会发一封信说，让我们谈谈。但他的计划是，他会在他们谈话之前就开始拆除峡谷。这就是他所做的。他给她们发了这封信，卡罗写道，他的信当然不会安抚这些母亲，但这已经无关紧要了。当她们读到他关于为什么有必要摧毁她们正在为之奋斗的峡谷的解释时，
there would no longer be any point in fighting for it. It wouldn't be there. This protest would be disposed of as he had been disposing of protests for 30 years. And then there's a space in the page and then he writes, but this protest was different. And why is it different? For these reasons we're talking about,
已经没有必要再为之奋斗了。它将不复存在。这次抗议将被处理掉，就像他30年来处理抗议活动一样。然后页面上有一段空白，然后他写道，但这次抗议不同。为什么不同？因为我们谈到的这些原因，
these protesters are educated, they are financially secure, they are well connected to the media, there are lawyers in these families, they can afford to raise the money to fight this legally or they can do the work themselves. You know, this is not, these are not people who are lower class people who live in a neighborhood that even though it's clean and nice and people love it,
这些抗议者受过教育，经济稳定，与媒体联系紧密，这些家庭中有律师，他们有能力筹集资金在法律上进行抗争，或者他们可以自己动手。你知道，这不是，这些人不是生活在即使干净漂亮、人们喜爱但却没有资源的社区里的下层阶级。而且这次不同还因为它是如此明确。卡罗指出，你可以对道路在这个空间更重要还是社区更重要，
does not have the resources. And this is also different because it's so clear cut. Carol makes the point, you can have competing ideas about whether a road is more important in this space or a neighborhood, a road is more important in this space or a neighborhood, whether housing is more important in this space or a neighborhood, what the needs of a city are. But this is children's play space versus a parking lot for a restaurant.
住房在这个空间更重要还是社区更重要，城市的需求是什么，有相互竞争的观点。但这是儿童游乐空间与餐厅停车场之间的较量。
Which is, so this is the closest the book gets to the plot of Break into Electric Boogaloo, where it's literally a community center for needy kids versus a shopping mall. Like it's, there's no, it's, where it's literally a community center for needy kids versus a shopping mall. Like it's, there's no, it's so, it's so clear cut. And Moses's role is so clear cut in this. In the housing fights that he does, he can hide behind the private developers
这最接近《霹雳舞2》的剧情，即贫困儿童的社区中心与购物中心之间的较量。就像是，没有，它是如此明确。摩西在其中的角色如此明确。在他所做的住房斗争中，他可以躲在私人开发商身后，
who are technically responsible for the on the ground stuff, even though he's calling all those shots. This is a park issue. It's in Central Park and everyone knows Moses is the parks man. And not only that, this is central park, which is a special park. It is literally, as everyone says, the
他们从技术上讲要对实地工作负责，尽管他掌控着一切。这是一个公园问题。它在中央公园，每个人都知道摩西是公园先生。不仅如此，这是中央公园，这是一个特殊的公园。正如每个人所说，它字面上是
lungs of the city. And I think it is hard to argue that the single greatest decision of the planners of New York city, it's hard to argue that there was a greater decision than the one to leave this space open, then to not grid it out and to make it into just streets, to leave this enormous space.
城市的肺。我认为很难争辩说纽约市规划者做出的最伟大的决定，很难争辩说有什么决定比决定留下这个空间，而不是把它网格化并变成街道，留下这个巨大的空间更伟大。
Cause, cause central park is huge. It's a huge park. It's not the biggest park in New York city. I think that's Pelham Bay park, but nobody, nobody goes up there. I mean, people do, but it's not the same. Central park is right in the middle of the action. And it is really a sacred space.
因为，因为中央公园很大。这是一个巨大的公园。它不是纽约市最大的公园。我想那是佩勒姆湾公园，但没人，没人去那里。我的意思是，人们确实去，但那不一样。中央公园就在行动的中心。它确实是一个神圣的空间。
And I remember months ago, we talked about what a big deal it was when Moses refurbished the park in the 1930s. That was one of the things that made him such a heroic figure for the city, is that he turned Central Park into this beautiful place again, that people could take a break from living in this crammed-in city. And it's a park that people spend a lot of time in. He can't do something there and hide it and keep it secret the way he could when he rammed the Major Deegan
我记得几个月前，我们谈到摩西在20世纪30年代翻新公园时是多么大的事情。那是让他成为城市英雄人物的事情之一，他让中央公园再次成为这个美丽的地方，人们可以从居住在这个拥挤的城市中休息一下。这是一个人们花很多时间在里面的公园。他不能在那里做些什么并隐藏它，像他在把迪根高速公路
through the Van Cortland Park marshes. People see Central Park. It's in the middle of Manhattan. It's very open. And so it's a very public place for him to pick a fight and especially to pick a fight with mops. Yeah, yeah. But he does and he starts doing the thing
强行穿过范科特兰公园沼泽地时那样保密。人们能看到中央公园。它在曼哈顿的中心。它非常开放。所以对他来说，这是一个非常公开的斗争场所，尤其是与妈妈们斗争。是的，是的。但他确实这样做了，并开始做他
that he normally does, which is, you know, before anyone can sort of like realize it, he sends his bulldozers to rip it up and, you know, to make it so that when, that it's a fait accompli and they can protest all they want to. But they actually caught on to this. Like, they see the bulldozers coming. One of the Central Park West residents, Eleanor Sanger,
通常做的事情，也就是，在任何人意识到之前，他派推土机去拆除它，你知道，为了造成既成事实，这样他们想怎么抗议都行。但他们实际上发现了这一点。就像，他们看到推土机来了。中央公园西侧的居民之一，埃莉诺·桑格，
looks at her bathroom window. She sees bulldozers ripping up trees and- It's such a cinematic scene. She's just going in the morning to like brush her teeth or whatever. And she looks out the window and sees bulldozers. And it's, I mean, it is, I mentioned Hitchhiker's Guide already, it's literally opening of Hitchhiker's Guide
看着她的浴室窗户。她看到推土机在拆除树木，这真是一个电影般的场景。她只是在早上像刷牙什么的。她看向窗外，看到了推土机。而且，我的意思是，我提到了《银河系漫游指南》，这字面上就是《银河系漫游指南》的开头，他看向外面，看到推土机要拆掉他的房子。所以她看到了，她做了什么？她只是打电话给她的朋友，他们跑了过去。你知道，就像基本上是妇女、儿童和婴儿车，他们站在推土机前面，拍照片放在报纸上看起来很有趣，他们知道这一点。
to the galaxy is he looks outside and sees bulldozers are gonna knock his house down. And so she sees it and what does she do? She just like calls her friends and they run down there. You know, like just basically like women and children and baby carriages and they stand in front of a Bulldozer and that looks so fun to take photographs of to put in the newspaper and they know it.
他们不一定站在推土机前面，因为这些是手里抱着孩子的妇女，但她们让自己出现在推土机面前，推土机司机停止了工作。她还叫了斯坦利·艾萨克斯。我们之前提到过他，长期的公民改革者，他帮助让媒体到场，媒体出现了。就像你说的，这是妈妈和孩子对抗推土机。
They don't necessarily stand in front of the Bulldozer because these are women with children in their hands, but they make themselves visible to the bulldozer and the bulldozer driver stops his work. And she is also called Stanley Isaacs. We mentioned him before, long time civic reformer, and he helps to get the press there and the press shows up. Like you're saying, this is moms and kids versus bulldozers.
这是一个媒体可以拍照的好故事。当莉莲·埃德尔斯坦试图拯救她那部分的东特雷蒙特时，她几乎无法引起记者的注意。她会举行数百人的集会，而记者却不在那里。但现在推着婴儿车的妈妈们
And this is a good story for the media that you can take pictures of. And when Lillian Edelstein was trying to save her part of East Tremont, she could barely get reporters to notice. She would hold rallies with hundreds of people and reporters were not there. But now moms with baby carriages
正在中央公园与推土机对峙。所有的报纸、电视台和广播电台的记者都蜂拥而至。很快这个故事就传遍了各地。卡罗在这里没有谈论太多的一点，我想可能是因为他是个报纸人，是电视可能带来的不同。
are having a face-off with bulldozers in Central Park. And reporters from all the newspapers and the TV stations and the radio stations rush in. And soon the story is everywhere. And something that Caro does not talk about too much here, I think maybe because he's such a newspaper guy, is the difference that television probably made with this too.
电视给事物带来了一种报纸和广播不一定具备的即时性，抱歉罗曼，我讨厌对广播这么说，但电视确实有某种东西。也许这也是一个区别，但他没有深入探讨。母亲们每天从早上7点到天黑设立轮流守卫，以防止推土机
That television just brings an immediacy to things that newspapers and radio don't necessarily, sorry Roman, I hate to say that about radio, but there's just something about television. And maybe that's a difference too, but he doesn't quite get into that. And the mothers, they set up a rotating guard from 7 a.m. to dark every day to keep the bulldozers
启动。记者们，他们喜欢这个。它有著名的名字，有妈妈和孩子，有树木。在恰逢植树周的时候，不是在公园里砍树的最佳周，它有一个处于危险中的公园。它有推土机。
from starting up. And the reporters, they love it. It's got famous names, it's got moms and kids, it's got trees. During what happens to be Arbor Day week, not the best week to be knocking down trees in your park, it's got a park in danger. It's got bulldozers.
这不仅仅是某个社区的本地公园问题。这是中央公园之战。他们就是这样构思的。还有“妈妈对抗摩西”，这是他们构思的另一种方式。太完美了。中央公园之战，冒号，妈妈对抗摩西。就像那是你的电影标题。太棒了。
And this isn't just a local park issue in some neighborhood. This is the Battle of Central Park. That's how they frame it. And Moms versus Moses, which is another way they frame it. It's perfect. The Battle of Central Park colon, Moms versus Moses. Like that's your movie title right there. It's amazing.
即使在21世纪，任何政治对话中最有力的东西是什么？被提出来的事情是，这对我们的孩子有什么影响？是什么？你知道，我是一位母亲，我关心我的孩子。这可能是人类存在中最普遍、最基本的关系，
And even now in the 21st century, what is the most potent thing in any political conversation? What's the thing that gets brought up is, what is this gonna do to our kids? What is it? You know, I'm a mom and I'm concerned about my kids. It is the single most probably universal, like basic fundamental relationship in human
大概是母子关系。抱歉爸爸们，我讨厌打破这个。抱歉阿姨、叔叔和兄弟姐妹。这并不意味着你需要一位母亲才能被培养得很好，但它回到了动物王国和进化。你知道，母亲和孩子之间的那种关系。所以能够利用这一点，罗伯特·摩西可以随心所欲地咆哮，但这就像人们和他们的母亲之间有一种牢不可破的纽带。
existence is probably mother and child. Sorry dads, I hate to break it to you. Sorry aunts and uncles and siblings. And it doesn't mean you need a mother, you know, to be raised great, but it goes back to the animal kingdom and evolution. You know, that relationship between mothers and children. And so to be able to tap into that, Robert Moses can bluster all he wants, but it's like there's an unbreakable bond between people and their mothers.
是的，是的。这也是其中之一，因为他是公园先生，这是中央公园，他是一个如此高大的人物，他可以站在后面，工程师们为这条路说这个，你知道，各种各样的东西。这是他一直坚持的，每一个决定都是他的。
Yeah, yeah. And this is also one of those things where because he's the parks guy and it's Central Park, and he's such a towering figure, he can kind of stand behind, the engineers say this for this road, that, you know, all sorts of stuff. Like this is the one that he's always held onto where every decision is his.
他因这一切而获得赞誉，因此他因这一件事而承担所有责任。是的。这与他可以把工程师说这个、城市需要这个、他为之编写法律的复杂规则等层层掩盖的其他事情完全不同。但这只是一个选择。它只是很好的素材，他完全不在状态。
He gets credit for all of it and therefore he gets all of the blame for this one. Yes. That's just totally different than the other stuff, which you can sort of like put these layers of like engineers say this, the city needs this, the different rules that are complicated that he wrote the laws for and everything like this. But this is just a choice. It's very simple. It just makes good copy and he's just completely out of his league.
他说的还是他以前说的话，但不管用。《纽约时报》甚至反对停车场，这是一件大事。他们通常在事情上支持他。摩西回应了，他只是派了他的公园工人和他的公园执行官斯图尔特·康斯特布尔，也就是“胡子”，我不确定。我不记得卡罗是否把那个绰号归于任何人，或者他
And he's saying the same things he said before, but it's not working. Even the New York Times comes out against the parking lot, which is a big thing. They usually support them on things. And Moses responds, he just sends his park workers and his parks executive Stuart Constable, aka the mustache, and I'm not sure. I don't remember if Caro attributes that nickname to anyone in particular, or if he, or if
自己想出来的，或者这就是他们叫他的方式，但这是我们在下一章中也会经常看到的角色。胡子，他们秘密地在深夜安装了围栏，并派出了推土机。甚至连纽约警察局都没有接到通知。他们在深夜发现，当有人向警察报告时，
he came up with it or if that's what they called him, but this is a character we'll see a lot of in the next chapter as well. The mustache and they secretly install a fence in the middle of the night and send the bulldozers in. Even the NYPD is not notified. They find out in the middle of the night when someone reports to a police officer,
嘿，看起来有人在公园里盖东西，发生了什么事。他们不得不派警察在早上挡住妈妈们，同时树木被砍倒并被切成碎片。媒体过去一直赞赏摩西做事的方式。他们对那种狡猾的做事方式有点默许。
hey, it looks like people are building things in the park, something's going on. And they have to send police officers in to hold the moms back in the morning while trees are knocked down and being chopped into pieces. And the media in the past has always applauded Moses's ways of getting things done. They kind of winked at him for those kind of devious ways.
你知道，他们谈论的是那种“哎呀，抱歉”的做事方法。但现在他们反过来对付他。他们拍到了母亲们在树木被砍伐时哭泣的照片。它们到处出现，尽管不幸的是它们不在书中。再次，照片部分是我觉得这本书如此令人失望的一部分，
You know, they talked about it was the like, oops, sorry method of getting things done. But now they turn on him. They got pictures of mothers crying as trees are cut down. They appear everywhere, though unfortunately they're not in this book. Again, the photo section is the one part of this book that I feel like is such a letdown,
但他们在书中展示了一张卡罗描述的照片，一个小男孩拿着玩具步枪，而一名警察在围栏旁站岗。到处都是这些照片，尴尬的警察，痛苦的母亲，反摩西的读者来信涌入，摩西没有被摧毁，
but they do show a photo in the book of a picture Carol describes of a little boy holding a toy rifle as a police officer stands guard at the fence. And it's just, there's all these photos come in, embarrassed police officers, anguished mothers, anti-Moses letters the editor pour in, and Moses is not destroyed,
但这是他第一次真正被玷污。卡罗写道，1956年4月24日星期二，罗伯特·摩西派他的部队进入中央公园的那一天是罗伯特·摩西的黑色星期二。因为在那一天，他失去了他最珍视的资产，他的声誉。摩西的繁荣持续了30年。现在它结束了。
but for the first time he's really tarnished. And Carol writes, Tuesday, April 24th, 1956, the day that Robert Moses sent his troops into Central Park was Robert Moses' Black Tuesday. For on it, he lost his most cherished asset, his reputation. The Moses boom had lasted for 30 years. Now it was over.
这并不是说，我的意思是，在任何人认为之前，并不是说摩西就像，好吧，没关系。就像他仍然，树木倒下了。就像他拆除了那些树。是的。而且他在这一时期也正在建造当时的一些主要高速公路和桥梁。你知道我的意思吗？这并不是说他的权力完全减弱，但就在这里，他真的受到了打击。是的，市长支持他，因为他有权力。市长需要那种权力。但有些事情，有一点不同发生了
And it's not like, I mean, before anyone thinks, it's not like then Moses is like, all right, never mind. Like he's still, the trees come down. Like he tears those trees down. Yeah. And he's like, during this period he's also building some of the major highways and bridges of this time. You know what I mean? This is like, this is not like a complete diminishment of his power, but right here he really takes it on the chin. Yes, and the mayor stands behind him because he has the power. The mayor needs that power. But something, one thing kind of different happens
在他开始为这个停车场铺设混凝土之前。所以回想1934年，他拆除了中央公园赌场，人们说，你不应该那样做。州法院说他可以这样做，因为他对公园拥有完全的权力。现在，22年后，是1956年，州最高法院，22年后，是1956年，州最高法院，其中一位法官实际上批准了一项禁令，停止工作，等待听证会。这就是他们以前甚至没有做过的事情，批准这些
before he can start laying down the concrete for this parking lot. And so remember back in 1934, he tore down the Central Park Casino and people were like, you shouldn't do that. And the state court said he can do it every once he has total power over the parks. Now, 22 years later, it's 1956, and the state Supreme Court, 22 years later, it's 1956, and the state Supreme Court, one of the justices actually grants an injunction, halting work, pending a hearing. And this is the kind of thing they didn't even do before, grant these
禁令。摩西就像，我会赢的。我可以按我的方式完成它。他拒绝妥协。那时斯坦利·艾萨克斯，那个狡猾的老改革者，他记得一件事并发现了两件事。他记得第一，当摩西拆除原来的赌场来建造酒馆时，他说他大惊小怪，说只有价格合理的餐厅才应该在公园里。而到了1956年，酒馆的价格并不合理。他们一个汉堡和一杯啤酒收费4.50美元。
injunctions. And Moses is like, I'm going to win this. I can get it done my way. He refuses to compromise. And that's when Stanley Isaacs, that wily old reformer, he remembers one thing and discovers two things. He remembers that one, when Moses tore down the original casino to build the tavern, he said he made a big stink about how only restaurants with reasonable prices should be in a public park. And by 1956, the tavern's prices are not reasonable. They're charging $4.50 for a hamburger and a beer.
我的意思是，这听起来像是一笔很棒的交易，但在1956年并非如此。卡罗引用了一篇新闻报道。他说，两个人的晚餐和小费总共23美元。酒吧里还有5美元买了两杯饮料。这不是发薪日前一天去的地方。再说一次，我像，就像我们之前几集中谈到的租金一样，我为那些价格流口水。这根本不是普通人可以随便走进去买个汉堡的餐厅。艾萨克斯发现的第二件也是更重要的事情是
And I mean, that sounds like an amazing deal, but in 1956 it was not. And Carrow quotes one news story. He goes, dinner and tip for two came to $23. There was another $5 at the bar for two drinks each. It's not a place to go the day before payday. And again, I'm like, like with the rents we were talking about in previous episodes, I'm salivating over those prices. And it's just, it is not, this is not a restaurant the average person could just walk into and buy a hamburger in. And the second and more important thing Isaac discovers is the
摩西给餐厅老板阿诺德·施莱弗的甜心交易。施莱弗应该向城市支付总收入的5%，对于一个主要城市公园中绝佳位置的高档餐厅来说，这已经是低得离谱的租金了。但即使是那个百分比他也没有支付，因为他的合同允许他从税收中扣除餐厅的改善成本。所以艾萨克斯发现，在四年期间，
sweetheart deal that Moses gave to the restaurant's owner, Arnold Schleifer. Schleifer is supposed to pay the city 5% of his gross income, which is already ridiculously low rent for a fancy restaurant in a major city park in a fantastic location. But even that percentage he hasn't been paying because his contract allows him to deduct the cost of improvements to the restaurant from his taxes. So Isaac finds that over a four year period,
施莱弗赚了近180万美元，他向城市支付了9000美元的税款。摩西本质上是以城市的代价让这家伙发财。卡罗说得很清楚，这笔交易并不违法。摩西没有拿回扣。尽管交换条件是施莱弗必须承办摩西喜欢的每一场宴会。
Schleifer made almost $1.8 million and he paid the city $9,000 in taxes. And Moses essentially making this guy rich at the city's expense. And Carol makes it clear, the deal is not illegal. Moses is not getting a kickback. Although the quid pro quo is that Schleifer has to cater every banquet Moses likes.
我们在之前的那一集中谈到施莱弗如何以一种对摩西来说太花哨、太民族化的方式承办了那场宴会。他写了那本很棒的回忆录。但这与摩西声誉的另一部分背道而驰。这种认为这家伙不搞裙带关系，不搞甜心交易的想法。他显然在搞。
And we talked in that earlier episode about how Schleifer catered that one banquet in a way that was just a little too fancy, schmancy, ethnic for Moses. And he wrote that great memoir about it. But this flies in the face of another part of Moses' reputation. This idea that the guy doesn't cater to favoritism, that he doesn't do sweetheart deals. He clearly is.
媒体也可以对此大做文章。他们可以过度简化故事，使其听起来比实际更腐败。但过去媒体的过度简化帮助了摩西，现在它开始伤害他了。是的。好吧，他就像，这就像一种感染。就像母亲们和那个拿着气步枪的可爱孩子的照片之类的东西，它们造成了一点小伤口。
And the press can make a lot of hay about this too. They can oversimplify the story to make it sound more corrupt than it is. But whereas in the past, the press's oversimplification has helped Moses, now it's starting to hurt him. Yeah. Well, he's just like, it's like an infection. Like the mothers and the images of the cute kid with the air rifle and stuff like that, they sort of make a little cut.
然后突然之间，这种通常不会给他带来任何问题的类型的事情，那里有足够的损害来感染，并使他在处理这些事情时偏离了正常状态。是的，这只是这种削弱，这种对他所依赖的声誉的一点点削弱。我只想指出，正是在故事的这一部分，我们在书中到了第999页。我们要做了，伙计们。即将跨入四位数的页码。
And then all of a sudden this type of thing, which normally wouldn't cause him any problems whatsoever, there's just enough damage there to infect and sort of get him off of his normal game when it comes to this stuff. Yeah, it's just this chipping away, this little bit of chipping away at the reputation that holds him up. And I just want to note, it's at this part of the story that we were on page 999 in the book. We're about to do it, people. About to tip over into quadruple digits in page numbers.
这不是你在很多书中能看到的。所以，真的很喜欢它，你知道。只有那些非常喜欢《幕府将军》电视剧以至于现在正在阅读那部小说的人，今年才会感受到这种达到一千页的快感。但是，关于这一点仍然有趣的是，你知道几十年来摩西一直以这种方式生活，并且在隐喻和字面上推土机般地碾过人们，而他仍然
Not something you see in a lot of books. So, really love it, you know. Only the people who loved the Shogun TV series so much that they're now reading that novel are gonna feel this thrill this year of reaching a thousand pages. But, so what's funny about this still is that you know for decades Moses has just sort of lived this way and and sort of bulldozed over people metaphorically and literally and he still
不太明白他处于失败的一方，所以他去了西班牙。是的，他去西班牙度了24天假。这是我有时有点怀疑的事情之一，我非常信任卡罗，但他会说，摩西是不可阻挡的，他总是工作。然后他去巴哈马度假了两周。就像然后他去西班牙度了24天假。我心想，我工作没有摩西那么努力，我也没有去西班牙度24天假。
doesn't quite get that he's on the losing side of this and so he takes off to Spain. Yeah he leaves on a 24-day vacation to Spain This is one of those things where I kind of wonder sometimes, I trust Caro so much, but he'll be like, Moses was unstoppable, he always worked. Then he went on a vacation for two weeks in the Bahamas. Like then he went on two week, 24 day vacation in Spain. And I'm like, I don't work as hard as Moses and I don't take 24 day vacations in Spain.
你刚才在西班牙，罗曼，对吧？你没有在那里待将近一个月。我没有在那里待将近一个月，但我绝对可以。那个地方太棒了。真是个伟大的国家。太美妙了。我真的很想回去。
You were just in Spain, Roman, right? You were not there for almost a month. I was not there for almost a month, but I definitely could have been. That place is great. Such a great country. It's wonderful. I really, I want to go back so badly.
我已经好几年没去了。太好了。但你是对的，他太自信了。他就像，我甚至不需要在这里。不幸的是，这在下一章也会成为一个问题，他留下了谁负责？那个胡子康斯特布尔，他就像没有机智、策略、优雅和智慧的摩西。康斯特布尔只是不必要地过度阻挠媒体，这让故事保持活力，并使城市更加愤怒。摩西不在那里协调政客、公园代表的反应，媒体正在猛扑并煽动某人发表的每一条小评论，以保持故事的进行。
I haven't been in years. It's so good. But you're right, he's so confident. He's like, I don't even need to be here. Unfortunately, and this will be a problem in the next chapter too, who does he leave in charge? The mustache constable who is like Moses without the tact and the strategizing
法院斗争中的下一轮法官维持了禁令。其中一位评论说，他对自己的法官薪水很满意，但即使对他来说，酒馆里的牛排也相当昂贵。他不能经常去那里。公开批评摩西开始变得更安全了。这是一个以前人们不得不窃窃私语的家伙，
and the grace and the wit. Constable just unnecessarily over stonewalling the press and that keeps the story alive and it makes the city angrier. And Moses is not there to coordinate the responses of politicians, of park reps, the media is pouncing on and sensationalizing every little comment that someone makes to keep the story going.
如果他们想批评的话，但现在这样做变得越来越容易了。摩西在度假后回到城市，那可能是一次很棒的西班牙之旅。当时从海外获取新闻更难，所以，我敢肯定他被屏蔽了一些消息。他试图保持冷静，但他最终在媒体上爆发了，
And the next round of judges in the court battle upholds the injunction. And one of them comments how he's happy with his judge's salary, but even for him, a steak at the tavern is pretty pricey. He can't afford deep air regularly. And it starts getting safer to publicly criticize Moses. This is a guy that people had to whisper about before,
就像他生气时总是做的那样。他甚至攻击范妮·赫斯特，这位受人尊敬的老年小说家，因为她对这个儿童游乐区大惊小怪，而她甚至没有孩子。如果她甚至没有孩子，她怎么能在这件事上有利害关系呢？读到这里，我心想，天哪，
if they wanted to criticize, but now it's becoming easier and easier to do that. And Moses returns to the city after, it was probably an amazing vacation in Spain. It was harder to get news from overseas then, so like, I'm sure he was shielded from some of this. And he tries to keep his cool, but he ends up blowing up in the press
我没想到这一部分会像现在这样相关。是的，真的很令人厌恶。是的，真的很令人厌恶。而且它感觉像是被撕裂的事实。真的很令人厌恶。是的，真的很令人厌恶，它感觉像是从今天的头条新闻中撕下来的，这种想法，有人说，好吧，如果你没有孩子，你就没有在这个国家有利害关系。
the way he always kind of used to when he was mad. And he goes so far as to attack Fanny Hurst, this respected elderly novelist, for making a stink about this children's play area when she doesn't even have children. How does she have a stake in this if she doesn't even have children? Which reading this, I was like, oh my God,
就像他以前生气时那样。他甚至攻击了备受尊敬的年长小说家范妮·赫斯特，因为她对这个儿童游乐区大惊小怪，而她自己根本没有孩子。她连孩子都没有，这事儿跟她有什么关系？读到这里时，我心想，天哪，
I didn't think this part was gonna be as relevant as it is now. Yeah, it's really loathsome. Yeah, it's really, and the fact that it felt like it was ripped. It's really loathsome. Yeah, it's really, the fact that it felt like it was ripped from today's headlines, this idea of someone saying, well, if you don't have children, you don't have a stake in the country.
我没想到这一部分在今天会如此切题。是的，这真的很令人厌恶。是的，真的，而且它感觉就像是从今天的新闻头条里直接摘下来的一样，这种观点——有人说，如果你没有孩子，你就与这个国家无关。
You're somehow selfish, don't care about the future. Yeah, it's bonkers. Unlike in the past, now the media is also giving the people Moses attacks a chance to reply to his attacks. And this attack on Fanny Hurst is really seen as too far, you know. Yeah. Oh, you know what? I just realized I kept saying next chapter about Constable in the Mustache, but it's actually the chapter after next chapter.
你有点自私，不关心未来。是的，这太疯狂了。与过去不同，现在媒体也给了那些被摩西攻击的人一个回应的机会。而这次对范妮·赫斯特的攻击真的被认为太过分了，你知道的。是的。哦，你知道吗？我刚意识到我一直说关于“留胡子的警官”的下一章，但实际上是下下章。
That's okay. So my apologies. Later in the episode. And Moses realizes that if this case keeps going through the court, then there's gonna be a discovery of other statements he's made, other sweetheart deals he's made. He's gonna have to testify about these things. That would be bad. He can't be in court testifying about this stuff
没关系。所以我道歉。在这一集的后面。摩西意识到，如果这个案件继续在法庭上进行，那么他所做的其他陈述、他所做的其他私下交易将会被发现。他将不得不就这些事情作证。那会很糟糕。他不能在法庭上就这些事情作证
because then he's on the record, he can't play games about it. So he does what he almost never does. He does something that is anathema to him. Roman, what does he do in terms of building this parking lot? What does he do? Yeah, well, he gives up. I mean, yeah, I mean, it's kind of amazing.
因为那样他就有了记录，他就不能在这些事情上玩花招了。所以他做了他几乎从不做的事情。他做了一件他深恶痛绝的事情。罗曼，在建造这个停车场方面他做了什么？他做了什么？是的，好吧，他放弃了。我的意思是，是的，我的意思是，这有点令人惊讶。
Like, you know, he just, yeah, he doesn't go through with it, which is amazing. He just backs down. He does it. He tries to do as quietly as possible. He has these delaying motions for the lawsuit. And then when the media dies down a little, he kind of agrees to give in
就像，你知道，他只是，是的，他没有坚持到底，这很令人惊讶。他只是退缩了。他做到了。他尽量悄悄地做。他为诉讼提出了延期动议。然后当媒体稍微平息下来时，他有点同意让步
so that it doesn't seem in his eyes as such a big loss. And he agrees to build a playground in that spot where the parking lot would have been. And now, Roman, I did a little on the ground investigating for this part of the episode. Well, I was preparing for this episode. We had our event at the New York Historical Society where we talked to Robert Caro on stage.
这样在他看来就不会显得损失那么大。他同意在原本是停车场的地方建一个游乐场。现在，罗曼，我为这一集的这一部分做了一些实地调查。好吧，我当时正在为这一集做准备。我们在纽约历史学会举办了活动，我们在舞台上采访了罗伯特·卡罗。
It was amazing. When people hear the audio from it, they will hear me noticeably run out of words. I'm so emotional at the end of it. Like, I'm so... When we were... It was an experience I'll carry with me in my heart for the rest of my life.
太棒了。当人们听到那段音频时，他们会听到我明显地词穷了。我在最后非常激动。就像，我太……当我们……那是我余生都会铭记在心的经历。
But beforehand, I decided to do a little Caro-style investigating, and I walked over to that part of the park, because it's very close to the Historical Society, and I wanted to be on the scene. I said, what would Robert Carra do? He would go and be in the space. And I walked around to those playgrounds
但在此之前，我决定做一点卡罗式的调查，我走到公园的那一部分，因为它离历史学会很近，我想身临其境。我说，罗伯特·卡罗会怎么做？他会去那个空间。我走到那些游乐场
that they put in, which are still there, which are definitely not as nice as a grove of trees would be. Like, they're okay. They're okay playgrounds. And I went down to Tavern on the Green, and that parking circle is still there, where cars can drop people off.
他们安装的那些游乐场还在那里，它们绝对没有树林那么好。就像，它们还可以。它们是还可以的游乐场。我走到“绿地酒馆”，那个停车场圆环还在那里，汽车可以在那里让人下车。
And when you look at it, it feels like someone came along and took a bite out of the park and just left pavement behind. It really feels like the outside world of the city has invaded briefly and been pushed back, but has left an emptiness, a void behind. And so to imagine that parking lot
当你看着它时，感觉就像有人过来从公园里咬了一口，只留下了路面。它真的让人感觉城市的外部世界短暂地入侵并被推了回去，但留下了一片空虚，一个空白。所以想象一下那个停车场
in the area where those playgrounds are, it would have been a very noticeable chunk taken out of the park. And it's an enormous park, but walking around, you're like, yeah, this would have had an effect. It would have had a real effect on the people who lived in that neighborhood. And it feels like something would have been torn out of it.
在那些游乐场所在的区域，那将是公园里非常显眼的一块。这是一个巨大的公园，但走来走去，你会觉得，是的，这会有影响。这对住在那个社区的人来说会有真正的影响。感觉就像有什么东西被从里面撕掉了一样。
And for what? For a parking lot, for a restaurant? That is like, I looked at the prices on the menu and I was like, this is an overpriced restaurant. Like the prices have kept kept up with inflation, let's say, you know, it's still an expensive hamburger. So no, thanks. That's what I say to that parking lot. Yeah, it's one of those things where he just he just kind of there was a plan he dug in. He made it had some, you know, friendly conversations with the proprietor of the restaurant or something like that to make it all make sense
为了什么？为了一个停车场，为了一个餐馆？那就像，我看了菜单上的价格，我想，这是一家价格过高的餐馆。就像价格跟上了通货膨胀，比如说，你知道，这仍然是一个昂贵的汉堡。所以不，谢谢。这就是我对那个停车场说的话。是的，这是那种他只是，他只是有点，有一个计划，他坚持了下来。他让它，你知道，与餐馆老板进行了一些友好的交谈，或者类似的事情，让这一切在当时说得通
at the time. But like, I mean, it's kind of amazing because this is not a thing to, like not a great hill to die on for him. You know, like it doesn't make any sense. It's such a small thing. And what's notable is that at a certain point, he perceived that as well.
但就像，我的意思是，这有点令人惊讶，因为这不是一件，就像不是一个值得他为之牺牲的伟大山头。你知道，就像这根本说不通。这是一件如此小的事情。值得注意的是，在某个时刻，他也意识到了这一点。
Because that's the new sort of behavior with him. So you just realize like, there is no reason to take this much damage for this parking lot. And it's chipped away at his reputation in a number of ways. And it's such a tiny hill for this to happen on, but Moses, his hope was nobody's going to notice that I gave in and lost this battle. But it gets big media attention, and Kara talks about the effect of that. He says, the aura of infallibility was gone also. He's talking about some other stuff that was gone,
因为那是他的一种新行为。所以你只是意识到，没有理由为了这个停车场承受这么大的损害。它在很多方面削弱了他的声誉。这是一个如此微小的山头，却发生了这样的事，但摩西的希望是没人会注意到我让步并输掉了这场战斗。但它引起了媒体的极大关注，卡罗谈到了这一点的影响。他说，不可战胜的光环也消失了。他谈到了一些其他消失的东西，
but the aura of infallibility was gone also. If Moses was the man who got things done, implicit was the assumption that the things that he got done were things that should be gotten done. He had always been portrayed as a man who was right. Now, in a single dramatic tableau he had been shown to be utterly unmistakably wrong. This idea that he's not a guy who can always get things done. He's not a guy who is incorruptible. Look at this sweetheart
但不可战胜的光环也消失了。如果摩西是那个能把事情办成的人，隐含的假设就是他办成的事情是应该办成的事情。他一直被描绘成一个正确的人。现在，在一幅戏剧性的画面中，他被证明是完全、毫无疑问地错了。这种认为他不是一个总能把事情办成的人的想法。他不是一个不可腐蚀的人。看看这个私下
deal. And he's not infallible. That he is not someone that you don't dare go up against because you're always going to lose. All these things have been removed from his reputation by this, again, kind of a trivial thing that like to give a parking lot to a restaurant, which of all the things he's done is not, by far not the worst, and not something you would even expect him to stick so on. And you all kind of have to wonder,
交易。而且他不是不可战胜的。他不是那种你不敢对抗的人，因为你总是会输。所有这些东西都被这件事从他的声誉中移除了，再说一次，这是一件琐碎的事情，比如给一家餐馆一个停车场，在他所做的所有事情中，这远不是最糟糕的，也不是你会期望他如此坚持的事情。你不得不怀疑，
maybe if he hadn't gone on that vacation to Spain, he would have wriggled out of it in some more face-saving way, I don't know. Right, right, right. But what this does is it starts this cycle of fights in which Robert Moses does not win, and also where Robert Moses is the bad guy. And what's really notable is that there begins to be
也许如果他没有去西班牙度假，他会以某种更保全面子的方式摆脱它，我不知道。对，对，对。但这开启了这场战斗的循环，罗伯特·摩西没有赢，而且罗伯特·摩西是坏人。真正值得注意的是，开始出现
like a group of newspaper reporters who were not alive or at least sentient during those time periods where Robert Moses would destroy a newspaper man's life pretty easily. And so they start seeing that there's some stories here and they start acting. And that's what the next chapter is about. It's called Late Arrival. We'll get to that after the break.
一群报社记者，他们在罗伯特·摩西可以很容易地摧毁一个报社记者的生活的那段时间里，要么还没出生，要么至少还没有知觉。所以他们开始看到这里有一些故事，他们开始行动了。这就是下一章的内容。它叫“迟来的到达”。休息后我们会讲到。
So this is chapter 43, Late Arrival, which is like a little rude. You know? Ha! Ha ha ha ha ha! It's just that Carol's like, I've been writing about this this whole time. What about you guys? But I think he's talking about,
所以这是第43章，“迟来的到达”，这有点粗鲁。你知道吗？哈！哈哈哈哈！只是卡罗说，我一直都在写这个。你们呢？但我认为他在谈论，
I think he's not talking about the reporters who are the focus so much as the editors maybe. He really is. The powers that be that run these newspapers, finally they start to see that criticizing Moses and telling these stories that are very compelling to the news reading public is worth it. And it takes a lot of work to get them to that point. And the work of a group of reporters that Carol Riegel and I have, to the news reading public is like, you know, it's worth it. And it takes a lot of work to get them to that point
我认为他谈论的不是那些作为焦点的记者，而是编辑们。他确实是。经营这些报纸的当权者，终于开始看到批评摩西并讲述这些对新闻阅读公众非常有吸引力的故事是值得的。让他们达到这一点需要做很多工作。而一群记者的工作，卡罗·里格尔和我，对新闻阅读公众来说就像，你知道，这是值得的。让他们达到这一点需要做很多工作
and the work of a group of reporters that Carol really has a lot of fun writing about. I think he feels a real kinship with these characters and real, and admires them. He starts the chapter with a incredibly prescient quote from Robert Moses. One of these quotes where it's like, it's super ironic, so he makes use of it a lot.
而一群记者的工作，卡罗真的很喜欢写他们。我认为他与这些角色有一种真正的亲缘关系，并且真的很钦佩他们。他以罗伯特·摩西的一句极具预见性的名言开始了这一章。这些名言之一，就像，它超级讽刺，所以他经常使用它。
So 1933 and Robert Moses talking about another New York politician who was having his comeuppance. He says, the great statesman McKee is a synthetic character which never actually existed on sea or land, puffed up by the press, dot, dot, dot. And now in the process of deflation, there's a large amount of unfairness to the individual in this process, but in the end, it arrives at the truth. And it's like, as if 25 or so years earlier, 23 years earlier, he's writing his own epitaph, you know, which is amazing. It's very prescient. It just happens sometimes, you know, history rhymes or whatever.
所以1933年，罗伯特·摩西谈论另一位正在遭受报应的纽约政治家。他说，伟大的政治家麦基是一个在海上或陆地上从未真正存在过的合成角色，被媒体吹捧，点点点。现在正处于通货紧缩的过程中，这个过程中对个人有很大的不公平，但最终，它会得出真相。这就像，好像25年左右前，23年前，他正在写自己的墓志铭，你知道，这很神奇。这非常有预见性。这只是有时会发生，你知道，历史会押韵什么的。
So we're introduced to some characters here. And one of them, one of the main ones here is this reporter for the World Telegram and Sun. Again, a newspaper that does not exist anymore. I always wonder if it's like, did the Telegram newspaper and the Sun newspaper merge and then the World newspaper merged with that one? A lot of these read like magnetic fridge poetry.
所以我们在这里介绍了一些角色。其中一个，这里的主要角色之一是《世界电讯报和太阳报》的记者。同样，一份已经不存在的报纸。我总是想知道它是否像，电讯报和太阳报合并了，然后世界报与那一份合并了？很多这些读起来就像磁性冰箱诗歌。
You know, there's like World Telegram, Herald, Times, you know, there's, there's like, there's like world telegram, herald times, you know, and then, and then they just throw them up and rearrange them over time. So yeah, I love it, yeah. And so this reporter, Gene Gleason, he says to his editors, I want to investigate Robert Moses, cause I'm sure that there's other fishy stuff,
你知道，有像世界电讯报、先驱报、时报，你知道，有像世界电讯报、先驱报、时报，你知道，然后，然后他们只是把它们扔起来，随着时间的推移重新排列它们。所以是的，我喜欢它，是的。所以这个记者，吉恩·格里森，他对他的编辑说，我想调查罗伯特·摩西，因为我肯定还有其他可疑的事情，
that the tavern on the green contract is not the only fishy thing about Robert Moses. And normally his editors would say no. But the Battle of Central Park has inspired them to say, like, okay, I'll allow it. His editor says, I'll allow it. And Gleason wants to start investigating the power of public authorities.
绿地酒馆的合同并不是关于罗伯特·摩西唯一可疑的事情。通常他的编辑会说不。但中央公园之战激励了他们说，好吧，我允许。他的编辑说，我允许。格里森想开始调查公共当局的权力。
But unfortunately, no groundwork's been done on that story before because the records are inaccessible. You can't get them, there's nowhere to start. But a little groundwork has already been done on the Manhattan Town Public Housing Project. And so Gleason is like, okay, I think there's potential. There's something for me to work off of. And he starts working with one of the rewrite men at the newspaper. And I apologize to call him a rewrite man, but they're all, all the reporters pretty much are men at this point.
但不幸的是，之前没有为那个故事做任何基础工作，因为记录是无法获取的。你拿不到它们，没有地方可以开始。但曼哈顿镇公共住房项目已经做了一些基础工作。所以格里森觉得，好吧，我认为有潜力。有一些东西可以让我利用。他开始与报社的一名改写员合作。我为称他为改写员道歉，但此时几乎所有的记者都是男性。
The, you know, not again, not for fair reasons, not because the men were just doing such a bang up job reporting, you know. And so he works with this rewriter, Fred J. Cook. And I think what's interesting here is I forget how a newspaper works in this way, where there's often this delegation of abilities between the person who is out doing the investigative work and the person that you call it into at the office who does the actual kind of writing of the article. And they work together so well on this,
你知道，不是因为公平的原因，不是因为男人们在报道方面做得那么出色，你知道。所以他与这位改写员弗雷德·J·库克合作。我认为这里有趣的是，我忘记了报纸是如何以这种方式运作的，通常在负责调查工作的人和你在办公室里打电话给的人之间有这种能力的分工，后者负责文章的实际写作。他们在这方面合作得非常好，
but it's just a reminder to me of like, oh, Robert Carroll could have written a whole book about how newspapers work, and it would have been fascinating. There's just so much I don't know about it. But they start putting together a series of articles that don't discover new things so much as they assemble all the known facts about Manhattan town
但这只是提醒我，哦，罗伯特·卡罗本可以写一整本书关于报纸是如何运作的，那会非常迷人。关于它我还有很多不知道的地方。但他们开始整理一系列文章，与其说发现了新东西，不如说他们第一次把关于曼哈顿镇的所有已知事实汇集在一起。
in one place for the first time. And the facts show that Moses' slum clearance program is clearing out functioning neighborhoods and replacing them with nothing. You know, just unfinished projects or slums. And they haven't found the corruption in the program yet, but they do make it clear that the program is making housing worse. It is not improving the problem. And most importantly, rather than blaming the city, in quotes, they name Moses and they put the blame on him. And so in a movie, this would be front page news.
事实表明，摩西的贫民窟清理计划正在清理功能正常的社区，并用虚无取而代之。你知道，只是未完成的项目或贫民窟。他们还没有发现该计划中的腐败，但他们确实清楚地表明该计划正在使住房变得更糟。它并没有改善问题。最重要的是，他们没有指责“城市”，而是点名摩西，并将责任归咎于他。所以在电影里，这会是头版新闻。
It would crack the case. Suddenly everyone be investigating Moses. Is that what happens, Roman? No, that's not what happens at all. It's also one of those things where the story is just so complicated, you know? Yes. And it involves lots of different people and maybe those people, their victimization isn't as compelling to newspaper readers, you know? It's just one of those things that doesn't quite
这会破案。突然每个人都会调查摩西。是这样吗，罗曼？不，根本不是那样。这也是那种故事太复杂的事情之一，你知道吗？是的。它涉及许多不同的人，也许那些人，他们的受害对报纸读者来说并不那么引人注目，你知道吗？这只是那种不太
have the traction that these sort of park fights do. I mean, because the other one that we're gonna talk about next chapter is another kind of low stakes park fight. But- Oh, it's the lowest stakes park fight. It's incredible, and it's basically over a misunderstanding, you know, more than anything else. But yeah, this one doesn't quite stick
有吸引力的东西，不像这些公园之战。我的意思是，因为我们要谈论的另一个下一章是另一种低风险的公园之战。但是——哦，这是风险最低的公园之战。这太不可思议了，而且它基本上是因为误解，你知道，比任何其他事情都多。但是是的，这一个不太能坚持下去
because it has the same kind of issues of all this stuff. But I mean, like, this is a very classic corruption that they uncover, like developers siphoned off money and then the story just gets buried. It's not interesting to people. They put it on the back pages of the paper and the editors are still afraid enough of Moses that they would tell him about it ahead of time
因为它有所有这些东西的同样的问题。但我的意思是，就像，这是他们揭露的一种非常经典的腐败，比如开发商挪用资金，然后故事就被埋没了。这对人们来说不感兴趣。他们把它放在报纸的后页，编辑们仍然足够害怕摩西，以至于他们会提前告诉他
and they provide space in the paper for him to have a rebuttal where he attacks the paper's own story. Right. And they don't put Moses' name in the headlines. And something that I think we've only become more familiar with in modern times is often people just look at the headlines. Yeah.
并且他们在报纸上为他提供空间进行反驳，在那里他攻击报纸自己的故事。对。而且他们没有把摩西的名字放在标题里。我认为我们现代人越来越熟悉的一件事是，人们通常只看标题。是的。
They don't read the article. And the way you, this is something that James Fallows writes about, is that a headline frames a story in a way that tells the reader what the main information is. And so the headline can be vastly not unrepresentative of the actual story, but the headline is what's going to stick with people. So if Moses' name is not in the headline, people are not going to think it. But one story leads to another. And there's this domino effect that Caro talks about where he says,
他们不读文章。詹姆斯·法洛斯写过的一件事是，标题以一种告诉读者主要信息是什么的方式构建故事。所以标题可能与实际故事大相径庭，但标题是人们会记住的东西。所以如果摩西的名字不在标题里，人们就不会想到它。但一个故事引出另一个故事。卡罗谈到了这种多米诺骨牌效应，他说，
Investigative reporters quickly become aware of a phenomenon of their profession. Information so hard to come by when they are preparing to write their first story in a new field suddenly becomes plentiful as soon as that first story has appeared in print. Every city agency has its malcontents and its idealists and its malcontent idealists, which is a, I love that. That is such a great way to say it.
调查记者很快就会意识到他们职业的一种现象。当他们准备在新的领域写第一篇报道时，信息很难获得，但一旦第一篇报道出现在印刷品上，信息就会突然变得丰富起来。每个城市机构都有它的不满者和理想主义者，以及不满的理想主义者，这是一个，我喜欢那个。这真是一个很好的说法。
Officials and aides and clerks and secretaries unhappy with the philosophy by which it is being run or the payoffs that are being made within it who have been just waiting for years for the appearance of some forum in which their feelings can be expressed. And so once these first articles come out, even though they're in the back, Gleason and Cook's phones start ringing. People are coming out of the woodwork to complain about Moses and suddenly there are lots of leads for them to continue this investigation and dig deeper. Of course, everyone is afraid of Moses so it all has to be off the record and a source
官员、助手、职员和秘书，对它的运作哲学或其中进行的贿赂感到不满，他们多年来一直等待着某种可以表达他们感受的论坛的出现。所以一旦这些第一批文章出来，即使它们在后面，格里森和库克的电话也开始响了。人们纷纷出来抱怨摩西，突然间他们有了很多线索来继续这项调查并深入挖掘。当然，每个人都害怕摩西，所以这一切都必须是非正式的，而审计长办公室的一个消息来源
in the Comptroller's Office reveals how the developers are milking their housing developments for millions while leaving tenants without heat. They're not paying taxes to the city for years and again these stories don't get that much play. They're complicated in a lot of ways. They involve names and numbers. If other papers mention them, it's usually just to run Moses' denials.
揭露了开发商是如何榨取他们的住房开发项目数百万美元，同时让租户没有暖气。他们多年来没有向城市缴纳税款，同样，这些故事并没有得到太多的报道。它们在很多方面都很复杂。它们涉及名字和数字。如果其他报纸提到它们，通常也只是为了刊登摩西的否认。
And the New York Times is still carrying Moses' water for him. Like they're still not ready. They did disagree about the parking lot, but they're not ready to turn on him completely. And then in June, 1957, it comes out that the Manhattan town developers have siphoned off so much money
而《纽约时报》仍然在为摩西效劳。就像他们还没准备好。他们确实在停车场问题上表示不同意，但他们还没准备好完全背叛他。然后在1957年6月，有消息称曼哈顿镇的开发商挪用了太多的钱
that they have none left to pay their taxes or their mortgage or build any of the buildings they've contracted to build. And the city will have to foreclose on this development. This is a city project that was given to developers. The city will now have to foreclose on and the Times buries this story, but the other papers don't. And Gleason gets Mayor Wagner to say at a press conference that he was conned for five years by these developers and that's a big thing.
以至于他们没有钱缴纳税款或抵押贷款，也没有钱建造他们签约建造的任何建筑。城市将不得不对这个开发项目进行止赎。这是一个交给开发商的城市项目。城市现在将不得不止赎，而《时报》埋没了这个故事，但其他报纸没有。格里森让市长瓦格纳在新闻发布会上说，他被这些开发商骗了五年，这是一件大事。
Yeah, yeah. I mean and this is like the tone of these newsrooms is changing a lot and the older reporters who used to criticize some of these upstarts for questioning the powers that be in the city are now like doing follow-up questions where they ask it. And it's beginning to become clear that this sort of rich diversity of different newspapers is helping the situation now. If the Times isn't going to do it, someone else is going to cover it. And therefore, this is the whole point of having an active and vibrant press, really. It's kind of amazing.
是的，是的。我的意思是，这些新闻编辑室的基调正在发生很大变化，那些过去常常批评一些后起之秀质疑城市当权者的老记者现在正在做后续提问，询问它。而且越来越清楚的是，这种不同报纸的丰富多样性现在正在帮助改善这种情况。如果《时报》不这样做，其他人也会报道。因此，这就是拥有一个活跃和充满活力的媒体的全部意义所在，真的。这有点令人惊讶。
Aaron Ross Powell And Gleason and Cook, once again, they fall prey to the great liberal myth that once you get the information out there, the system will do its job and people will get mad or they'll change their minds. It'll be great. They're like, Moses is going to get his comeuppance now. He's going to have his wings clipped by the mayor. But they don't understand how central Moses has become to the actual invisible machinery of the city. And so Kara says, the two reporters' expectation was not unreasonable. Ordinarily, the tainting of a city program was scandal and failure, scandal of immense proportions, failure five years in duration, would result in at least curtailment of the powers of the mayoral subordinate heading that program, lest the public
亚伦·罗斯·鲍威尔：格里森和库克再次沦为伟大的自由主义神话的牺牲品，即一旦你把信息发布出去，系统就会发挥作用，人们就会生气，或者他们会改变主意。那会很棒。他们就像，摩西现在要得到报应了。他的翅膀要被市长剪掉了。但他们不明白摩西已经变得多么核心于城市实际的隐形机器。所以卡罗说，这两位记者的期望并非不合理。通常，城市项目的玷污是丑闻和失败，巨大比例的丑闻，持续五年的失败，会导致至少削减领导该项目的市长下属的权力，以免公众
outcry turn against the mayor. Their expectation was just based on a false premise that Robert Moses was really the mayor's subordinate. They did not understand that as a matter of practical politics, the mayor could not discipline, demote or remove Title I's administrator, and so they were surprised at ensuing developments. And those developments are that a spokesman of Moses' announces that new developers are coming in to take over Manhattan Town. They're not going to have foreclosure hearings.
的抗议转向市长。他们的期望只是基于一个错误的假设，即罗伯特·摩西真的是市长的下属。他们不明白，从实际政治的角度来看，市长无法纪律处分、降职或撤换第一章的管理者，所以他们对随后的发展感到惊讶。而这些发展是摩西的发言人宣布新的开发商将进来接管曼哈顿镇。他们不会有止赎听证会。
The old developers will have no penalties. In fact, the two principal stockholders of the mismanaged Manhattan Town, Inc. are going to be kept on the payroll as consultants. They're actually going to have their stock bought out from them and they're going to remain stockholders in the new development. So these guys who cheated the city out of millions, they're going to keep making money off of it. And there's an outcry and the
旧的开发商将不会受到任何惩罚。事实上，管理不善的曼哈顿镇公司的两个主要股东将被保留在工资单上作为顾问。他们实际上将把他们的股票买断，他们将继续作为新开发项目的股东。所以这些欺骗了城市数百万美元的家伙，他们将继续从中赚钱。而且有抗议，而
mayor's like, all right, I'll take action. I will cut off some of the money those developers would receive. They're still going to be rewarded for their failure. They're just not getting as much reward. And Gleeson and Cooke are like, we did all this work and all we managed to do was get more money
市长说，好吧，我会采取行动。我将削减那些开发商本可以收到的一些钱。他们仍然会因为他们的失败而得到奖励。他们只是没有得到那么多的奖励。而格里森和库克就像，我们做了所有这些工作，我们所能做的只是给坏人更多的钱
to the bad guys. And Moses has not really been affected at all. And Moses has big plans at this point. He's planning this new vision of Manhattan's West side, Lincoln Center, which involves raising, not raising like raising up, but raising is like raising to the ground. You know, R-A-Z. Like a razor shaving.
而摩西根本没有受到任何影响。而且摩西此时有宏大的计划。他正在规划曼哈顿西区的新愿景，林肯中心，这涉及夷平，不是像筹集资金那样的筹集，而是夷平就像夷为平地。你知道，R-A-Z。就像剃刀刮胡子。
Yeah, exactly. Oh, they probably come from the same group. I never even thought about that. Roman, you're so smart. Come on. You're as smart as the empire that bears your name. They're gonna raise 18 square blocks
是的，完全正确。哦，它们可能来自同一个词根。我从来没想过那个。罗曼，你太聪明了。来吧。你和以你名字命名的帝国一样聪明。他们要夷平18个街区
and they're replacing them with Lincoln Center, the Metropolitan Opera, the New York Philharmonic, the New York Ballet, the High School of Performing Arts, Juilliard, Fordham University's new campus. The newspapers are like, they love this plan. It's gonna displace 7,000 low-income families and replace their homes with 4,000 luxury apartments, but the newspapers love it.. It's going to displace 7,000 low-income families and replace their homes with 4,000 luxury apartments, but the newspapers love it.
他们要用林肯中心、大都会歌剧院、纽约爱乐乐团、纽约芭蕾舞团、表演艺术高中、朱利亚德学院、福特汉姆大学的新校区来取代它们。报纸就像，他们喜欢这个计划。它将流离失所7000个低收入家庭，并用4000套豪华公寓取代他们的家园，但报纸喜欢它。它将流离失所7000个低收入家庭，并用4000套豪华公寓取代他们的家园，但报纸喜欢它。
And Roman, I want to hear you say, but then I have, I have a thing I want to say about Lincoln Center. So here's the thing. It's not better than 7,000 homes for people who can afford it, but Lincoln Center is pretty great. It is. I, I, that was what I was going to say in all disclosure. I have spent so many memorable hours
罗曼，我想听你说，但我有一个，我有一件事想说关于林肯中心。所以事情是这样的。它并不比7000个负担得起的人的家更好，但林肯中心相当棒。确实。我，我，这就是我本来要说的，完全披露。我度过了许多难忘的时光
and beloved hours of my life at Lincoln Center. Some of my happiest memories of experiencing culture and art have taken place there. It's a place that is, it's inextricably tied in with my memories of my grandmother, who I spent many, many hours with there. And so it's, when I think about her, I think about Lincoln center. I was in New York for that event and I walked by Lincoln center twice.
以及我生命中珍爱的时光在林肯中心。我体验文化和艺术的一些最快乐的记忆都发生在那里。这是一个地方，它与我祖母的记忆紧密相连，我和她在那里度过了许多许多小时。所以，当我想到她时，我就想到林肯中心。我当时在纽约参加那个活动，我两次经过林肯中心。
And each time I was just flooded with, with these feelings, it's a, it's a really, it's a magical place, but again, you don't want to kick out 7,000 people. No, or, or if you do these big plans, you have to take care of them. And he never did that sort of thing. Um, but, but like, you know, you see movies in the park there in the summertime, you know, like, I've watched people dance to San Francisco's there. You know, like, it's, and it has all these cultural,
每次我都沉浸在，沉浸在这些感觉中，这是一个，这是一个非常神奇的地方，但再说一次，你不想赶走7000人。不，或者，或者如果你做这些大计划，你必须照顾他们。他从来没有做过那种事。嗯，但是，但是就像，你知道，你在夏天在那里看公园里的电影，你知道，就像，我看过人们在那里跳旧金山的舞。你知道，就像，它有所有这些文化，
like, as a center of culture, it's kind of stunning how concentrated it all is at this like place. And anyway, it's just one of those ones like, I mean, Jones Beach didn't have anything that it was knocking down, so therefore it's kind of this unalloyed good, and this one plenty alloyed, I guess.
就像作为一个文化中心，它集中在这个地方是多么令人震惊。总之，它只是那种之一，就像，我的意思是，琼斯海滩没有任何它要拆除的东西，所以因此它是一种纯粹的好处，而这一个合金很多，我想。
But Lincoln Center is pretty awesome, I think. Yes, it's a, I mean, I feel a little about it like I felt like when I visited Versailles years ago, where I was like, they could have fed so many people with the money it took to build this house, but those people would still be dead now and the house is still here. So like, I wouldn't, I'm going to get to
但林肯中心相当棒，我想。是的，它是一个，我的意思是，我对此的感觉有点像我几年前参观凡尔赛宫时的感觉，当时我想，他们本可以用建造这座房子的钱养活那么多人，但那些人现在仍然会死，而房子仍然在这里。所以就像，我不会，我要去
enjoy the house. Like that's, so it's, and like you're saying, the people that were displaced should have been taken care of, should have been accounted for, maybe should have had a say in the, in the process, you know? Yeah, absolutely. But it is, it is hard not to feel as a New
享受这座房子。就像那是，所以它是，而且就像你说的，流离失所的人应该得到照顾，应该被考虑到，也许应该在，在过程中有发言权，你知道吗？是的，绝对。但它确实是，作为纽约人很难不感到，
Yorker, like a certain amount of pride in this, that there's this space where you can, I mean, if they were all scheduled on the same day, you could go to the opera, then go to the ballet, then hear the Philharmonic, then look at the fountain where they shot that scene and the producers, you know? Like, I've seen so many things there that were amazing. It just, but it's hard to know that while you're there,
某种自豪感，在这个空间里，你可以，我的意思是，如果它们都在同一天安排，你可以去歌剧院，然后去芭蕾舞团，然后听爱乐乐团，然后看喷泉，他们在那里拍摄了那个场景和制片人，你知道吗？就像，我在那里看过很多令人惊叹的东西。只是，但很难知道当你身处那里时，
so many people's homes were taken from them to make it possible. But you could argue, I mean, it's hard to know that while you're there, so many people's homes were taken from them to make it possible. You could argue, I mean, it's a little different, but it's sort of in the same philosophy that the existence of Central Park, even though it doesn't knock down homes, its existence does deny a lot of spaces where homes could be built to make life
这么多人的家园被从他们手中夺走以使它成为可能。但你可以争辩，我的意思是，很难知道当你身处那里时，这么多人的家园被从他们手中夺走以使它成为可能。你可以争辩，我的意思是，它有点不同，但它在某种程度上与中央公园的存在是同样的哲学，即使它没有拆除房屋，它的存在确实否定了许多可以建造房屋的空间，使生活
more affordable in Manhattan. And that's a choice that we make, and I think it's a good choice that is made where homes could be built to make life more affordable in Manhattan. And that's a choice that we make. And I think it's a good choice that is made on behalf of the citizens of New York. But it's one of those things, it does matter that there was something there ahead of time. I'm not just being, I'm not trying to just like abstract this to the point
在曼哈顿更负担得起。这是一个我们做出的选择，我认为这是一个代表纽约市民做出的好选择。但它是那种事情之一，它确实很重要，因为那里提前有一些东西。我不是只是，我不是试图只是像把这个抽象到
of having just a philosophical discussion where people mean nothing. But there is a cost when it comes to like, things take place in physical space. And if you have one thing, you don't have another. And this is one of those ones where at least the end product I think was executed in a interesting and valuable, like that was an interesting valuable thing was made.
进行哲学讨论的地步，在那里人们毫无意义。但当涉及到像，事情发生在物理空间时，是有成本的。如果你有一件事，你就没有另一件事。这是那种之一，至少最终产品我认为是以一种有趣且有价值的方式执行的，就像那是一个有趣且有价值的东西被制造出来了。
I cannot say that about the Cross Bronx Expressway. No, I certainly, I have no loving memories of the Cross Bronx Expressway at all. You know, whereas Lincoln center is a place that, like I said, I have such a, I have such a personal relationship with, I can't be impartial about it. But you're right that I think it gets to, it gets to the heart of what so much of what Carol is saying, that everything is a choice, everything in governance and how you run a city is a choice and choosing to keep Central Park a park means effectively raising the price of housing for everyone who lives in the city, a
我不能对跨布朗士高速公路说同样的话。不，我当然，我对跨布朗士高速公路根本没有任何美好的回忆。你知道，而林肯中心是一个地方，就像我说的，我有一个如此的，我有一个如此个人的关系，我不能对此保持公正。但你是对的，我认为它触及了卡罗所说的大部分内容的核心，即一切都是选择，治理和经营城市的一切都是选择，选择保持中央公园作为一个公园意味着有效地提高了住在城市里的每个人的住房价格，一定
certain amount. And that was an easy choice to make when the city was half or not even a quarter built and you still had farm estates up in what would become, you know, 125th street. Yeah. But it's, it is a choice that they make and you're true that you're right that it's a, there are those choices.
数量。当城市只有一半甚至不到四分之一建成时，这是一个容易做出的选择，你仍然有农场庄园在后来成为，你知道，125街的地方。是的。但它，这是一个他们做出的选择，你是对的，这是一个，有那些选择。
What is not the best way to do it though with Lincoln Center is the things that the papers didn't dig into in their enthusiasm for the news project. So how Moses is selling the land involved to developers at discount prices, how he's paying politically connected landowners like the Kennedys above market purchase prices. Like seven times as much. Yes, like a lot more money. The federal administrator for Title I funds, Albert M. Cole, he thinks this is the moment to demand Moses answer for his kind of slipshot and misleading way of administering title one projects and he threatens to cut off all of title ones
不过，林肯中心并不是最好的做法是报纸在对新闻项目的热情中没有深入挖掘的事情。所以摩西是如何以折扣价将涉及的土地卖给开发商的，他是如何向政治上有联系的土地所有者（如肯尼迪家族）支付高于市场购买价格的。就像七倍那么多。是的，就像更多的钱。第一章资金的联邦管理者，阿尔伯特·M·科尔，他认为这是要求摩西为他那种草率和误导性的管理第一章项目的方式负责的时刻，他威胁要切断所有第一章的
funds to the city if Moses doesn't change his ways and Moses threatens to resign and within an hour Mayor Wagner is backing him publicly and the papers rushed to back up Moses against the federal government just like when Roosevelt tried to get him fired and Moses calls his powerful friends they call the White House and Cole has to back down. And Gleason and Cook, they start realizing Moses is still too powerful for the federal government to undercut him, let alone the city government, let alone regular people.
资金给城市，如果摩西不改变他的方式，摩西威胁要辞职，在一小时内市长瓦格纳就公开支持他，报纸争先恐后地支持摩西对抗联邦政府，就像罗斯福试图解雇他时一样，摩西打电话给他的权势朋友，他们打电话给白宫，科尔不得不退缩。而格里森和库克，他们开始意识到摩西仍然太强大，联邦政府无法削弱他，更不用说市政府，更不用说普通人了。
And this aura of incorruptibility, even though it's not all the way there, it's still strong enough that people will defend him against the federal government. And his infallibility has been disproven by the Central Park battle. But there's still this idea that he is a public servant above politics.
而这种不可腐蚀的光环，即使它没有完全存在，它仍然足够强大，以至于人们会为了他对抗联邦政府。而他的不可战胜性已经被中央公园之战所反驳。但仍然有一种想法，即他是一位超越政治的公务员。
He's not on the take. He doesn't get involved in petty political battles. And they realize it's gonna take a lot more work on behalf of reporters whose editors have invested a lot of years in the Moses myth to make a real difference. Moses has had such a relationship with top publishers, top editors that he can just take it for granted that they are going to believe in him. And Gleason and Cook find that their sources within city agencies after
他不参与贪污。他不参与琐碎的政治斗争。他们意识到，代表那些编辑在摩西神话中投入了多年时间的记者，需要做更多的工作才能产生真正的改变。摩西与顶级出版商、顶级编辑有这样的关系，以至于他可以认为他们会相信他。而格里森和库克发现，他们的城市机构内部的消息来源在
that first rush, they're newly paranoid. They don't want to talk about it, but they keep digging and they're able to start reporting the ties between local politicians and the slum clearance developers, the developers who get contracts. And by 1958, they can show that William S. Liebwohl, the director of Moses' Slum Clearance Committee is a stockholder in the Nassau Management Company, the real estate relocation firm that we talked about in a previous episode that has been paid millions to do essentially nothing, to help nobody. And they start finding more and more links between Moses' people and the companies
那第一波热潮之后，他们新产生了偏执。他们不想谈论它，但他们继续挖掘，他们能够开始报道当地政治家与贫民窟清理开发商之间的联系，那些获得合同的开发商。到1958年，他们可以证明摩西贫民窟清理委员会主任威廉·S·利布沃尔是拿骚管理公司的股东，那家我们在上一集中谈到的房地产搬迁公司，它被支付了数百万美元基本上什么都没做，没帮助任何人。他们开始发现摩西的人与公司之间越来越多的联系
being given contracts and local politicians. But at this point, Roman, you talked about how other reporters are gonna jump in. They're still not jumping in yet. Editors keep removing Moses' names from their articles. They keep pressuring them, do some other stories. These aren't too complicated. And Caro says the stories about corruption in these projects are being put on
被给予合同和当地政治家。但在这一点上，罗曼，你谈到了其他记者将如何加入。他们还没有加入。编辑们不断从他们的文章中删除摩西的名字。他们不断向他们施压，做一些其他的故事。这些并不太复杂。卡罗说关于这些项目中腐败的故事被放在
page 27. And the stories about how Moses has this great project he's building are on page one. And by 1959, the leads are really drying up. Moses is starting to get public works named after him, which is pretty out of the ordinary for a living person. And Gleason and Cook, they're like, we're going to pin him on Title I, on the Corruption, but I guess that's dead now, until they come up with their plan. And Caro says, to understand what Gleason and Cook did then, it is necessary to understand Gleason and Cook.
第27页。而关于摩西正在建造的这个伟大项目的故事在第一页。到1959年，线索真的枯竭了。摩西开始以他的名字命名公共工程，这对于一个活着的人来说是非常不寻常的。而格里森和库克，他们就像，我们要把第一章的腐败钉在他身上，但我猜那现在已经死了，直到他们想出他们的计划。卡罗说，要理解格里森和库克当时做了什么，有必要理解格里森和库克。
And you're like, I've been reading about these guys. Are you, now's when you're gonna tell me about them? And he just gives, he gets into their personalities. Gleason, he's that classic front page, his Girl Friday, hard drinking, fast talking reporter, dedicated to protecting the little guy, loves the thrill of it, the rush. And Cook is this unassuming guy,
而你就像，我一直在读关于这些家伙的内容。你是，现在是你告诉我关于他们的时候了吗？他只是进入，他进入了他们的个性。格里森，他是那个经典的头版，他的“星期五女郎”，酗酒，快言快语的记者，致力于保护小人物，喜欢那种刺激，那种冲动。而库克是一个谦逊的家伙，
but he's also a crusading liberal who wants to protect the little guy. And Carol mentions how Cook wrote a book defending Alger Hiss when Alger Hiss was, what is at his most priish, a stance that in 1974 seemed better, that it has aged poorly now considering Alger Hiss was at his most priish, a stance that in 1974 seemed better, that it has aged poorly now, considering Alger Hiss, I don't wanna reopen it,
但他也是一个十字军式的自由主义者，想要保护小人物。卡罗提到了库克是如何写一本书为阿尔杰·希斯辩护的，当阿尔杰·希斯是，什么是他最受争议的时候，一个在1974年看起来更好的立场，它现在已经老化得很差，考虑到阿尔杰·希斯是他最受争议的时候，一个在1974年看起来更好的立场，它现在已经老化得很差，考虑到阿尔杰·希斯，我不想重新打开它，
but he probably did what he was accused of doing. It is no longer a just taken for granted, if you're liberal, you love Alger Hiss and you wanna defend him. That's right. And for anyone listening who doesn't know that name, either look it up or don't worry about it. It's the kind of thing that like my grandparents
但他可能做了他被指控做的事情。如果是一个自由主义者，你爱阿尔杰·希斯并且你想为他辩护，这不再是一个理所当然的事情。那是对的。对于任何不知道那个名字的听众，要么查一下，要么不用担心。这是那种像我祖父母
took as just as took as gospel that Al Juhis had been railroaded. And Cook hates that Moses pushes people around and Carroll quotes him using the phrase, the power brokers to talk about Moses and the people around him, which is I think the first time the phrase really gets brought up in the mouth of somebody,
认为理所当然的事情，阿尔杰·希斯被冤枉了。而库克讨厌摩西推搡人们，卡罗引用他使用“权力掮客”这个词来谈论摩西和他周围的人，我认为这是这个词第一次真正出现在某人的嘴里，
maybe this is around the time it's getting born. I actually kind of wondered if this is where Carol gets the name of the book, like, because this is all reported, you know, obviously well before he's writing all this stuff. And if this is unlocking, I don't know, I don't know. The power broker is not a phrase I know besides coming from this book, really. I mean- I know it from this book, really? I mean-
也许这是它诞生的时间。我实际上有点怀疑这是否是卡罗得到书名的地方，就像，因为这一切都是报道的，你知道，显然在他写所有这些东西之前很久。如果这是解锁，我不知道，我不知道。权力掮客不是一个我除了来自这本书之外真正知道的词。我的意思是——我从这本书里知道它，真的？我的意思是——
I know it from this book, and I know it from the Marvel comic, Supervillain the Power Broker, who's the guy who gives people superpowers, yeah. But it seems to me like it's possible that, I mean, maybe it's just sort of like common parlance among people who write about politics and stuff, that there are power brokers and this and that,
我是从这本书里知道这个词的，也从漫威漫画里知道，超级反派“权力掮客”（Power Broker），就是那个赋予人们超能力的人，没错。但在我看来，这似乎有可能——我是说，也许这只是那些写政治评论之类的人常用的说法，说有什么权力掮客之类的，
and maybe it's just such super common of a phrase, but it shows up here and it's very notable to me. You know, like this is sort of a great moment in the book. It is the moment in the movie where someone says the title. He's like some kind of power broker and the audience goes, oh. And we've heard it from, we've heard the phrase used by Caro,
也许这只是一个非常常见的短语，但它在这里出现，对我来说非常引人注目。你知道，这就像书中的一个精彩瞬间。就像电影里有人说出片名那一刻。他就像某种权力掮客，观众会想，哦。我们已经听过卡罗（Caro）用过这个词，
but we haven't heard it used by a character in the story, you know, which is really great. But he doesn't make a lot out of it. He just has it in the quote. So it's done very subtly. And so Gleason Cook, the thing that he talks about here also is that they're competitive. All these reporters are competitive.
但我们还没听过故事里的角色用过它，你知道，这真的很棒。但他并没有过多渲染。他只是把它放在引语里。所以处理得非常微妙。格里森·库克（Gleason Cook）在这里谈到的另一件事是，他们之间存在竞争。所有这些记者都在竞争。
They want the credit. They want the glory of the big story. They want to beat the other papers. But they realize if their editors aren't supporting them, they're going to have to find a way around that. And the only way around that is to start colluding with the ultimate enemy, other reporters at other papers. And this is what I was hinting at earlier,
他们想要功劳。他们想要大新闻带来的荣耀。他们想打败其他报社。但他们意识到，如果编辑不支持他们，他们就得想办法绕过这一点。而唯一的办法就是开始与终极敌人——其他报社的记者——勾结。这就是我之前暗示的，
is this, I love this so much. Like this is the whole part. I mean, this is the best part of this chapter, which is essentially them coming to the conclusion that well, if every, if editor is going to bury it here, I can tip off this other person and we can begin to sort of trade parts of these stories. And they actually kind of, I mean, they really do collude.
我太喜欢这个了。这简直是整章最精彩的部分，本质上是他们得出了结论：好吧，如果编辑要在这里压下新闻，我可以给另一个人通风报信，我们可以开始交换这些报道的片段。他们实际上确实，我是说，他们真的勾结在一起了。
Like it's not just sort of like kind of allowing it to happen. Like they meet and decide what's going to happen. Yeah, they're meeting in bars and saying, you take this part of the story, and then after you run that, I'll do this part. Okay, and then you take this tip and you handle that. They are, I mean, it's like insider trading between reporters, but in a way that is,
这不仅仅是某种默许。他们会见面并决定接下来怎么做。是的，他们在酒吧里碰头，说：“你负责报道这部分，等你发了之后，我再做这部分。好的，然后你拿这个线索去处理那个。”我是说，这就像记者之间的内幕交易，但以一种，
there's nothing illegal about it, and it helps them. And Caro, every now and then he'll indulge in a kind of fanciful metaphor or description. And he has one here and he just says, soon like two flamenco dancers, spurring each other to wilder and wilder efforts, Haddad and Gleason were both helping and striving to outdo each other, their stories picking up and taking off from each other's and hitting harder and harder. I love that. I just love that they're comparing them to two flamenco dancers, you know,
这没什么违法的，而且对他们有帮助。卡罗偶尔会沉迷于某种奇特的隐喻或描述。他在这里就用了一个，他说：“很快，就像两名弗拉门戈舞者，互相激励着做出越来越狂野的动作，哈达德（Haddad）和格里森（Gleason）都在互相帮助，努力超越对方，他们的报道相互呼应、借力，冲击力越来越强。”我喜欢这个。我就是喜欢他把他们比作两名弗拉门戈舞者，你知道，
challenging each other. And they know that if their editors see a story about Title I corruption in another paper, they're going to want them to get on. It's like, you know, they are bringing the spice back into the relationship between their editors and this story by cheating with another paper, you know. And soon there's this circle of reporters that are trading tips and things to strategizing how to get this done. And Caro says about these reporters, like you said, Roman earlier, these are young people. They're mostly in their 20s and 30s. They're young enough that they are still idealistic, and they're also young enough that the Moses myth does not matter to them.
互相挑战。他们知道，如果他们的编辑在另一份报纸上看到关于“第一章”（Title I）腐败的报道，就会要求他们跟进。这就像，你知道，他们通过与其他报纸“出轨”，重新为编辑和这篇报道之间的关系注入了活力。很快，就形成了一个记者圈子，他们交换线索，策划如何完成报道。卡罗谈到这些记者时说，就像你之前说的，罗曼（Roman），他们都是年轻人。他们大多在二三十岁。他们足够年轻，依然怀有理想主义，而且他们足够年轻，以至于摩西（Moses）的神话对他们来说毫无意义。
They were babies when Jones Beach got built. They don't remember him as the hero of the working class and the liberal reformers. They know him as an old man, this stubborn old dictator who needs to be toppled, and they're also too young to remember or have felt the threat of Moses ending your career when his bloodhounds go after you.
琼斯海滩（Jones Beach）建成时他们还是婴儿。他们不记得他是工人阶级和自由派改革者的英雄。他们只知道他是一个固执的老独裁者，需要被推翻，而且他们太年轻了，不记得或没感受过摩西的“猎犬”追捕你时，他会毁掉你职业生涯的威胁。
They are fearlessly young and they're also like in the way that can help a young person kind of ignorant of history or the feeling of history in that what Moses means to them is what Moses is right now and not what he used to be. And Cairo, he like, you can't help but feel that he loves these guys, you know, he's just, these men and women and he glorifies them. And Caro, he like, you can't help but feel that he loves these guys, you know, he's just, and these men and women,
他们无所畏惧，而且在某种程度上，这种年轻让他们对历史或历史的沉重感有些无知，因为摩西对他们来说就是现在的摩西，而不是他过去的样子。卡罗，你忍不住会觉得他爱这些人，你知道，他只是，这些男人和女人，他美化了他们。卡罗，你忍不住会觉得他爱这些人，你知道，他只是，这些男人和女人，
and he glorifies them and he notes, oh, they're competitive, they want glory. That's not all, you know, just sterling heroism, you know, but he mostly attributes their actions to their need to see Moses get justice for pushing people around. And it's just, again, if you're making a movie of the power broker, don't do it, it's too big.
他美化了他们，并指出，哦，他们很有竞争心，他们想要荣耀。这不仅仅是纯粹的英雄主义，你知道，但他主要将他们的行为归因于他们需要看到摩西因为欺压他人而受到正义的审判。再说一次，如果你要拍一部关于“权力掮客”的电影，别拍，它太宏大了。
But this could be, this could be that movie. Yeah, this is the making a movie of the power broker, don't do it, it's too big, but this could be. This would be the moment. This could be that movie. Yeah, this is the real spotlight, having people spar with each other, trying to create the best story, meeting secretly, and it's just great. This is why the world progresses when old people step aside and new people come in.
但这可以，这可以成为那部电影。是的，这就是拍一部关于“权力掮客”的电影，别拍，它太宏大了，但这可以。这将是那个时刻。这可以成为那部电影。是的，这就是真正的“聚焦”（Spotlight），让人们互相切磋，试图创造最好的报道，秘密会面，这太棒了。这就是为什么当老年人退位、新人接手时，世界才会进步。
And it's super important to have that in the world. You know, like it's just like, it's great that these guys have no memory or sense of Jones Beach or no fear. This is exactly what you need in a society. It's, there's certain standard barriers that hold history and there's certain people that do not give fuck about history.
在世界上拥有这一点超级重要。你知道，这些家伙对琼斯海滩没有记忆或感觉，也没有恐惧，这太棒了。这正是社会所需要的。有些标准的障碍阻碍了历史，而有些人根本不在乎历史。
And it's important to have all those people to make progress. And I just, I love this stuff. It makes me very happy. Yeah, and as we've seen in the book, like Moses used to be one of these types of people. And the other thing is that they are living in the world that Moses' positive work has created.
拥有所有这些人对于取得进步很重要。我就是喜欢这些东西。这让我非常开心。是的，正如我们在书中所见，摩西曾经也是这类人中的一员。另一件事是，他们生活在摩西的积极工作所创造的世界里。
And so they can take it for granted. Moses' fight years ago was people should have parks. This was a new thing. And now their fight is, maybe people shouldn't be pushed out of their homes. Like to make those parks, Moses had to ride roughshod over people. But now they live in a world with parks,
所以他们可以认为这是理所当然的。摩西多年前的斗争是“人们应该拥有公园”。这是一件新鲜事。而现在他们的斗争是，“也许人们不应该被赶出家园”。为了建造那些公园，摩西不得不横行霸道。但现在他们生活在一个有公园的世界里，
and now it's maybe we shouldn't ride roughshod over people. I love this idea of this team of reporters. I think it's just hilarious. And I think the part of me that gets nervous and nostalgic about this stuff is the fact that there's enough papers and like morning editions and late editions and stuff that they can be in conversation like this in a way
现在的问题是，也许我们不应该横行霸道。我喜欢这个记者团队的想法。我觉得这太搞笑了。我内心感到紧张和怀旧的部分在于，当时有足够的报纸，还有早报、晚报之类的，他们可以像这样进行对话，而现在
that papers just don't anymore. They just can't be. Yeah. And knowing that whatever they write, someone's going to read it. Even if it's buried in the back of the newspaper, it's going to get to somebody. But there's got to be new ways to do that, podcasts or whatever. So now it's 1959. Moses is 70 years old.
报纸已经做不到了。他们就是做不到了。是的。而且知道无论他们写什么，总会有人读到。即使它被埋在报纸的背面，也会传达到某人手中。但必须有新的方式来做到这一点，播客或其他什么。现在是1959年。摩西70岁了。
He is seemingly still at the top of the New York power pyramid. He is basking in praise all the time. He's raking in all his investment dollars for his projects. He is easily reappointed as the state power authority. He's on his way to building this massive dam at Niagara that Robert Caro never spends much time on. It is so massively important and yet he never talks about it because it has nothing to do with the things
他似乎仍然处于纽约权力金字塔的顶端。他一直沉浸在赞美声中。他为自己的项目赚取了所有的投资资金。他轻松地被重新任命为州电力局局长。他正在建造尼亚加拉大坝，罗伯特·卡罗（Robert Caro）从未花太多时间描写它。它非常重要，但他从不谈论它，因为它与他
he's really talking about in the same way. And we have to thank him for that. Like you look at this book and you're like, he must talks about it because it has nothing to do with the things he's really talking about in the same way and we have to thank him for that. Like you look at this book and you're like, he must have left it all in, he didn't make any decisions. No, he did. He does not go into the story of this dam. I don't care about it, thank you. I don't wanna hear about it.
真正谈论的事情没有太大关系。我们必须为此感谢他。你看这本书时会想，他一定把所有内容都写进去了，他没有做任何删减。不，他做了。他没有深入描写这座大坝的故事。我不在乎它，谢谢。我不想听关于它的事。
I know it's there, I don't need to, I'm sure there were a lot of struggles, I'm sure there was engineering, amazing feats of engineering that was done. That's right. Don't care. Thank you, Robert Carroll for not getting into it. I mean, I bet you probably in his archives, at the historical society,
我知道它在那里，我不需要，我相信有很多斗争，我相信有工程，完成了惊人的工程壮举。没错。不在乎。谢谢你，罗伯特·卡罗，没有深入描写它。我是说，我敢打赌在他的档案里，在历史协会，
there's probably pages and pages about this dam. I'm sure there's pages and pages. I bet you could write a whole book about what he discovered about that dam. Yeah, but that's not a book I'm necessarily as interested in as New York City. I think there's a feeling of like, what's relevant to someone who lives in the New York area,
可能有关于这座大坝的几页又几页的内容。我肯定有几页又几页。我敢打赌你可以写一整本书来讲述他关于那座大坝的发现。是的，但那不一定是我像对纽约市那样感兴趣的书。我觉得有一种感觉，比如，对于住在纽约地区的人来说什么是相关的，
which you could say makes the book a little provincial in some ways, but also focuses the book quite a bit. There's also a different version of this book, Robert O. Caro spends a lot more time on Moses' itineraries on his vacations. I'm glad we don't have that, that's okay. That's right.
你可以说这让这本书在某些方面显得有点狭隘，但也让这本书非常聚焦。这本书还有另一个版本，罗伯特·O·卡罗花了很多时间描写摩西度假的行程。我很高兴我们没有那个，没关系。没错。
But then in February, so Moses seems like he's on the top of the heap. In February, one of the reporters, he writes a story about how Sydney Unger, pretty good name, the man Moses picked to sponsor his Riverside Amsterdam urban renewal project, is actually a politically connected slumlord. He is not a developer with a good track record and he's politically connected. And suddenly, the editors of these papers, they're afraid they'll miss out on similar scoops like this. And now it's not just that they are listening to their reporters and saying, okay, you can look at Title I. They
但到了二月，摩西看起来似乎处于权力的巅峰。二月，其中一名记者写了一篇报道，讲述了悉尼·昂格（Sydney Unger，名字挺好听的），那个摩西挑选来赞助他河滨阿姆斯特丹城市更新项目的人，实际上是一个有政治背景的贫民窟房东。他不是一个有良好记录的开发商，而且他有政治背景。突然间，这些报纸的编辑们害怕错过类似的独家新闻。现在不仅仅是他们听取记者的意见，说“好吧，你可以调查第一章项目”，他们
are assigning reporters to Title I projects to investigate them. And the stories are getting closer and closer to the front page. They're on page seven and they're on page four. And finally, Moses is being named directly in these stories, directly in the headlines. And this is a longish excerpt, but I love it. So I'm going to read it. It's got a lot of power packed into it. In 1953, the women's city club had issued reports
开始指派记者去调查第一章项目。报道越来越接近头版。它们出现在第七版和第四版。最后，摩西在这些报道中被直接点名，直接出现在标题中。这是一个很长的摘录，但我很喜欢。所以我打算读一下。它蕴含着巨大的力量。1953年，妇女城市俱乐部发布了报告，
disclosing that Moses had been shifting tenants in slum clearance sites to other buildings on the site, like, and then he uses the word for Roma that I'm not going to use on the podcast, but you know, it's books from 1974. The reports had been ignored in 1954, a minority report, the city planning commission had made similar revelations. That report had been ignored. In 1954, a minority report the City Planning Commission had made similar revelations. That report had been ignored. But now, in 1959, when J. Clarence Davies Jr., new independent head of the city's real estate bureau,
披露摩西一直在将贫民窟清理地点的租户转移到该地点的其他建筑物中，比如，然后他用了一个我不会在播客中使用的词，但你知道，这是1974年的书。这些报告在1954年被忽视了，一份少数派报告，城市规划委员会也做出了类似的披露。那份报告被忽视了。1954年，一份少数派报告，城市规划委员会也做出了类似的披露。那份报告被忽视了。但现在，在1959年，当城市房地产局新任独立负责人J·克拉伦斯·戴维斯（J. Clarence Davies Jr.）
made the same report, it was headline letters. City admits shifts from slums to slums. The press of the city awake at last, Fred Cooke exulted, and he was right. The press had not been awakened by its owners, dot dot dot, or by its top editors, dot dot dot. It had been awakened by its reporters, not by its famous reporters, but by young unknown staff writers scheming together to force publishers and editors to do what the young men felt was their duty. But it was awake. I feel like it's such a, it's like, it's such a powerful thing. Like they didn't do it now. They didn't do it here, they didn't do it here. But these guys, they forced it to happen
做出同样的报告时，它成了头条新闻。城市承认从贫民窟转移到贫民窟。弗雷德·库克（Fred Cooke）欢呼道：“这座城市的媒体终于觉醒了”，他是对的。媒体并没有被其所有者，点点点，或其顶级编辑，点点点，所唤醒。它被其记者唤醒了，不是被那些著名的记者，而是被年轻、不知名的职员作家们，他们密谋在一起，强迫出版商和编辑去做那些年轻人认为他们有义务做的事。但它确实觉醒了。我觉得这太，这太强大了。他们当时没做。他们没在这里做，没在这里做。但这些家伙，他们强迫它发生了，
just through their sheer need for it to happen in some ways and their strategy. Yeah, just the sort of ingenuity and sort of playing these different powerful editors and newspaper owners against their own insecurities about being the best paper, having the first story. They just were so smart about it all. I love it.
仅仅通过他们对这件事的纯粹需求，以及他们的策略。是的，就是那种独创性，以及利用这些不同权势的编辑和报纸所有者对成为最佳报纸、抢到第一手新闻的自身不安全感。他们对此非常聪明。我喜欢它。
I think it's just hilarious and fun. And this is the part that I get really, really excited about. Yeah, and there's a feeling. This is not kind of what we think of when we think of community activism, in a way. But it's the same basic principles of people working together for a common goal
我觉得这太搞笑了，很有趣。这就是让我感到非常、非常兴奋的部分。是的，有一种感觉。这在某种程度上不是我们所认为的社区行动主义。但这是人们为了共同目标而共同努力的基本原则，
and using the tools at their command to make that happen. And it's really, you know, when it's for a good thing, it's wonderful. You know, I can see thinking about it now, I can see the same techniques being used for a bad thing. But that's the nature of tools. And as all these stories are landing, another great story that cannot be denied,
并利用他们掌握的工具来实现这一目标。这真的，你知道，当它是为了好事时，这太棒了。你知道，现在想起来，我可以看到同样的技术被用于坏事。但这就是工具的本质。随着所有这些报道的发布，另一个不能被否认的伟大故事，
even though the stakes are so low, the lowest in probably Robert Moses' career. This is chapter 44, Mustache and the Bard, it's pages 1026 to 1039. This one's pretty silly. This is a silly chapter. The title is silly and the chapter's silly. And I wonder, maybe that's the point, that this is, this is a small, seemingly trivial, not even necessarily
尽管赌注很低，可能是罗伯特·摩西职业生涯中最低的。这是第44章，“胡子与吟游诗人”（Mustache and the Bard），第1026到1039页。这一章很傻。这是一章傻乎乎的内容。标题很傻，章节也很傻。我想，也许这就是重点，这是一个小的、看似琐碎的，甚至不一定是
misdeed of Moses, like miscommunication and mismanagement of a subordinate. And it leads to one of his biggest public relations issues. And I think that's, I wonder if that's that, that's the theme that Caro is getting to is that like the little things end up being what trip him up. It's not the big things. It's not the systems that are supposed to keep people in check. It's these little things, not because they affect the most people, but they affect things that the people in the media are interested in talking about. And also things that have a, like an intangible quality. You know, again, you can argue it's too bad you have to lose your house, but we need this road. It's hard to argue kids don't need to play or that William Shakespeare is
摩西的恶行，比如下属的沟通不畅和管理不善。它导致了他最大的公关问题之一。我想这就是卡罗想要表达的主题，即小事最终会成为绊倒他的东西。不是大事。不是那些本应制衡人们的系统。而是这些小事，不是因为它们影响的人最多，而是因为它们影响了媒体感兴趣谈论的事情。还有一些具有无形品质的东西。你知道，再说一次，你可以争辩说失去房子很糟糕，但我们需要这条路。很难争辩说孩子们不需要玩耍，或者威廉·莎士比亚（William Shakespeare）不是
not good, you know, that kind of stuff. It's hard to argue kids don't need to play or that William Shakespeare is not good, that kind of stuff. It's hard to argue this stuff. Shakespeare is a communist. Yeah, exactly. And Kara opens with an excerpt from the 1958 HUAC hearing where theater producer Joseph Paparovsky,
好东西，你知道，那种东西。很难争辩说孩子们不需要玩耍，或者威廉·莎士比亚不是好东西，那种东西。很难争辩这些东西。莎士比亚是共产主义者。是的，完全正确。卡罗以1958年非美活动调查委员会（HUAC）听证会的摘录开篇，当时戏剧制作人约瑟夫·帕帕罗夫斯基（Joseph Paparovsky），
better known as Joe Papp, now he's known as Joe Papp everywhere, who will become one of the towering figures in New York and American theater. He's being asked if he's using Shakespeare to spread communist ideology and the ridiculousness. In the transcript, the congressman who is asking the question seems to understand how ridiculous the premise is even as he uses it.
更广为人知的名字是乔·帕普（Joe Papp），现在他到处都被称为乔·帕普，他将成为纽约和美国戏剧界的泰斗级人物之一。他被问及是否利用莎士比亚传播共产主义意识形态，这太荒谬了。在笔录中，提问的国会议员似乎明白这个前提有多荒谬，即使他使用了它。
That ridiculousness goes through. And Carol, when he gets it after the excerpt, he opens it with almost an acknowledgement that this is an unfair story that's being told, that this is the press and the public getting outraged about this tyrannical move of Moses's when it's really a fight that Moses seems to have not wanted and didn't really have the stomach for and gave up on, but it still hurt his reputation so badly. And it seems like comparing that quote from earlier
那种荒谬感贯穿始终。卡罗在摘录之后，以一种近乎承认的方式开篇，即这是一个被讲述的不公平的故事，这是媒体和公众对摩西的这种暴政行为感到愤怒，而这实际上是一场摩西似乎并不想打、也没有胃口打、最终放弃了的战斗，但它仍然严重损害了他的声誉。这似乎与之前的那句引语相比，
from Moses, it's unfair, but it gets out of truth because if ever there was a thing to get Moses on, it's not this one. And so Moses, he's always been a fan of Shakespeare. He wrote poetry in college. You know he loves Shakespeare. Come on. And in 1956, Joseph Papp, he's a young theater impresario. He says to Moses, can I put on free Shakespeare plays in this amphitheater
来自摩西的，“这不公平，但它触及了真相”，因为如果有什么事能抓住摩西的把柄，那肯定不是这一件。所以摩西，他一直是个莎士比亚迷。他在大学时写过诗。你知道他喜欢莎士比亚。得了吧。1956年，约瑟夫·帕普，他是一位年轻的戏剧经理人。他对摩西说：“我可以在这个露天剧场上演免费的莎士比亚戏剧吗？”
on the Lower East Side that the Parks Department built, and that Moses built in part because Al Smith had told Moses when I was young, I could not afford tickets to the theater. I just couldn't afford to go. And Moses seems to admire Pabst's genuine interest in providing shows for free. And besides the stage is empty all the time anyway.
在下东区，公园管理局建造的，摩西建造它在一定程度上是因为阿尔·史密斯（Al Smith）年轻时曾对摩西说：“我买不起剧院的票。我就是买不起。”摩西似乎很欣赏帕普提供免费演出的真诚兴趣。而且反正舞台一直空着。
No one does anything with it. So why not? And Pabst starts putting on productions there and they're very respected. The local audiences who cannot afford theater tickets love them. And this happens throughout history with live theater, but especially with Shakespeare is that you show them to people who you think are going to be like, this is too complicated. I don't understand it. And they love it. Like in the old west, Shakespeare was incredibly popular. Like it's just, it's writing that just gets to,
没人用它。所以为什么不呢？帕普开始在那里制作演出，而且非常受人尊敬。买不起剧院票的当地观众很喜欢它们。这在现场戏剧的历史中一直发生，尤其是莎士比亚，你把它们展示给那些你认为会说“这太复杂了，我看不懂”的人，结果他们却很喜欢。就像在旧西部，莎士比亚非常受欢迎。就像他的文字组合能力，
he's almost Robert Caroweske in his ability to put words together. And Pat is like, I wanna expand these shows, I wanna put them in more parks. And there's one person standing in his way, Moses gives permission, but there's one person who doesn't like it, Stuart Constable, the mustache,
他几乎是罗伯特·卡罗式的。帕普说：“我想扩大这些演出，我想把它们带到更多的公园。”有一个人挡了他的路，摩西给了许可，但有一个人不喜欢它，斯图尔特·康斯特布尔（Stuart Constable），那个“胡子”，
who we already know is a foe of mothers, doesn't like moms. There is a kind of like strain in these chapters of subordinates to Moses, who don't have any of his skill whatsoever. Like they're as pugnacious as he is, but can't like operate around people, can't like bully people the same way
我们已经知道他是摩西的敌人，不喜欢妈妈们。在这些章节中，摩西的下属有一种倾向，他们完全没有他的任何技能。他们像他一样好斗，但无法像他那样在人际中运作，无法像他那样欺负人，
and make wrongheaded decisions that, you know, to his credit in a way, Robert Moses has great loyalties to his subordinates. But they just don't deserve it because they are kind of so boneheaded so much of the time. Yeah, you see it a lot in organizations where someone at the top has a special quality that has allowed them to create this position of power. And then yeah, the people underneath them try to imitate that or have been taught to
并做出错误的决定，你知道，值得称赞的是，罗伯特·摩西对他的下属有极大的忠诚。但他们不配，因为他们大部分时间都太笨了。是的，你在组织中经常看到这种情况，处于顶端的人拥有某种特殊品质，使他们能够创造这种权力地位。然后，是的，他们下面的人试图模仿这一点，或者被教导
work in that ethic and they just don't have it. You know, they just don't, they can't do it the right way. And we'll see as we get through it. Yeah, his loyalty to his subordinates, which would normally be a, a positive thing gets him into so much trouble here. And this whole chapter has an element of farce about it. You know, there's, there's, it's, it's written with a kind of like almost the most winking that Carol gets throughout. And it's, it's a, it's a fun chapter, but, uh, it's, I have, this is the
以那种道德准则工作，但他们就是没有那种能力。你知道，他们就是做不到，他们无法以正确的方式做到。随着我们深入阅读，我们会看到的。是的，他对下属的忠诚，这通常是一件积极的事情，在这里却让他陷入了巨大的麻烦。而这一整章有一种闹剧的成分。你知道，它写得带有一种卡罗全书中最多的调侃意味。这是一章很有趣的章节，但是，呃，我有，这是
chapter I maybe have the most trouble with in some ways. Oh, really? Oh, we'll talk about it. We'll talk about it. Okay. Um, partly because there's part that, and we'll talk about it. We'll talk about it. Okay. Partly because there's part, and we'll get to it later, but there's times when I'm reading it,
我在某些方面最难读下去的章节。哦，真的吗？哦，我们会谈谈它的。我们会谈谈它的。好的。嗯，部分原因是有一部分，我们会谈谈它的。我们会谈谈它的。好的。部分原因是有一部分，我们稍后会讲到，但有些时候我在读它时，
each time I've read it where I'm like, why is this jamper on the book? Like, why? There's nothing about James Jacobs, but there's all this stuff about Joe Papp and Shakespeare. But I think it's because this larger point I think he's getting to. But Papp proposes putting on plays in Central Park.
每次读到它我都会想，为什么这一章在书里？为什么？这里面没有关于简·雅各布斯（Jane Jacobs）的内容，但全是关于乔·帕普和莎士比亚的内容。但我认为这是因为他想要表达的那个更大的观点。但帕普提议在中央公园上演戏剧。
And Moses is like, that's okay if you don't charge admission for them. And this is a start of Shakespeare in the Park, which again is for the cultural life of New York City is one of, by this point in the year 2024, one of the most beloved things going on in New York. And I have seen shows in that festival. I know like friends of mine, I couldn't do this
摩西说：“如果你不收门票，那没问题。”这是“公园里的莎士比亚”（Shakespeare in the Park）的开始，这对于纽约市的文化生活来说，到了2024年，是纽约最受喜爱的活动之一。我曾在那个艺术节看过演出。我知道，比如我的朋友们，我做不到这一点，
because I had a job, but friends of mine would go, they would wait online for hours because all you need to do is wait online. You'd wait on for hours. And like, I remember a friend being like, oh yeah, I was standing next you need to do is wait online. You wait online for hours. And like, I remember a friend being like, oh yeah, I was standing next to Mike Myers waiting for Shakespeare in the Park tickets for four hours.
因为我有工作，但我的朋友们会去，他们会排队排上几个小时，因为你只需要排队。你会排上几个小时。而且，我记得一个朋友说，“哦，是的，我当时站在……”你只需要排队。你排上几个小时。而且，我记得一个朋友说，“哦，是的，我当时站在迈克·迈尔斯（Mike Myers）旁边，排了四个小时队买‘公园里的莎士比亚’的票。”
Like, that's just what you do. And it's first come first serve. And it's just a beloved event to a certain section of New Yorkers. And it's kind of magical when you are in the park, how Central Park, even it's a safe park, but now, but it's still scary to be in a park at night. It's like you like you're in the woods. It's scary and you've been raised on these stories of people being killed in the park You know
就像，这就是你所做的。而且是先到先得。对于一部分纽约人来说，这是一个备受喜爱的活动。当你身处公园时，这有一种魔力，中央公园，即使它是一个安全的公园，但现在，在晚上待在公园里仍然很可怕。就像你在树林里一样。这很可怕，而且你从小听着人们在公园里被杀的故事长大，你知道，
But there's something magical about how when there's a large group of people Seeing a performance because I used to see the Philharmonic in the park quite a bit, too It transforms that space and it takes a space that could be threatening and turns into this communal space That is magical and warm and what a city does best, you know, which is take the fear of solitude and turn it into a shared experience with lots of strangers who become your neighbors, you know, they become people that you know for a moment and have a connection to that otherwise would just be, you know, unknown names, unknown faces, unknown lives. It's just, there's something very magical about it.
但当有一大群人观看演出时，有一种魔力，因为我过去也经常在公园看爱乐乐团的演出。它改变了那个空间，它把一个可能具有威胁性的空间变成了一个公共空间，那是神奇而温暖的，是一个城市做得最好的事情，你知道，那就是消除孤独的恐惧，把它变成一种与许多陌生人的共享体验，他们变成了你的邻居，你知道，他们变成了你认识的人，哪怕只有片刻，并与之产生联系，否则他们只会是，你知道，未知的名字，未知的面孔，未知的生命。这太神奇了。
And Moses, to his credit, likes this. Yeah, no, he thinks it's great. This is the stuff, he's not a big fan of like, just wild glens and trees and stuff, but this is the type of thing that he is into. Yes, you are using a space. He does not like unused space. And so if you can use it and use it for something
摩西，值得称赞的是，喜欢这一点。是的，不，他认为这很棒。这就是那些东西，他不是那种喜欢荒野、树木之类的人，但这是他感兴趣的那种事情。是的，你在利用一个空间。他不喜欢未使用的空间。所以如果你能利用它，并把它用于
that no one else is doing with it, it's he's for it. And he really appreciates the chutzpah that Joe Papp has in the way he fund raises for it. And Moses comes to see him, the book implies as kind of like a young go getter like himself, who has a project that's to help people and will go to any length to do it. And so by 1959, Moses, they've never met each
其他人没有做的事情，他就是支持的。他真的很欣赏乔·帕普在为它筹款时表现出的那种胆识。书里暗示，摩西把帕普看作像他自己一样的年轻有为者，他有一个旨在帮助人们的项目，并且会不惜一切代价去实现它。所以到了1959年，摩西，他们从未见过面，
other, but Moses is telling Joe Papp, I'll handle the fundraising for another season of Plays in the Park. I'll take care of it. I like what you're doing. Don't worry about money. And then he leaves town
但摩西告诉乔·帕普：“我会负责下一季‘公园里的戏剧’的筹款。我会处理好的。我喜欢你正在做的事情。别担心钱的问题。”然后他离开了城里，
on a three week vacation of Barbados. Another one of these long vacations that this workaholic is taking, you know. Maybe he's taking more of them at this age, I don't know. And unfortunately he leaves things in the hands of the mustache constable who does not like Shakespeare, doesn't trust Papp. And it only gets worse when he learns that
去巴巴多斯度了三周假。这个工作狂又在休这种长假了，你知道。也许他在这个年纪休得更多了，我不知道。不幸的是，他把事情留在了那个“胡子”康斯特布尔手中，他不喜欢莎士比亚，不信任帕普。当他得知
Papp refused to name names before HUAC because constable is, if anything, just a straightforward anti-communist, you know, steak and potatoes, New York guy with a big mustache later on reporters are like, uh, doesn't this smack of McCarthyism? And he goes, what's wrong with McCarthy? And that kind of says everything you need to know
帕普拒绝在非美活动调查委员会（HUAC）面前供出名字时，情况变得更糟了，因为康斯特布尔如果说有什么特点的话，那就是一个直截了当的反共分子，你知道，那种吃牛排和土豆的纽约人，留着大胡子。后来记者们问：“这难道没有麦卡锡主义的味道吗？”他回答：“麦卡锡有什么错？”那句话几乎说明了你需要知道的关于
about the mustache, yeah. And so what the constable, oh, not the constable, I guess the mustache constable. Yeah, his name is Constable, but I keep calling him almost the constable also, yeah. Decides to do is that, you know, he doesn't like all these people like using the park and maybe causing some maintenance issues with, I, you know, he doesn't like all these people like using the park
那个“胡子”的一切，是的。所以那个康斯特布尔，哦，不是康斯特布尔，我想是那个“胡子”康斯特布尔。是的，他的名字是康斯特布尔，但我一直叫他“康斯特布尔”，也是，是的。他决定做的是，你知道，他不喜欢所有这些人利用公园，可能造成一些维护问题，我，你知道，他不喜欢所有这些人利用公园，
and maybe causing some maintenance issues with, I don't know, sitting down on blankets or something like that. And so he says that, well, you know, what you gotta have to do is you need to reimburse the park department for maintenance, and therefore that would require charging admission to Shakespeare in the park,
并可能造成一些维护问题，比如坐在毯子上之类的。所以他说，好吧，你知道，你必须做的是你需要补偿公园管理局的维护费用，因此这将需要对“公园里的莎士比亚”收取门票，
which is against the sort of like deal that Pap had made with Robert Moses about doing Shakespeare in the Park. And so it puts him in this bind. He has to, yeah, that he has promised I will never charge for Shakespeare and he doesn't want to. But now he's being told you have to.
这违背了帕普与罗伯特·摩西达成的关于在公园里做莎士比亚戏剧的某种协议。所以这让他陷入了困境。他必须，是的，他承诺过我永远不会对莎士比亚收费，他也不想。但现在有人告诉他你必须收费。
And Constable is sure that Moses would be like, yeah, get this subversive out of the park. I don't want him in there. So it was one of those things where it's like, my boss did the exact opposite, but I know he really wants me to do this because it aligns with the values I ascribe to him. And it's just, it's foolish.
而康斯特布尔确信摩西会说：“是的，把这个颠覆分子赶出公园。我不想让他待在那里。”所以这就像是那种情况，比如，“我的老板做了完全相反的事情，但我知道他真的希望我这样做，因为它符合我归因于他的价值观。”这太愚蠢了。
Don't do that people. Just do it, do what the boss did. And that's what they want being done right now. And you would think again, that Moses would just overrule mustache when he hears about, but like Roman, if you were saying earlier, one of these commandments that was ingrained in him in politics was you always have to support your subordinates.
别那样做，人们。只要做，做老板做过的事。而这正是他们现在想要完成的事情。你又会认为，摩西听到这件事时会直接推翻“胡子”的决定，但就像罗曼你之前说的，他在政治中根深蒂固的戒律之一就是你必须始终支持你的下属。
That's how you get their loyalty. You make them feel like you have their back all the time. And in addition to that, if he says Constable is wrong, then it's almost like saying he's wrong because he has invested Constable with this power. So if his whole thing is infallibility, if the guy he hired is wrong, that means he's a little wrong. And so he had vowed publicly to his subordinates, I will never overrule you. And that's how I'm going to keep you loyal to me is I'm going to be
这就是你获得他们忠诚的方式。你让他们觉得你一直支持他们。除此之外，如果他说康斯特布尔错了，那就几乎等于说他自己错了，因为他赋予了康斯特布尔这种权力。所以如果他的整个核心是“永不犯错”，那么他雇的人错了，就意味着他自己也有一点错了。所以他曾公开向他的下属发誓，我永远不会推翻你们。这就是我保持你们忠诚的方式，我会
loyal to you. So when Moses comes back, he backs up the mustache and refuses to talk to Pap. And the money he said he'd raise for the Shakespeare festival, that's not happening. And Moses writes Pap a letter saying, well, for maintenance, it's going to cost between a hundred thousand and a hundred and fifty thousand dollars that you're going to have to reimburse the parks department. And like, this is 1959. Like, I mean, that's a lot of money now.
忠于你们。所以当摩西回来时，他支持了那个“胡子”，并拒绝与帕普交谈。他说他会为莎士比亚艺术节筹集的资金，那是不可能的。摩西写信给帕普说，好吧，维护费用在十万到十五万美元之间，你需要补偿公园管理局。而且，这是1959年。我是说，那在现在是一大笔钱。
That's an astronomical amount back then. And Pap is trying to meet with Moses, but Moses is like, I'm not in charge. Constable's in charge. And I wonder if here it's a little bit loyalty and a little bit him trying to insulate himself from blame that like, if there's constable between me and pap, then pap can't get mad at me.
那在当时是一笔天文数字。帕普试图与摩西会面，但摩西说：“我不负责。康斯特布尔负责。”我想在这里，这既有一点忠诚的成分，也有一点他试图将自己与指责隔离开来的成分，比如，如果康斯特布尔在我与帕普之间，那么帕普就不能对我生气。
And constable keeps moving the goalpost. He used to say, he's like, you got to charge a $1 admission fee. And pap's like, okay, I'll consider it. Cause it was, okay, then it's $2 admission fee. And pap starts to realize this is not about money. This is about the mustache thinks I'm a communist and that's what it's about.
而康斯特布尔不断地移动球门柱。他过去常说，他就像，“你必须收取1美元的门票费。”帕普说，“好吧，我会考虑的。”因为那是，好吧，然后是2美元的门票费。帕普开始意识到这与钱无关。这是关于那个“胡子”认为我是个共产主义者，这就是重点。
This is not a fair fight and I'm gonna have to fight it like a fight. Yeah. And so what does he do? He uses the same tool the moms use. He goes to the press. What does he do Roman? Yeah, no, he goes to the media and starts like, you know, he starts to talk about Shakespeare. These are all like educated people love Shakespeare. They are now at a point in Moses career where the newspapers are criticizing Moses on a somewhat regular basis. And the funny thing here is he really goes for drama. Like he's gonna kind of do the things that Robert Moses is known for.
这不是一场公平的战斗，我必须像打仗一样去打它。是的。那么他做了什么？他使用了摩西使用的同一个工具。他去找媒体。罗曼，他做了什么？是的，不，他去找媒体，开始，你知道，他开始谈论莎士比亚。这些都是受过教育的人，热爱莎士比亚。在摩西职业生涯的这个阶段，报纸已经开始定期批评摩西了。有趣的是，他真的追求戏剧性。他会做罗伯特·摩西所熟知的事情。
It's like this sort of like attack on character, different sort of innuendo, like different things to sort of like make it feel like there's a lot of corruption here, that Moses is a kind of kind of villain here, doesn't like actually, I don't think it really highlights his role in the beginning of making it all possible. No, not at all. He really, he makes it into a play, you know, he's quoting Shakespeare all the time and the reporters love that. And Moses responds in kind
这就像那种对人格的攻击，不同的影射，比如不同的事情，让它感觉这里有很多腐败，摩西在这里是一个反派，我不认为这真的突出了他在开始时使这一切成为可能的作用。不，一点也不。他真的把它变成了一出戏，你知道，他一直在引用莎士比亚，记者们很喜欢这一点。摩西也以同样的方式回应，
and he tries to go back to his old playbook similarly. And he starts these innuendos behind the scenes about Pap being a Red. But that used to work. Times have slightly changed. This is not a time when it's okay to be a communist, but Joe McCarthy has been dead for a couple of years. People kind of look back at that as gross.
他试图以同样的方式回到他的旧剧本。他在幕后开始这些关于帕普是“红党”的影射。但这过去是有效的。时代已经稍微改变了。现在不是一个可以成为共产主义者的时代，但约瑟夫·麦卡锡（Joe McCarthy）已经死了几年了。人们回顾那段历史时觉得很恶心。
They're not like, I love communism. Everyone should believe what they want. But they're like, that as gross. They're not like, I love communism, everyone should believe what they want, but they're like, that was gross. And they called, and so reporters, when they hear these rumors, they say, this is McCarthyism in a disapproving way. And just as with the first battle of Central Park,
他们不是说，“我热爱共产主义。每个人都应该相信他们想要的。”但他们说，“那太恶心了。”他们不是说，“我热爱共产主义，每个人都应该相信他们想要的”，但他们说，“那太恶心了。”他们称，所以记者们，当他们听到这些谣言时，他们说，这是麦卡锡主义，带着一种不赞成的语气。就像中央公园的第一场战役一样，
this story is getting simplified. Moses is the villain, he hates free Shakespeare, something that is objectively good. You cannot argue that there is a downside to putting on free Shakespeare plays in the park. You can't, it's impossible. And the thing is that they also do is they start to fact check his claims about what's going on
这个故事正在被简化。摩西是反派，他讨厌免费的莎士比亚，这是一件客观上好的事情。你不能争辩说在公园里上演免费的莎士比亚戏剧有什么坏处。你不能，这不可能。他们还做的一件事是，他们开始核实他关于正在发生的事情的说法，
in ways that they didn't used to do. It used to be if Moses said something, that was the end of it. You didn't question it, but now they're questioning it. And once again, public opinion turns against him. And Carol points out that in the past, when there had been serious PR crises, Moses would get sick and be in the hospital.
以他们过去没有做过的方式。过去如果摩西说了什么，那就是定论。你不会质疑它，但现在他们在质疑它。舆论再次转向反对他。卡罗指出，在过去，当出现严重的公关危机时，摩西会生病并住院。
And the same thing happens here for reasons that are never fully explained. My pet theory is that he has a heart attack, but who knows, you never know, but he goes to the hospital. And Carol says that photos of Moses leaving the hospital make him look for the first time, old, like actually old, like an old weathered man. And then Pap is like, I'm going to put this, the onus of this on Mayor Wagner, Mayor, overrule these
这里也发生了同样的事情，原因从未完全解释清楚。我的个人理论是他心脏病发作了，但谁知道呢，你永远不知道，但他去了医院。卡罗说，摩西离开医院的照片让他看起来第一次显得老了，真的老了，像一个饱经风霜的老人。然后帕普说，“我要把这件事的责任推给市长瓦格纳（Mayor Wagner），市长，推翻这些
policies. And of course the mayor is like, I'd love to, I'd love to just say, yeah, put Shakespeare in the park, but he can't overrule Moses. And it's almost like at this point the mayor must've felt so annoyed. Moses is punishing the mayor just for considering it. He refuses to take Wagner's calls. And Mayor Wagner becomes the subject of these joking headlines where Mayor Wagner will be like, I plan to talk to Moses later. I can't quite get him.
政策。”当然，市长说，“我很乐意，我很乐意说，‘是的，把莎士比亚带进公园’”，但他不能推翻摩西。在这一点上，市长一定感到非常恼火。摩西仅仅因为市长考虑这件事就在惩罚他。他拒绝接听瓦格纳的电话。瓦格纳市长成了这些开玩笑的头条新闻的主题，瓦格纳市长会说，“我计划稍后与摩西谈谈。我不太能联系上他。”
And so there's headlines where it's like, Mayor searches for Moses. Where's Moses? Mayor can't find him. And if I was Wagner, I'd be so pissed that I'm not even in a fight with Moses. I'm in a fight with the mustache, and I'm looking like a fool
所以有这样的头条新闻，比如“市长寻找摩西。摩西在哪里？市长找不到他。”如果我是瓦格纳，我会非常生气，我甚至没有和摩西打架。我是在和那个“胡子”打架，而我看起来像个傻瓜，
because with a guy who shouldn't even, I shouldn't have to deal with, you know, and he can't fire Moses. And so Wagner has to then support him and say, Moses, too valuable. I can't do anything about it. And the press plays it as Wagner giving in to Moses. So again, if I'm Wagner, I'm like,
因为和一个我甚至不应该处理的人，你知道，而且他不能解雇摩西。所以瓦格纳不得不支持他，说：“摩西，太有价值了。我对此无能为力。”媒体将其报道为瓦格纳向摩西屈服。所以再说一次，如果我是瓦格纳，我会想，
I'm losing a fight with the mustache. This is ridiculous. And ultimately, Pap goes to the courts and a court finds narrowly, kind of for the first time, that Moses is being capricious with his power and that he cannot do that with the parks. This is really stunning because this was a kind of thing that in the previous court cases,
我正在输给那个“胡子”。这太荒谬了。最终，帕普诉诸法庭，法庭勉强裁定，这在某种程度上是第一次，摩西在行使权力时反复无常，他不能那样对待公园。这真的很令人震惊，因为这是在之前的法庭案件中，
the law was interpreted in such a way, written by Moses and interpreted in such a way, that anything within the park walls, anything that related to parks whatsoever, was the complete domain of Robert Moses. They could- He was the king of the parks. They could not, he could tear down any structure
法律被以某种方式解释，由摩西撰写并以某种方式解释，即公园墙内的任何东西，任何与公园有关的东西，都是罗伯特·摩西的完全领地。他们不能——他是公园之王。他们不能，他可以拆除任何建筑。
that he wanted, build any other one that he wanted. I mean, like it was really, and for something related to like, ephemeral exhibition of Shakespeare plays, to think that this is the thing, that a non-permanent cultural institution, just like, or even just like cultural, like, I don't know, occurrence,
他想要的，建造任何他想要的其他东西。我的意思是，这真的很……而且对于像莎士比亚戏剧的短暂展览这样相关的事情，认为这就是那件事，一个非永久性的文化机构，就像，或者甚至只是像文化，我不知道，某种现象，
is the thing that stops him when it comes to court interpretation of what his power is inside of the parks, is really stunning. It's a interpretation of what his power is inside of the park, is really stunning. It's a real change in his power. It's huge, and again, if you're making a movie about R.R. Moses, this is one of the things you do because the drama and the narrative is there,
竟然是他在法院对其在公园内权力的解释方面所面临的阻碍，这真的很令人震惊。这是对他公园内权力的解释，真的很令人震惊。这是他权力上的真正改变。这太巨大了，再说一次，如果你要拍一部关于罗伯特·摩西的电影，这就是你会做的其中一件事，因为戏剧性和叙事就在那里，
because it's so simple, and it's like, it's such an ephemeral thing, you're right, but the story is so clear. It's such a clear story, and the only thing that screws up this story dramatically is Moses probably not really wanting to do it. Exactly, yeah. And just as we've been yelling this whole series,
因为这太简单了，而且这就像，这是一种如此短暂的事情，你是对的，但故事非常清晰。这是一个如此清晰的故事，而唯一让这个故事在戏剧性上搞砸的事情，大概就是摩西其实并不想做这件事。没错，是的。就像我们整个系列一直在大喊的那样，
why don't you just accept its resignation? There's a part of me here that's like, just do it. Just swallow your loyalty philosophy and just do it because it's so obviously wrong. Yeah. But maybe this is like one of those things, like if you eliminate the penny, people begin to like understand
你为什么不直接接受它的辞职呢？我内心有一部分觉得，就这么做吧。吞下你的忠诚哲学，直接去做吧，因为它显然是错的。是的。但也许这就像那种事情，比如如果你取消了一分钱硬币，人们开始理解
that money has no meaning. That money is not real. Yeah. And it's kind of one of those things like he knows that he's so propped up in this system of you just support your guys. I, you know, the mayor just supports me, the governor just supports me,
金钱没有意义。金钱不是真实的。是的。这有点像那种事情，他知道他在这个系统中被支撑得太高了，你只需要支持你的人。我，你知道，市长支持我，州长支持我，
like, you know, they trust me to do it. And so I think that this is really something that he can't possibly move on, mostly, because he knows that the whole structure that holds him in place is at the base level this thing, you know, of this idea of like, I trust your judgment because you are you. That's what he depends on for the newspapers. That's what he depends on for the newspapers.
就像，你知道，他们信任我去做这件事。所以我认为这确实是他无法摆脱的事情，主要是因为他知道支撑他地位的整个结构在基础层面上就是这个东西，你知道，这种想法，比如，我信任你的判断，因为你是你。这就是他依赖报纸的原因。这就是他依赖报纸的原因。
That's what he depends on for his relationship in politics as he remains this bureaucrat inside of this constantly changing political machinery. And so I get it. I get that this is the thing that he can't change on. It makes sense. It's like when we talked to AOC, she was talking about how like so much of politics
这就是他依赖政治关系的原因，因为他仍然是这个不断变化的政治机器中的官僚。所以我明白了。我明白这是他无法改变的事情。这说得通。就像我们和AOC交谈时，她谈到政治中有多少
is based on if you give your word, can you keep it? Yeah. Do you have the power and the strength to keep it if you promise something or if you say you're going to support something or go against something. And this is one of those times you're right.
是基于如果你许下诺言，你能遵守吗？是的。如果你承诺了什么，或者如果你说你要支持什么或反对什么，你是否有权力和力量去遵守它。这是其中一次，你是对的。
Yeah. He has to, he has to maintain that, that power of saying like, no, when I say something, it happens. Um, but Carol points out that based on precedent, Moses could have appealed this court case and I say something, it happens. Um, but Carol points out that based on precedent, Moses could have appealed this court case and won. Yeah, for sure.
是的。他必须，他必须保持那种，那种说“不”的权力，当我说什么时，它就会发生。嗯，但卡罗指出，根据先例，摩西本可以对这个案件提出上诉，我说什么，它就会发生。嗯，但卡罗指出，根据先例，摩西本可以对这个案件提出上诉并胜诉。是的，当然。
But instead he says, I'll abide by the decision. We'll have Shakespeare in the park. And he tries to arrange the money Pap needs to get the festival back into the park. And Pap only has time for one play. He puts on Julius Caesar. It's a huge triumph. Everybody loves it.
但他反而说，我会遵守裁决。我们会在公园里举办莎士比亚戏剧。他试图筹集帕普需要让戏剧节回到公园的资金。而帕普只有时间排演一部戏。他上演了《朱利叶斯·凯撒》。这是一个巨大的胜利。每个人都喜欢它。
I think it's very funny that he probably did it on, maybe didn't purpose. That's the story of a, of a potential tyrant being taken down, you know? Yeah. Yeah. And Carol wonders, he says, why did Moses give up this fight when previously he had never admitted defeat so relatively easily? And he says, one explanation is that Moses could see the damage it was doing to his public image. But Carol ultimately he's like,
我觉得很有趣的是，他可能这样做，也许不是故意的。这就是一个潜在暴君被推翻的故事，你知道吗？是的。是的。而卡罗感到好奇，他说，为什么摩西放弃了这场斗争，而之前他从未如此轻易地承认失败？他说，一种解释是摩西能看到这对他的公众形象造成的损害。但卡罗最终觉得，
I think that Moses just didn't want to fight this battle in the first place and got dragged into it because of Constable's dumb choices. And then he seems to have mired Papp so much that he let it happen. And he eventually builds the Delacorte amphitheater in the park expressly as a permanent home for Papp's productions. And so Sid Shapiro, he suspects, and he says to Carol,
我认为摩西根本不想打这场仗，是因为康斯特布尔的愚蠢选择才被拖进去的。然后他似乎把帕普困得太深，以至于他让这件事发生了。他最终在公园里建造了德拉科特露天剧场，明确作为帕普作品的永久家园。所以希德·夏皮罗，他怀疑，并对卡罗说，
that he thinks Moses wanted to lose this one. That like, if there ever was a battle that Moses not just was okay with losing, but didn't wanna win, you know, on the merits, this is it. And Carrow goes on to talk about Joe Papp. This fight was one of the best things that ever happened to Joe Papp. He's the darling of the liberal elites.
他认为摩西想输掉这一场。就像，如果说有什么战斗是摩西不仅愿意输掉，而且不想赢的，你知道，从是非曲直来看，就是这一场。卡罗接着谈到了乔·帕普。这场斗争是乔·帕普发生过的最好的事情之一。他是自由派精英的宠儿。
He becomes this institution in the theater world. He founds the public theater eventually, down by Astor Place, which is still there. But for Moses, it's another bloatose reputation. It's another demonstration of just how much power he has over the mayor, which people are starting to realize. And the press turns further against it. They see that Constable is kind of this mini version of the boss, that this arrogance is
他成为了戏剧界的这种机构。他最终在阿斯特广场附近创立了公共剧院，至今仍在那里。但对摩西来说，这是又一个臃肿的声誉。这是又一次证明了他对市长有多大的权力，人们开始意识到这一点。媒体进一步反对他。他们看到康斯特布尔有点像老板的迷你版，这种傲慢是
just his boss's arrogance. And now it's not just the young go-getters who are looking to get Moses. It's the establishment as well. And even the Times starts to investigate Moses' Title I projects. And the new frame for the media isn't Moses the hero, who occasionally maybe, I don't know if he's wrapped up in something, we'll see, but Moses the villain.
他老板的傲慢。现在不仅仅是那些想要搞垮摩西的年轻进取者了。建制派也加入了。甚至《泰晤士报》也开始调查摩西的“第一章”项目。媒体的新框架不再是英雄摩西，偶尔可能，我不知道他是否卷入了什么，我们会看到的，而是恶棍摩西。
Oh, what a tangled web we weave, which is not Shakespeare. I should have had a Shakespeare quote. I don't think it is anyway. I'll look it up. I don't think it is. Well, while you look it up, we'll play some ads and then we'll come back with Chapter 45, Off to the Fair.
哦，我们编织了多么复杂的网，这不是莎士比亚。我本该引用一句莎士比亚的话。我觉得反正不是。我会查一下。我不认为它是。好吧，在你查的时候，我们先放些广告，然后回来继续第45章，去集市。
This is Chapter 45, Off to the Fair, which is like one of these weird chapters that it sets up the sort of big deal that's about to come, which is there's just something that allows Moses to be kind of dislodged from his like tendrils and everything, because there's this one thing for him to do. Yes, this is the beginning of it's you know, you hear people say that things change very slowly and then suddenly very fast and that this is the slower part of that change and then the chapter after it which will end this episode with is the fast change. Before we get into it, we do have unfinished business. I just want to say, Oh, what a tangled web. It's Sir Walter Scott. It's not Shakespeare. I apologize. That's okay. Another great UK author, another towering giant in English language literature. But okay, we're still in 1959 in off to the fair. It's May 1959 and the New York Citizens Union, it's another one of these civic reform groups. Moses had been close to it once. They want to ask Moses some questions about his Title I projects and he answers them in print. He answers them very haughtily and the newspapers, they do it normally, run those statements just as straight facts.
这是第45章，去集市，这就像这些奇怪的章节之一，它为即将到来的大事做铺垫，那就是有一些东西让摩西能够从他的触角和一切中被某种程度上移开，因为他有一件事要做。是的，这是开始，你知道，你听到人们说事情变化非常缓慢，然后突然变得非常快，这是那个变化中较慢的部分，然后结束这一集的下一章是快速的变化。在我们进入之前，我们还有未完成的事情。我只想说，哦，多么复杂的网。是沃尔特·斯科特爵士。不是莎士比亚。我道歉。没关系。另一位伟大的英国作家，英语文学中又一位高耸的巨人。但好吧，我们还在1959年的“去集市”。那是1959年5月，纽约市民联盟，这是另一个公民改革团体。摩西曾经一度与它关系密切。他们想问摩西一些关于他“第一章”项目的问题，他以印刷形式回答了他们。他回答得非常傲慢，而报纸，他们通常会这样做，直接把这些声明当作事实刊登出来。
They wouldn't have questioned them. But now they're going to look into them and they point out he hasn't been truthful about say who actually pursued that Manhattan town development. Moses leaves out the name of a graft crook and politician Samuel Caspert, who's going to be a big figure in that corruption scandal. And even worse when asked if there are written reports about the bidders for the projects and whether those are available to the public, he gives us indignant response of like, well, of course they are.
他们本不会质疑它们。但现在他们要深入调查，他们指出他在比如谁真正追求那个曼哈顿镇开发项目上并没有说实话。摩西漏掉了一个贪污犯和政客塞缪尔·卡斯珀特的名字，他将成为那起腐败丑闻中的大人物。更糟糕的是，当被问及是否有关于项目投标人的书面报告以及这些报告是否对公众开放时，他给出了愤慨的回应，比如，好吧，它们当然是。
And of course they're open to the public. Like as if I'm offended, you would even accuse me of hiding those things and the reporters, they see that and they are nearly orgasmic over this because this is the promise. Oh, like what did he, what he just did is gave us permission to ask him to look at the title one files. These have been secret for years and now we can finally look at them. This is amazing. And Caro sees this as like a real tactical blunder.
而且它们当然对公众开放。就好像我被冒犯了，你竟然指责我隐瞒这些东西，而记者们，他们看到了这一点，他们对此几乎感到高潮，因为这就是承诺。哦，就像他刚才所做的是允许我们要求他查看“第一章”文件。这些文件多年来一直是秘密，现在我们终于可以查看它们了。这太棒了。卡罗认为这是一个真正的战术失误。
And he says, why did he make this tactical blunder? Why did he do this? Basically giving permission to have people come investigate him. And Caro speculates, maybe he knew that legally he could not block them since slum clearance is a city committee. It's not an authority. You can't treat it like a private corporation or maybe he'd been so busy with the Messina and Niagara power dams. Again, these dams that the book barely talks about, which are enormous, enormous projects that
他说，他为什么要犯这个战术失误？他为什么要这样做？基本上是允许人们来调查他。卡罗推测，也许他知道在法律上他无法阻止他们，因为贫民窟清理是一个城市委员会。它不是一个管理局。你不能把它当作私人公司来对待，或者也许他一直忙于梅西纳和尼亚加拉水电大坝。再说一次，这些书里几乎没提的大坝，它们是巨大的，巨大的项目，
really take up so much of his brain space. We don't hear much about him again, I don't want to, that he wasn't paying that close attention to Title I anymore, didn't know how damning the files were. This is at a point where he's less than six weeks until the gala opening of the Messina Dam, Nixon, the vice president's gonna be there, Queen Elizabeth II is gonna be there, this is a big deal for him.
真的占据了他太多的脑力空间。我们没再听到太多关于他的消息，我不想，他不再那么密切关注“第一章”了，不知道这些文件有多么令人谴责。此时距离梅西纳大坝的盛大开幕还有不到六周，尼克松副总统会出席，伊丽莎白二世女王会出席，这对他是件大事。
He cannot let, I forgot the name of the guy from Tavern on the Green, but he cannot let him feed, you know, garbage to the vice president and the Queen of England. He's got to be on top of that. But Carol, he also talks about, Moses is undeniably at this point for all the power he has always had, for what a dynamo he is. He's an old man and he is overseeing the Parks Department, the Long Island Park expansion projects, the expressways, the bridges, those big dams that again take up a lot more of his life than the book would lead you to believe. Maybe he's just stretched too thin and maybe he's just trusting his own reputation too much.
他不能让，我忘了那个“绿地酒馆”家伙的名字，但他不能让他给副总统和英国女王喂，你知道，垃圾。他必须掌控这一切。但卡罗，他也谈到，摩西在这一点上不可否认，尽管他一直拥有所有权力，尽管他是一个发电机。他是一个老人，他正在监督公园部门、长岛公园扩建项目、高速公路、桥梁、那些再次占据了他比书中所述更多生活的大坝。也许他只是精力分散得太厉害了，也许他只是太相信自己的声誉了。
Maybe he thinks his subordinates can get in those files and strip anything negative out before people look at them. And so he delays letting people see them, but he can only do it for so long. And then finally on May 29, 1959, he has to let these two reporters, Haddad and Kahn, who he didn't mention in detail before, but they're reporters, he says, okay, you can come to Triborough, you can look at those files, and they go there. And they go to see those files. And they are salivating. They're so excited about it. They're very excited. There's so many files and they find nothing. They really find nothing. It is such a disappointment for them.
也许他认为他的下属可以在人们查看之前进入那些文件并剔除任何负面内容。所以他推迟让人们看到它们，但他只能拖延那么久。最后在1959年5月29日，他不得不让这两个记者，哈达德和卡恩，他之前没有详细提到他们，但他们是记者，他说，好吧，你们可以来三区管理局，你们可以查看那些文件，他们就去了那里。他们去查看那些文件。他们垂涎欲滴。他们对此非常兴奋。他们非常兴奋。有这么多文件，但他们什么也没发现。他们真的什么也没发现。这对他们来说真是太失望了。
They are, first they have to wait for hours to get in and finally they go in and they're like, oh boy, nobody's looked in these files for 35 years and it is a real Geraldo with Al Capone's Vault situation where you're just like, what's in this thing? And you open it and there's, all they've got are brochures, there's formal memos, there's nothing about the project sponsors. And the thing, there's in this thing? And you open it and there's, all they've got are brochures, there's formal memos,
他们，首先他们不得不等上几个小时才能进去，最后他们进去了，他们就像，哦天哪，35年来没人看过这些文件，这真是一个杰拉尔多打开阿尔·卡彭金库的情况，你只是想，这东西里有什么？你打开它，里面有，他们得到的只有小册子，有正式的备忘录，关于项目赞助商什么都没有。而那件事，这东西里有？你打开它，里面有，他们得到的只有小册子，有正式的备忘录，
there's nothing about the project sponsors. And the thing, there's a great detail here that I love. They go to talk to Spargo, who is one of Moses' right-hand men. We haven't talked about him a huge amount, but Spargo is a hugely important part of Moses' operation. And Spargo is being so disrespectful to them that while they talk to him in his office,
关于项目赞助商什么都没有。而那件事，这里有一个我喜欢的很棒的细节。他们去和斯帕戈谈话，他是摩西的得力助手之一。我们没有谈论他太多，但斯帕戈是摩西行动中极其重要的一部分。斯帕戈对他们非常不尊重，以至于当他们在他的办公室里和他谈话时，
he just keeps eating soup through the whole meeting. And I just love this image. It is hard for me to think of a way to be more disrespectful to someone who's come to talk to you than to be eating soup, because that's a noisy thing to eat. It's a sloppy thing to eat. Well, it's like, even if you're eating it cleanly,
他整个会议期间一直在喝汤。我真的很喜欢这个形象。对我来说，很难想到比在吃汤时更不尊重来找你谈话的人的方式了，因为喝汤是一种很吵的声音。这是一种很邋遢的吃法。好吧，就像，即使你吃得很干净，
you're slurping it. You know, like it's to just be like, yeah. The only thing I can think of is if he was eating just a box of crackers and just spitting out crumbs at them the entire time, you know, every time you open his mouth, it's, oh. And Carrow, he takes a paragraph, also talk about how shabby the reporters are
你也在吸溜它。你知道，就像这只是，是的。我唯一能想到的是，如果他只是在吃一盒饼干，并且整个过程中一直在向他们喷碎屑，你知道，每次你张开嘴，哦。而卡罗，他用了一段话，也谈到了记者们是多么寒酸，
and the used car they drive compared to this kind of neatly put together Triborough officers. And so it seems like this is a bust. These files seem like they were so excited about them and they're kind of a bust. Do they give up, Roman? Do they stop looking through them?
以及他们开的二手车，与这种整洁的、拼凑在一起的三区管理局官员相比。所以看起来这是一个失败。这些文件看起来他们对此非常兴奋，但它们有点失败。他们放弃了吗，罗曼？他们停止查看了吗？
They do not. They're real reporters. They keep going and they turn kind of a bust. Do they give up Roman? Do they stop looking through them? They do not. They're real reporters. They keep going and they turn every page as a- They turn every page in the approved of Carol Manor. And they end up finding sort of like a smaller project called Mid-Harlem. They find this short letter of appreciation from Louis Pokras, who is an associate
他们没有。他们是真正的记者。他们继续前进，他们转而……有点失败。他们放弃了吗，罗曼？他们停止查看了吗？他们没有。他们是真正的记者。他们继续前进，他们翻阅每一页——他们以卡罗认可的方式翻阅每一页。他们最终发现了一个叫做“中哈莱姆”的小项目。他们发现了这封来自路易斯·波克拉斯的简短感谢信，他是一个合伙人，
of the mob boss, Frank Costello. And then it begins to become like, oh, okay. This is a real thing, because Frank Costello, nobody knows the name Louis I. Pokras, which is a great name, you know. It looks like his name is Pokras, which is a funny name. But Frank Costello has just recently been the star of these televised hearings that Senator Estes Kiefauver
属于黑帮老大弗兰克·科斯特洛。然后它开始变得像，哦，好吧。这是一件真实的事情，因为弗兰克·科斯特洛，没人知道路易斯·I·波克拉斯这个名字，这是一个很棒的名字，你知道。看起来他的名字是波克拉斯，这是一个有趣的名字。但弗兰克·科斯特洛最近刚刚成为参议员埃斯蒂斯·基福弗在电视上播出的那些听证会的主角，
did on organized crime. Everybody knows Frank Costello. It's like Al Capone. If you have Costello's name in some way connected to this, then it's gold. And they find this handwritten note from Tom Shanahan, who we mentioned in the past. He runs a big bank that all of Moses's contractors have to park their money in. And he says in this note, I've been made aware of a delicate situation involving progress, but the sponsorship gets approved anyway. And this is a story, right? This is the kind of story they can do something with. Yeah, because it just has all the characters. It has all these shorthands for people to
关于有组织犯罪。每个人都知道弗兰克·科斯特洛。就像阿尔·卡彭。如果科斯特洛的名字以某种方式与此联系在一起，那么它就是金子。他们发现了这张来自汤姆·沙纳汉的手写便条，我们过去提到过他。他经营着一家大银行，摩西所有的承包商都必须把钱存在那里。他在便条中说，我被告知了一个涉及波克拉斯的微妙情况，但赞助商还是被批准了。这是一个故事，对吧？这就是他们可以做点什么的这种故事。是的，因为它拥有所有的角色。它有所有这些速记，让人们
understand it without having to understand complex details of like, of math and numbers and things like that. It just has Costello's name on it. And therefore it's all of a sudden Title I and the mob. And it takes Moses to disprove that. You know what I mean? It's more like it's just set up to tell the story that everyone knows. And this is another one of those things for Carol goes. I don't know if this is exactly fair.
理解它，而不必理解复杂的细节，比如数学和数字之类的东西。它只是上面有科斯特洛的名字。因此，它突然变成了“第一章”和黑帮。而这需要摩西来反驳。你知道我的意思吗？这更像是它只是为了讲述每个人都知道的故事而设置的。这是卡罗又一个觉得，我不知道这是否完全公平。
This is like levels and levels and levels down from actual Moses decision-making. Yeah, like it's very unlikely. It's possible that he just handed this off to Shanahan like levels and levels and levels down from actual Moses decision making. Yeah, like it's very unlikely, it's possible that he just handed this off to Shanahan to deal with and is not aware that someone with connection to the mob was doing it. And they find this other story where they find
这就像比实际的摩西决策低了好几个层次。是的，就像这不太可能。他可能只是把这件事交给了沙纳汉，比实际的摩西决策低了好几个层次。是的，就像这不太可能，他可能只是把这件事交给了沙纳汉去处理，而不知道有人与黑帮有联系的人在做这件事。他们发现了另一个故事，他们发现
that Vincent the Chin Gigante, who had already been, it was a former attempted hitman, he was hired as a temporary night watchman. And this is what, and it damages Moses. Oh, this other mob associate was hired to work There and Moses like to be fair to Moses Moses like the man went to jail like he can't get a job now It's like this is the lowest level job How like a like a former felon was given a low-level job as a night watchman by a contractor hired by another
文森特·“下巴”·吉甘特，他已经是一个前未遂杀手，他被雇为临时夜间保安。这就是，它损害了摩西。哦，这个黑帮合伙人被雇佣在那里工作，而摩西，公平地说，摩西就像，那个人坐过牢，他现在找不到工作。这就像这是最低级别的工作，一个前重罪犯是如何被另一个承包商雇佣为夜间保安的，
Contractor hired by the project sponsor who Moses didn't necessarily hand pick and it just it's so super unfair but the only funny thing about it is that of course Vincent the Chin Gigante goes on to be a major mob figure like at that they didn't know that they couldn't have known this at the time but eventually he is leading the mob in New York in in many ways and he becomes famous and I remember I remember very well the years when because I have for decades, they used to call him the odd father because he would deliberately walk around in a bathrobe, kind of mumbling to himself in public so that people would think he
承包商由项目赞助商雇佣，而摩西并没有亲自挑选，这太不公平了，但唯一有趣的是，文森特·“下巴”·吉甘特后来成为了一个主要的黑帮人物，就像在当时他们不知道，他们不可能知道这一点，但最终他在纽约以多种方式领导黑帮，他变得出名了，我记得，我记得很清楚那些年，因为我有几十年了，他们过去叫他“怪胎教父”，因为他会故意穿着睡袍在公共场合走来走去，一边嘟囔着，这样人们就会认为他
was crazy so that the feds wouldn't, wouldn't, uh, charge him with anything. He did this for like 30 years. It was amazing. And I remember when he died, they're like, Oh, the odd father's finally gone. But this just adds to more. They don't know that he's going to become the odd father, but it adds to the dirt and most reputation that like, even this, which is the tiniest of things,
疯了，这样联邦调查局就不会，不会，呃，指控他任何事情。他这样做大约30年。这太神奇了。我记得他死的时候，他们说，哦，怪胎教父终于走了。但这只会增加更多。他们不知道他会成为怪胎教父，但这增加了污点和摩西的声誉，就像，即使是这个，这是最小的事情，
you can still put in a headline, mob hitman hired on Moses project. That's right, that's right. It's so this sort of stink of underworld stuff, it really just becomes something that he just can't get away from. And now all these really tenacious reporters who have probably dug up worse dirt,
你仍然可以在标题中写上，黑帮杀手被雇佣在摩西的项目上。没错，没错。所以这种黑社会的东西，它真的变成了一种他无法摆脱的东西。现在所有这些非常顽强的记者，他们可能挖出了更糟糕的污点，
things that Moses had a hand in directly, they see an opportunity here to just go to town on this stuff. And they start finding it. They find real stuff. They find bribes to politicians. They find sweetheart purchases by the committee of land owned by local politicians.
摩西直接参与的事情，他们在这里看到了一个机会，可以大肆渲染这些东西。他们开始发现它。他们发现了真实的东西。他们发现了给政客的贿赂。他们发现了委员会购买当地政客拥有的土地的内幕交易。
They find stories about crooked machine bosses being involved in the housing projects. And Hat Ed uncovers how important Tom Shanahan, one of the Democratic bosses, is. And he's the guy who qualifies developers mainly by getting kickbacks from them through his bank. You know, if they put his money in the bank, then they are qualified to do this, which means a lot of money for his bank, which means money for him. And the reporters are continuing that strategy we talked about of sharing information and doling out so that this paper gets it and then this paper gets it, and they are taking advantage, they're using the inborn competitiveness of the papers to keep this going.
他们发现了关于腐败的机器老板参与住房项目的报道。哈达德揭露了汤姆·沙纳汉，民主党老板之一，是多么重要。他就是那个通过他的银行从开发商那里收取回扣来使他们获得资格的人。你知道，如果他们把钱存在他的银行，那么他们就有资格做这件事，这意味着他的银行有很多钱，这意味着他有钱。而记者们正在继续我们谈到的那种分享信息和分发的策略，这样这份报纸得到了，然后那份报纸得到了，他们正在利用，他们正在利用报纸天生的竞争性来保持这一点。
And so much of this is now a matter of public record that the paper of record, the New York Times, like they can't ignore it. And they start doing a series of articles, not necessarily investigating, but synthesizing the information from the other papers articles. Classic New York Times shit right there. Yeah. Let's get into this. Let's get into this. This is an ax you've had to grind against them for a while. I just have it just like, we've just noticed this thing. It represents like reporting from a million different sources
而其中很大一部分现在已成为公共记录，以至于记录报纸《纽约时报》，他们无法忽视它。他们开始做一系列文章，不一定是调查，而是综合其他报纸文章的信息。典型的《纽约时报》烂事就在那里。是的。让我们进入这个。让我们进入这个。这是你有一段时间一直想针对他们发泄的怨气。我只是有它，就像，我们刚刚注意到这件事。它代表了来自一百万个不同来源的报道
and different newspapers already, but anyway. But now that they're talking about it, it's real. It's the exact opposite of the joke about the Times Style section used to be, well, what are the friends of Times reporters doing these days? Like, that's the style, that's what people do. There was a, oh, I loved it, there was sort of articleized,
和不同的报纸已经，但无论如何。但现在他们谈论它了，它是真实的。这与《泰晤士报》风格版曾经的笑话完全相反，好吧，泰晤士报记者的朋友们最近在做什么？就像，那是风格，那是人们做的事情。有一个，哦，我喜欢它，有一种文章化的，
I wish I had kept it, I wish I had clipped it, that was in the Times Style section years ago, where they were like, a new development among young Brooklynites, a new styles trend, the pot belly. And it was like, well no, your friends are getting older. Like that's what they're gaining weight and they're carrying it in their belly. Like that's what, this is not a style trend, you know. And they're refusing to stop wearing t-shirts. That was so funny. I gotta find that in the archives somewhere. Anyway, but now even the Times are on it. Tips are pouring in about Title I stories and the
我希望我保留了它，我希望我剪下了它，那是多年前在《泰晤士报》风格版上的，他们说，年轻布鲁克林人中的一种新发展，一种新风格趋势，啤酒肚。而这就像，好吧，不，你的朋友们变老了。就像那是他们正在增加体重，他们把它背在肚子里。就像那是，这不是一种风格趋势，你知道。而且他们拒绝停止穿T恤。那太搞笑了。我得在某个地方的档案里找到那个。无论如何，但现在连《泰晤士报》也参与进来了。关于“第一章”故事的线索源源不断，而
older reporters. Now they're starting to help the younger reporters. They're realizing that there's something there. They're late to it, but they're there. And reporters are starting to notice the names of Moses Associates on the payrolls of housing project sponsors, of the developers that are doing these projects. And Caro takes a moment. He humanizes the reporters, he talks about they feel sympathy for the families of these guys because they know we're about to write exposés of these people. They talk to a guy who they're going to write an exposé on and they see a picture of his family on his desk and they're like, yeah, I feel bad about it, but this is the story. I got to run it.
老记者们。现在他们开始帮助年轻记者了。他们意识到那里有些东西。他们迟到了，但他们到了。记者们开始注意到摩西合伙人的名字出现在住房项目赞助商的工资单上，出现在做这些项目的开发商的工资单上。卡罗花了一点时间。他使记者人性化，他谈到他们对这些人的家庭感到同情，因为他们知道我们即将写这些人的曝光文章。他们和一个他们即将写曝光文章的人交谈，他们看到他桌上有一张他家人的照片，他们就像，是的，我对此感到难过，但这是故事。我必须把它发出来。
And I think what he's doing here, I think Carol is trying to draw distinction between Moses's form of reputation destroying yeah, and this kind of more principled form that this is for this is necessary Even though there's something not great about the the effects rather than Moses which are just for the sheer accumulation of power Yeah, I think that's right I mean he he this is a book really about journalism in a lot of ways. And he's trying to sort of just give a full picture of why this type of thing is better than the other type of thing.
我认为他在这里所做的是，我认为卡罗试图在摩西那种破坏声誉的方式和这种更原则性的形式之间划清界限，这是必要的，尽管效果上有一些不太好的东西，而不是摩西那种纯粹为了权力的积累。是的，我认为那是对的。我的意思是，他，这是一本在很多方面真正关于新闻业的书。他试图以某种方式给出一个完整的图景，说明为什么这种类型的事情比另一种类型的事情更好。
And these folks are not out to destroy individuals. They really are trying to take on a system. And these are the systems that need to be taken on. And these are things that Carol obviously cares about deeply that these systems are challenged. You could say they're out to destroy one individual, Robert Moses, but at this point he has become a system. Exactly.
而这些人并不是要摧毁个人。他们确实是在试图挑战一个系统。而这些是需要被挑战的系统。这些是卡罗显然非常关心的事情，即这些系统受到挑战。你可以说他们是要摧毁一个人，罗伯特·摩西，但在这一点上，他已经成为了一个系统。没错。
Yeah, exactly. And stories soon start breaking about George Spargo, who you may remember earlier eating soup in front of some reporters, and just about how he's receiving hundreds of thousands of dollars in consulting fees, in quotes, from Moses authorities while also being the director of this shady bank that we talked about
是的，没错。关于乔治·斯帕戈的故事很快就开始传开了，你可能还记得早些时候他在一些记者面前吃汤，以及关于他如何从摩西管理局获得数十万美元的咨询费，加引号，同时还是我们谈到的那个阴暗银行的董事
a couple episodes back. It's just, he's so close to Moses that you can't help but put Moses' name, not just in the articles about corruption, but in the headlines. Yeah, which is what everyone reads. Everyone reads the headlines, yeah. I mean, you can't help but glance at it. Exactly, you take it in.
几集前。这只是，他离摩西太近了，你忍不住把摩西的名字，不仅放在关于腐败的文章中，而且放在标题中。是的，这是每个人都读的。每个人都读标题，是的。我的意思是，你忍不住瞥一眼。没错，你接受了它。
It's right there. Yeah. And Moses responds with official statements, but that only serves him to tie him closer to the stories, you know, and he strikes out at the press in petty ways. He stops telling them when committee meetings are beheld. He locks the hallway at Trierboro where there's a vending machine
它就在那里。是的。摩西用官方声明回应，但这只会让他与这些故事联系得更紧密，你知道，他以琐碎的方式抨击媒体。他停止告诉他们委员会会议在哪里举行。他锁上了三区管理局的走廊，那里有一个自动售货机
that the reporters have been using to get snacks while they're working. And the more he attacks the press, the more he gives them a reason to hit him back. You know, he is now hurting them in a way that is making the papers mad at him. And the Times starts having this divided relationship with him where it's gonna print these stories
记者们在工作时一直用它来买零食。他攻击媒体越多，他给他们回击他的理由就越多。你知道，他现在以一种让报纸对他生气的方式伤害他们。而《泰晤士报》开始与他建立这种分裂的关系，它会打印这些故事
about problems with his projects and then print his reaction as news and is still printing editorials saying, oh, if Moses resigns, it would be irreparable loss. You don't bench Babe Ruth, you know. The owners of the Times, they're still trying to keep their relationship with Moses, but the editorial staff, they cannot ignore these stories. There's real
关于他项目的问题，然后把他的反应作为新闻打印出来，并且仍然在打印社论说，哦，如果摩西辞职，那将是不可弥补的损失。你不会让贝比·鲁斯坐冷板凳，你知道。《泰晤士报》的老板们，他们仍然试图保持与摩西的关系，但编辑人员，他们无法忽视这些故事。有真正的
news value. And Caro is like, time out, the new media, they're chopping away at the supports of this Moses reputation. And he uses again that Moses quote from the chapter a little bit ago about the synthetic character of the statesman that was built up by the press and then deflated unfairly but truthfully. And he talks about how Al Smith had said, told him popularity is a slender read to lean on. And he says, now that read was broken. But here's the thing, Roman, does Moses still need to be popular to be powerful? He doesn't because he's already built up this war chest.
新闻价值。而卡罗就像，暂停，新媒体，他们正在砍掉摩西声誉的支撑。他再次使用了摩西在不久前那一章中关于被媒体建立起来然后被不公平但真实地贬低的政治家合成性格的引语。他谈到阿尔·史密斯曾告诉他，受欢迎程度是一根脆弱的芦苇。他说，现在那根芦苇断了。但这里的问题是，罗曼，摩西还需要受欢迎才能有权力吗？他不需要，因为他已经建立了这个战争基金。
Like he controls all this money right now still. So, so this is a big deal. So like as the sort of PR, love of the public, all that can erode because now he has this war chest. He's already kind of abandoned the need for public approval a little bit before this. He's never been quite a villain, but he just didn't need like people to like cheer him on
就像他现在仍然控制着所有这些钱。所以，所以这是一个大问题。所以，就像那种公关，公众的爱，所有这些都可以被侵蚀，因为现在他有了这个战争基金。他已经在某种程度上放弃了对公众认可的需求，在这之前。他从来都不是一个恶棍，但他只是不需要人们为他欢呼
for him to do his things. But he still has this problem of like, everyone in politics needs jobs in their ward, and to be reelected, and he still controls that money. There's still this unshakable logic, yeah, that real political power comes from money and jobs and being able to provide those, and he's the only one who can provide them.
让他做他的事情。但他仍然有这个问题，比如，政治中的每个人都需要他们选区的就业机会，为了连任，而他仍然控制着那些钱。仍然有这种不可动摇的逻辑，是的，真正的政治权力来自金钱和就业机会，以及能够提供这些的能力，而他是唯一能提供它们的人。
And so the newspapers are like, certainly now the mayor will fire Robert Moses. And of course they can't, because there's just too much money, there's too many jobs, there's too much need for the political machine for that. And also that Mayor Wagner, if he can avoid it, he's not gonna fire anybody.
所以报纸就像，当然现在市长会解雇罗伯特·摩西。当然他们不能，因为钱太多了，就业机会太多了，政治机器对那个的需求太多了。而且瓦格纳市长，如果他能避免，他不会解雇任何人。
He's a guy who wants to be liked. He doesn't like firing people. Yeah, and he has this longstanding relationship with Moses. I mean, his father knew Moses. You know, like it's, you know, it's just- He's known Moses since he was a little boy. You know, and he says at one point to somebody,
他是一个想被喜欢的人。他不喜欢解雇人。是的，他和摩西有长期的关系。我的意思是，他父亲认识摩西。你知道，就像它，你知道，它只是——他从小就认识摩西。你知道，他在某个时候对某人说，
I forget if he says to Kara, somebody says, you don't fire your father. You can't fire your father. Like Moses is a father figure to him in many ways. But even if Wagner did fire him from his city posts, Moses would still, he'd have five New York state jobs. He'd still be the chairman of the tribal authority. All firing him would do would make an enemy
我忘了他是对卡罗说，还是某人说，你不会解雇你的父亲。你不能解雇你的父亲。就像摩西在很多方面是他的父亲形象。但即使瓦格纳确实解雇了他的城市职位，摩西仍然会，他会有五个纽约州的工作。他仍然会是三区管理局的主席。解雇他只会制造一个敌人
out of someone who is still massively powerful. That's right. And still has access to all this money that Wagner believes the city needs. And so he can't risk giving Moses a reason to throw his power behind one of his opponents. What if he endorsed someone in the next election and it wasn't Mayor Wagner?
来自一个仍然拥有巨大权力的人。没错。而且仍然有权使用瓦格纳认为城市需要的所有这些钱。所以他不能冒险给摩西一个理由，把他的权力投向他的对手之一。如果他在下次选举中支持某人，而那个人不是瓦格纳市长呢？
And the press doesn't know any of this because they don't have access to the documents that would show them how the democratic machine actually works with Robert Moses. And Carroll also says the press misunderstood the relationship because of what he calls the wishes predilection to be father of the thought, which I think is such a beautiful phrase,
而媒体对此一无所知，因为他们没有获得那些能向他们展示民主党机器实际上是如何与罗伯特·摩西合作的文件。卡罗还说，媒体误解了这种关系，因为他所说的“愿望是思想之父”，我认为这是一个如此美丽的短语，
and I don't know if he's quoting it somewhere, if it's a famous phrase or whatever, but the idea that I want this to be the case, so I think it is gonna be the case. I am gonna think it's that way. They want Wagner to fire Moses, so they assume that Wagner will do it and wants to do it. And every time Wagner stalls, the press takes that to mean
我不知道他是在哪里引用的，如果这是一个著名的短语还是什么，但那种想法是，我希望这是真的，所以我认为它会是这样。我会认为它是那样。他们希望瓦格纳解雇摩西，所以他们假设瓦格纳会这样做，并且想这样做。而每次瓦格纳拖延，媒体就认为
that he will eventually do it, that he just hasn't done it yet. It's so fascinating. But one of the things that's again, a new thing, a new turn in Moses, who's now 74 years old. So I'm glad he can learn a few new things. Yeah, yeah, of course, yeah. This old dog's got some new tricks in him.
他最终会这样做，他只是还没做而已。这太迷人了。但其中一件事，再次，摩西的一个新事物，现在74岁了。所以我很高兴他能学到一些新东西。是的，是的，当然，是的。这只老狗身上有一些新把戏。
Is he's recognizing that the source of all of his misery is this Title I stuff. Like, you know, he knows that this is just out of control for him. He knows parks, he knows highways, and he knows dams apparently, but I don't know anything about him knowing dams, but I didn't read about that.
是他认识到他所有痛苦的根源是这些“第一章”的东西。就像，你知道，他知道这对他来说已经失控了。他了解公园，他了解高速公路，显然他还了解大坝，但我不知道他了解大坝的任何事情，但我没读到过。
This book certainly wouldn't tell you too much about it. But he figures it out. Yeah, but you're right. Like, he was never really that interested in housing as a thing. This book certainly wouldn't tell you too much about it. But he figures it out. Yeah. But you're right that like, he was never really that interested in housing as a thing. He saw it as a source of power and a source of money, and now that money is starting to dry up, the power is starting to dry up.
这本书当然不会告诉你太多关于它的事情。但他弄明白了。是的，但你是对的。就像，他从来没有真正对住房作为一件事感兴趣。这本书当然不会告诉你太多关于它的事情。但他弄明白了。是的。但你是对的，就像，他从来没有真正对住房作为一件事感兴趣。他把它看作是权力的来源和金钱的来源，现在钱开始枯竭，权力开始枯竭。
It's becoming more of a hassle. And the press thinks, Oh, Moses won't let go of title one housing. He just holds onto it with his vulture like clause. But the people around Moses starting to become convinced that he doesn't really want to do it anymore. That he would be happy to leave it, but he can't do it while the press is hounding him
它变得越来越麻烦。而媒体认为，哦，摩西不会放手“第一章”住房。他只是用他那秃鹫般的爪子紧紧抓住它。但摩西周围的人开始确信他不再真正想做这件事了。他会很高兴离开它，但他不能在媒体追捕他的时候这样做
or else it'll look like they won. And the thing he hates more than anything else is to look like he's losing. But wait, what if an exit strategy came along? That's right. What if a perfect exit came along? But what would that be? What could possibly be an exit
否则看起来就像他们赢了。而他最讨厌的事情就是看起来像他输了。但等等，如果有一个退出策略呢？没错。如果有一个完美的退出呢？但那会是什么？什么可能是一个退出
that would allow him to leave this realm of construction while still saving face and looking like it was his idea? What could that be? Well, it's a brand new thing that everyone loves. The 1964 New York World's Fair is coming, and they need someone who knows how to get things done and build things fast and take care of business. And he decides that if he can focus on that and let go of title one, then
那将允许他离开这个建设领域，同时仍然保住面子，看起来像是他的主意？那会是什么？好吧，这是一个每个人都喜欢的新事物。1964年纽约世界博览会即将到来，他们需要一个知道如何把事情做好、快速建造东西并处理业务的人。他决定，如果他能专注于那个并放手“第一章”，那么
he can sort of save face. He doesn't have to, you know, be, he's not hounded out. He has this new shiny new thing that only he can achieve. And therefore it just gives him a way out, uh, making himself look good. Yes. And, and he's got even, even though even more reasons waiting, he needs money. He has, he's a guy who he has 71 years old. He is still supporting some of his children. His wife is in such bad health
他可以某种程度上保住面子。他不必，你知道，被，他没有被追赶出去。他有这个新的闪亮的新事物，只有他能实现。因此，它只是给了他一条出路，呃，让自己看起来不错。是的。而且，他有更多，即使有更多等待的理由，他需要钱。他是一个71岁的人。他仍然在支持他的一些孩子。他的妻子健康状况非常糟糕
that she needs round the clock nursing care. He needs money and he doesn't make a lot of money from his jobs. That's part of his whole thing. He's the guy who doesn't make money from his jobs. He doesn't care about money. And the World's Fair presidency, which has offered him, would pay him a lot of money.
以至于她需要全天候的护理。他需要钱，而他从他的工作中赚不到很多钱。这是他整个事情的一部分。他是那个不从工作中赚钱的人。他不关心钱。而世界博览会主席，提供给他的，会付给他很多钱。
It's a pretty good job. I forgot about this part, but yeah, that lot of money. It's a pretty good job. Yeah, I forgot about this part, but yeah, that is a thing. Like he, it has the sort of veneer of this sort of same, you know, civic duty, because it sort of bolsters and boosters the New York area. These World Fairs are a very big deal, but this is like, this is a job job.
这是一份相当不错的工作。我忘了这一部分，但是的，那很多钱。这是一份相当不错的工作。是的，我忘了这一部分，但是的，那是一件事。就像他，它有一种这种同样的，你知道，公民义务的表象，因为它某种程度上支持和促进了纽约地区。这些世界博览会是一件大事，但这就像，这是一份工作，工作。
You know, this is a high pain job. This is a real job, yeah. This is essentially a private job. He is entering the private sector in it in a big way. And it sets into motion this other thing, which is it's one of those things that whereas he was able way back when when LaGuardia was trying to get him to be in charge of all of the parks and other aspects like where he was, he changed the law to like both work in the state and the city and have these dual appointments,
你知道，这是一份高薪工作。这是一份真正的工作，是的。这本质上是一份私人工作。他正在以一种大的方式进入私营部门。它启动了另一件事，那就是它是那种事情之一，鉴于他在很久以前拉瓜迪亚试图让他负责所有公园和其他方面时，他改变了法律，比如既在州又在市工作，并拥有这些双重任命，
even though they were in conflict to each other. This creates a conflict that is sort of untenable. He can't be ahead of this private corporation and be the person who would approve those things. And it sets up a little bit of this unwinding of his sort of like, this rope of like like that he's built through all these different cords that is uncuttable, you know, because he just has to let go of some of his public stuff if he's going to be in charge of the fair. And he sees it as in some ways a trading up, it is worth letting go of those things, which he feels he has expended a lot of the power from
尽管它们之间存在冲突。这制造了一种难以维持的矛盾。他不可能既是这家私营公司的负责人，又是批准那些项目的人。这导致了他多年来建立的那种牢不可破的权力纽带开始松动，因为如果他想负责世博会，就必须放弃一些公共职务。在某种程度上，他认为这是一种升级，放弃那些他觉得已经耗尽了权力的东西是值得的。
for this new thing, which will bring in new power and new money, and it's also gonna be more fun, probably. Like this is a guy, he liked making the Central Park Zoo. He liked making Jones Beach. He doesn't love building public housing. And so it is a way, I think, in his mind of cutting that Gordian knot. Yeah, he can unwind these things
为了这个新事物，它将带来新的权力和新的金钱，而且可能更有趣。他就是这样一个人，他喜欢建造中央公园动物园，喜欢建造琼斯海滩。他并不热衷于建造公共住房。所以，我认为在他看来，这是解开那个“戈耳狄俄斯之结”的一种方式。是的，他可以解开这些东西。
by just getting rid of the problem. And so he takes the thing that was hurting his reputation, Title I, his city jobs, and he trades them for this other thing that he thinks is gonna build it back up. And so he works out this arrangement with the mayor that they are first gonna have the legislator, first they're gonna have a legislature
通过摆脱这些问题。于是，他拿走了那些损害他声誉的东西——第一章（Title I）、他的城市职务，并用它们换取了他认为能重建声誉的新事物。他与市长达成了一项安排，他们首先要让立法机构通过一项法律。
pass a law exempting officers of the fair from the city's code of ethics, which should be a red flag right there. But then he starts resigning from his city jobs. He resigns as the city park commissioner. He resigns from the city planning commission. He resigns from the committee on slum clearance. He recommends that his job as the construction coordinator be abolished as it is no longer necessary now that he's not doing it. And the press is like, oh, Wagner's trying to push out Moses. But Moses is doing this all himself.
通过一项法律，豁免世博会官员遵守城市的道德准则，这本身就应该是一个危险信号。但他开始辞去他的城市职务。他辞去了城市公园专员的职务。他辞去了城市规划委员会的职务。他辞去了贫民窟清理委员会的职务。他建议废除他的建设协调员职位，因为既然他不干了，这个职位就不再必要了。媒体都在说，哦，瓦格纳正试图排挤摩西。但摩西这一切都是自己做的。
He leaves in triumph from these jobs. And there's this 1,044 person dinner where everyone pays a hundred dollars a plate to be there. This is in 1959. And the city's power elite, they give him a standing ovation. He is leaving at seemingly the height of his power to take on this other stuff.
他带着胜利离开了这些职位。当时有一场1044人的晚宴，每个人花一百美元买票入场。那是1959年。城市的权力精英们为他起立鼓掌。他似乎是在权力的巅峰时期离开，去承担其他事务。
He's getting rid of the things that were hurting his reputation. Not only that, his replacement at the Parks Department is this guy, Newbold Morris, again, a great name. I love the first name Newbold, especially because he is a very much not a bold man and he does not have new ideas. And he is, Carol portrays him as this like well-meaning bumbler who is so eager to do whatever Robert Moses tells him. And he tells a story about a reporter calling Morris and Mars says let me call you right back about that and then the reporter calls Moses his private number Which is busy and then Mars calls him back and tells him what Moses told him to say like he immediately got off phone and called Moses like Morris and Moses are even similar sounding names
他正在摆脱那些损害他声誉的事情。不仅如此，他在公园部门的继任者是纽博尔德·莫里斯（Newbold Morris），又是一个很棒的名字。我喜欢“纽博尔德”这个名字，尤其是因为他一点也不“大胆”（bold），也没有什么新想法。卡罗把他描绘成一个好心但笨手笨脚的人，非常渴望做罗伯特·摩西告诉他的一切。他讲了一个故事，说有记者打电话给莫里斯，莫里斯说让我回电给你，然后记者打给摩西的私人号码，结果占线，接着莫里斯回电告诉记者摩西让他说的话，就像他挂了电话立刻就打给摩西一样。莫里斯和摩西听起来名字都很像。
So and Moses still controls the federal and state highway programs in New York. So what's clear is so the city stuff has all been resigned in order to take this job for the World's Fair. The federal and state highway program stuff is still that still stuff that he has control of. But because so much of his power was drawn from having the connections between the two and then if he was let go of one, he would be in control of another. It really does just erode one of his, like, the legs of his stool here, you know what I mean, by having this one. And, because now, you know, when it comes to state authority,
所以，摩西仍然控制着纽约的联邦和州公路项目。很明显，他辞去城市职务是为了接手世博会的工作。联邦和州公路项目仍然是他控制的范围。但由于他的大部分权力来自于两者之间的联系，如果他放弃了一个，而另一个又被别人控制，这确实削弱了他权力支柱的一条腿，你明白我的意思吗？因为现在，当涉及到州政府权力时，
there is a new person in charge who can take that power away from him. Yes. What he's got in accomplice, so that we're gonna meet someone in the next chapter is a very fun person to talk about who is going to be a little bit more than Moses can handle, but this guy has an accomplice and that accomplice's name is Robert Moses because as Caro says, only Robert Moses
有一个新的负责人可以从他手中夺走权力。是的。他有一个同谋，我们将在下一章见到一个非常有趣的人，他会让摩西难以应付，但这个人有一个同谋，那个同谋的名字就是罗伯特·摩西，因为正如卡罗所说，只有罗伯特·摩西
could lose Robert Moses his power and he did. Okay, this is chapter 46 and it's just called Nelson. It's not about the band Nelson. I'm sorry, everybody. It stands for Nelson Rockefeller and, uh, oh my God, this is it. This is it. Buckle up. This is the chapter you've been waiting for.
才能让罗伯特·摩西失去权力，而他确实做到了。好了，这是第46章，标题就叫“纳尔逊”。不是关于纳尔逊乐队，抱歉大家。它代表纳尔逊·洛克菲勒，天哪，就是这个。就是这个。系好安全带。这就是你们一直在等待的章节。
You've, you've sat through hours and hours of us talking, waiting for Moses to finally get what he was getting. And this is when he gets it. It's Nelson. And so, yeah, the Nelson here, as she says, Nelson Rockefeller, in 1959, he is the new New York governor. And Nelson Rockefeller, Caro tells us, he's a little different from the previous governors
你们听了我们几个小时的谈话，等着摩西最终得到他应得的下场。这就是他得到报应的时候。是纳尔逊。所以，是的，这里的纳尔逊，正如她所说，纳尔逊·洛克菲勒，在1959年，他是新任纽约州州长。而纳尔逊·洛克菲勒，卡罗告诉我们，他与之前的州长有点不同。
that Moses has dealt with. He is not quite the same type of politician. What's the reason for this? Because Nelson Rockefeller, as you can tell from his last name, is enormously rich, like cosmically rich. Absolutely rich. And they're basically, you know,
摩西曾与之打交道的那些人。他不是那种类型的政治家。原因是什么？因为纳尔逊·洛克菲勒，正如你从他的姓氏中可以看出的，非常有钱，简直是富可敌国。绝对富有。基本上，你知道，
he mentions that the Rockefeller family has basically been bankrolling the Republican Party. Basically like, it pays for the Republicans. So anything that they wanna do, you know, it's just up to him and his family. So like, the idea that Moses controls a lot of money, it's just nonsense to him. This is a guy, this is a guy like that, his grandfather was the richest man potentially
他提到洛克菲勒家族基本上一直在资助共和党。基本上就是，他们为共和党买单。所以他们想做的任何事情，你知道，都取决于他和他的家族。所以，摩西控制着很多钱的想法，对他来说简直是无稽之谈。这是一个祖父曾经可能是世界上最富有的人的人。
in the world, you know, when he was alive. This is a guy who, Kara talks about, he has a ranch in Venezuela that is five times as large as the combined boroughs of New York City. Like this guy owns so much, his brother controls Chase Manhattan Bank. At the time, Caro says, probably the most powerful financial institution in the world.
在他活着的时候。卡罗谈到，这个人拥有的牧场在委内瑞拉，面积是纽约市所有行政区总和的五倍。这家伙拥有的东西太多了，他的兄弟控制着大通曼哈顿银行。卡罗说，在当时，这可能是世界上最有权势的金融机构。
They have a controlling stake in Con Edison, where almost everyone gets their power from. Like they are so rich and they have so many sources of power in a way that Robert Moses just can't with his rinky dink bridges, you know, his authorities, things like that, like just can't do it. This family is so powerful that Nelson's brother,
他们在联合爱迪生公司拥有控股权，几乎每个人都从那里获取电力。他们太有钱了，拥有如此多的权力来源，而罗伯特·摩西那些破烂的桥梁、他的管理局之类的东西，根本无法相比。这个家族太强大了，以至于纳尔逊的兄弟，
David Rockefeller, his lawyer is former governor Thomas Dewey. Like one of the, one of the major governors is his, it works for him. You know, it's crazy. And so Nelson Rockefeller is like, I want to be governor. And he basically buys his way into the office. He, like you said, he, if he tells the Republican party, I want to be governor, then it's crazy. And so Nelson Rockefeller was like, I wanna be governor. And he basically buys his way into the office.
大卫·洛克菲勒，他的律师是前州长托马斯·杜威。像这样一位主要州长竟然为他工作。这太疯狂了。所以纳尔逊·洛克菲勒说，我想当州长。他基本上是买通了进入办公室的道路。他告诉共和党，我想当州长，这太疯狂了。所以纳尔逊·洛克菲勒说，我想当州长。他基本上是买通了进入办公室的道路。
Like you said, if he tells the Republican party, I wanna be governor, then it's gonna happen. But he also plays politics well. This is a guy, he's gonna run for president years later. He's gonna be vice president years later. He's a real political figure. And he's good also in a way that other governors have not been at visualizing the pros and the cons
就像你说的，如果他告诉共和党，我想当州长，那就会发生。但他也很擅长政治。这家伙后来还要竞选总统。他后来还要当副总统。他是一个真正的政治人物。而且他擅长以其他州长所不具备的方式去构想大型建筑计划的利弊。
of big building plans. He can't think of these big plans, but he's really good at looking at someone else's plan for a massive project and seeing what's good or what's bad about it. And he was really heavily involved in Rockefeller Center when it was a new thing, when he was 30 years old, when his father was building it.
他自己想不出这些宏大的计划，但他非常擅长审视别人为大型项目制定的计划，并看出其中的优缺点。当洛克菲勒中心还是个新事物时，他30岁，当时他父亲正在建造它，他参与得非常深。
And so as governor, he has these big building plans that he wants to do. And so he has that in common with Robert Moses that he has big infrastructure dreams And so he has that in common with Robert Moses, that he has big infrastructure dreams. What he also has in common with Robert Moses is he is incredibly arrogant, he's incredibly stubborn. And Caro describes it as a serene sense that because his motives are pure,
所以作为州长，他有他想做的宏大建筑计划。所以他和罗伯特·摩西有共同点，那就是他有宏大的基础设施梦想。他和罗伯特·摩西的另一个共同点是，他极其傲慢，极其固执。卡罗将其描述为一种宁静的信念，因为他的动机是纯洁的，
his decisions are right. Like he's wealthy, he's a wealthy man, he's always been wealthy. He was born basically with the assumption, what I want is gonna happen. And I want it, so it must be the right thing. I'm gonna get it if I want it. And Carol says, Rockefeller's arrogance,
所以他的决定就是正确的。他是个富有的人，一直都很富有。他出生时基本上就带着一种假设：我想要的就会发生。我想要它，所以它一定是正确的事情。如果我想要，我就能得到。卡罗说，洛克菲勒的傲慢，
it's different from the abrasive, hard arrogance of Robert Moses. Robert Moses has this kind of like poking you arrogance, whereas Nelson Rockefeller's is the easy, gracious arrogance of someone who does not have to prove himself, who just takes it for granted, you will listen to me. And he is ruthless, but he's ruthless in a way that assumes I will win.
与罗伯特·摩西那种尖锐、强硬的傲慢不同。罗伯特·摩西有一种那种“戳你一下”的傲慢，而纳尔逊·洛克菲勒的傲慢是那种不需要证明自己的人所拥有的轻松、优雅的傲慢，他认为理所当然，你会听我的。他很无情，但他那种无情是建立在“我会赢”的假设之上的。
And it's something that Robert Moses has never really had to face ever in his career. Yeah, yeah. I mean, what the two share is this love of cosplaying in a hard hat. They do, they both love that thing. Yes, that's true. And they do love.
这是罗伯特·摩西职业生涯中从未真正面对过的东西。是的，是的。我的意思是，两人共同点是这种喜欢戴着安全帽扮演建筑工人的爱好。他们确实都喜欢那个。是的，那是真的。他们确实喜欢。
Neither of them are engineers or construction contractors, but they like to be around a site. Yes, that's true. And they do love- Neither of them are engineers or construction contractors, but they like to be around a site. Yeah. And they understand the power of money. And what's so funny is up until the previous thousand pages, what Caro has really demonstrated is that these nickels and dimes, what fortune they amass to make Robert Moses able to do what he has done. And then right at this moment when Nelson Rockefeller enters the scene, all of a sudden there are
他们都不是工程师或建筑承包商，但他们喜欢待在工地上。是的，那是真的。他们确实喜欢——他们都不是工程师或建筑承包商，但他们喜欢待在工地上。是的。而且他们了解金钱的力量。有趣的是，在之前的一千页里，卡罗真正展示的是，这些零钱积累起来的财富，让罗伯特·摩西能够做他所做的事情。然后在纳尔逊·洛克菲勒登场的这一刻，突然间又出现了
nickels and dimes again. And it's like, you don't understand what money is. And it's really something. If there was ever a guy who was burning thousand dollar bills to light his cigars, like it's this guy. So yeah, all the change that commuters are throwing in is nothing. And, and Caro says, survey the whole vast cast of characters on the New York political scene. And there was only one man who could with impunity confront and defeat Robert Moses, the man who is now governor. Like this is, this is going to be bad for Moses. And Caro's like, Moses should see this. He should recognize how tough Rockefeller is going to be bad for Moses. And Carol's like, Moses should see this. He should recognize how tough Rockefeller's going to be. But the old Moses is no longer interested in kind of understanding who he's up against.
零钱。这就像是，你不明白钱是什么。这真的很特别。如果曾经有一个人烧掉一千美元的钞票来点雪茄，那就是这家伙。所以，通勤者扔进来的所有零钱根本不算什么。卡罗说，审视纽约政治舞台上庞大的角色阵容，只有一个人能够毫无顾忌地对抗并击败罗伯特·摩西，那就是现在担任州长的这个人。这这对摩西来说会很糟糕。卡罗说，摩西应该看到这一点。他应该认识到洛克菲勒有多强硬。但老摩西不再有兴趣去了解他的对手是谁了。
And Moses and Rockefeller have a history. He's worked with the Rockefeller family. He's worked with Nelson Rockefeller. Like Nelson Rockefeller worked with him on getting the UN into New York. So like they've worked together. He thinks he has the measure of him. And, um, Moses is in his 70s, Rockefeller is 50. And so Moses is like, this young man, I can be fatherly towards him. I can assume
摩西和洛克菲勒有渊源。他曾与洛克菲勒家族合作过。他曾与纳尔逊·洛克菲勒合作过。比如纳尔逊·洛克菲勒曾与他合作将联合国引入纽约。所以他们合作过。他认为他了解他。而且，摩西已经70多岁了，洛克菲勒50岁。所以摩西觉得，这个年轻人，我可以对他表现出父爱。我可以假设
his support because I think he kind of sees him like Wagner, where Wagner is like, I'm a young man, Moses is an old man, I look up to him, I have to listen to him. And the difference again is that Wagner is not colossally like globally rich in the way that Rockefeller is. And so conflict seems inevitable. They're huge arrogant fish in this New York state sized pond and there's one early point of conflict. Rockefeller has this aide who's a former NYU professor, go NYU, my alma mater, William J. Ronan,
他的支持，因为我觉得他有点像瓦格纳，瓦格纳就像是，我是个年轻人，摩西是个老人，我仰望他，我必须听他的。而区别再次在于，瓦格纳不像洛克菲勒那样拥有全球性的巨额财富。所以冲突似乎是不可避免的。他们是纽约州这个池塘里两条巨大的傲慢的鱼，有一个早期的冲突点。洛克菲勒有一位助手，是前纽约大学教授，威廉·J·罗南（William J. Ronan），
who has sparred with Moses in the past and recommended abolishing the State Council of Parks and putting it under the Department of Conservation. And Moses is like, nope, that's not going to happen. And nothing happens. And I think Moses takes from that, oh, I can push these people around the same way that I pushed everyone else around. But Rockefeller starts intruding on the territory that Moses considers his territory, essentially parks and Long Island parks, especially. And Nelson Rockefeller's brother, Lawrence, his name is spelled L-A-U, like the fancy way of spelling Lawrence, not L-A-W like the normal people would.
他过去曾与摩西发生过争执，并建议废除州公园委员会，将其置于保护部之下。摩西说，不，那不会发生。结果什么也没发生。我想摩西从中得出结论，哦，我可以像摆布其他人一样摆布这些人。但洛克菲勒开始侵入摩西认为是自己领地的领域，主要是公园和长岛公园。纳尔逊·洛克菲勒的兄弟劳伦斯（Lawrence），他的名字拼写是L-A-U，那种花哨的拼写方式，而不是普通人用的L-A-W。
He starts getting involved in having the state acquire more parkland, and Moses is like, great, I want more parkland. But in 1960, Rockefeller wants this massive state mass transit program put into place, and transit is Moses' thing, and he puts Ronan, Moses new nemesis. He makes him his closest advisor
他开始参与让州政府收购更多的公园用地，摩西说，太好了，我想要更多的公园用地。但在1960年，洛克菲勒想要实施一项大规模的州公共交通计划，而交通是摩西的地盘，他让罗南，摩西的新宿敌，成为他最亲密的顾问，
and has him looking at this program. And the first big battle that's kind of around these, these kind of shared interests that they're gonna squabble over is over Moses age. Like I said, he's 70 years old at this point. When Rockefeller becomes governor, 65 is the mandated state retirement age. Legally, if you work for the state,
并让他负责这个项目。他们将要争吵的第一个围绕这些共同利益的大战是关于摩西的年龄。就像我说的，他当时70岁了。当洛克菲勒成为州长时，65岁是法定的州退休年龄。从法律上讲，如果你为州政府工作，
you have to retire at 65, unless the governor state retirement age legally. If you work for the state, you have to retire at 65, unless the governor signs an age extension and you can sign them for up to two years. And previous governors, they would sign them as early as possible. They'd sign them for two years. Rockefeller, he'll only give Moses one year extensions and he always waits as close to Moses's birthday
你必须在65岁退休，除非州长签署年龄延期，你可以签署最长两年的延期。以前的州长，他们会尽可能早地签署。他们会签署两年。洛克菲勒，他只会给摩西一年一年的延期，而且他总是等到摩西生日快到的时候
as possible. So in the days leading up to Moses's birthday, which should be a time for, you know, excited celebration, instead he is agonizing over whether the governor is going to sign this extension and let him keep his jobs. Yeah, yeah. Which really begins to eat at him. I mean, like, you can tell that where Lisa S. Caro describes it, you know, he is an older man. He's perceived as an older man. He has these hearing aids. He can't hear as well. You know, they think that maybe this is one of the reasons why Rockefeller, like, feels like he can do this, you know what I mean? Because the world is perceiving Moses as older too. Yes, and I have to assume when you're in a meeting with
才签署。所以在摩西生日前的几天里，本应是兴奋庆祝的时刻，他却在为州长是否会签署延期让他保住工作而苦恼。是的，是的。这真的开始折磨他了。我的意思是，你可以看出卡罗描述的那样，他是一个老人。他被视为一个老人。他戴着助听器。他听力不太好。你知道，他们认为这可能是洛克菲勒觉得他可以这样做的一个原因，你明白我的意思吗？因为世界也觉得摩西老了。是的，我必须假设当你和
Moses, he probably comes off as very old. Caro describes him as not really being able to hear what people are saying, so he just kind of assumes what people will say, which reminds me of a story about my wife's grandmother that she refused to wear a hearing aid. At one point she was eating dinner with their family and her dad said something about like, how's the food? And she said, the doctor says it's fine because she was responding to the question
摩西开会时，他可能看起来非常老。卡罗描述他听不清别人在说什么，所以他只是假设别人会说什么，这让我想起我妻子祖母的一个故事，她拒绝戴助听器。有一次她和家人吃晚饭，她爸爸问了句“食物怎么样？”，她说“医生说没问题”，因为她在回答她
she thought she was being asked rather than the question she was actually being asked. And it feels like Moses is doing that stuff. And so Rockefeller has this sense, Moses has agreed to transfer the parks department to my brother Lawrence. And Moses has this sense that will happen agreed to transfer the Parks Department to my brother Lawrence. And Moses has this sense, that will happen way in the future whenever I decide it.
以为被问到的问题，而不是实际被问到的问题。摩西似乎也在做同样的事情。所以洛克菲勒有一种感觉，摩西已经同意将公园部门移交给我的兄弟劳伦斯。摩西有一种感觉，那会在遥远的未来，等我决定的时候再发生。
And this comes to a head in 1962, the first appearance of Spider-Man that year. Moses' 74th birthday is approaching. And Rockefeller and Moses, they're having lunch to kind of smooth over this disagreement over when Moses will transfer the parks, the state parks to Lawrence Rockefeller. And nobody knows exactly what happens in this lunch,
这在1962年达到顶峰，那一年也是蜘蛛侠首次亮相。摩西的74岁生日临近了。洛克菲勒和摩西正在吃午饭，试图平息关于摩西何时将州公园移交给劳伦斯·洛克菲勒的分歧。没人确切知道那顿午饭发生了什么，
but Moses ends up storming out and Rockefeller goes out on the sidewalk and is trying to pull him back into the building. And Moses shakes himself out of his hands and gets in his car and he leaves the governor standing on the sidewalk being like, come on, come on. Like this is crazy. And Moses tells Sid Shapiro and he says,
但摩西最终冲了出去，洛克菲勒走到人行道上试图把他拉回大楼。摩西甩开他的手，上了车，把州长留在了人行道上，就像是“来吧，来吧”。这太疯狂了。摩西告诉了西德·夏皮罗（Sid Shapiro），他说，
don't tell anybody about this. But of course Sid Shapiro tells Caro, because Sid Shapiro loves to talk to Robert Caro. That Rockefeller said, he kind of holds up in his hand an extension of Moses's presidency of the Long Island State Park Commission. In his other hand, he holds up this kind of transition of the State Council of Parks chairmanship to Lawrence.
别告诉任何人这件事。但当然西德·夏皮罗告诉了卡罗，因为西德·夏皮罗喜欢和罗伯特·卡罗聊天。洛克菲勒说，他一只手拿着摩西的长岛州立公园委员会主席职位的延期文件。另一只手拿着将州公园委员会主席职位移交给劳伦斯的过渡文件。
And what Moses feels is this is a quid pro quo. You're saying you won't extend it unless I sign this up to Lawrence. And Moses goes, well, maybe I should just resign all of my state posts then. And Rockefeller's like, no, I just want you to resign the Council of Parks position, that's all I want. And Moses is like, they're all connected.
摩西觉得这是一种交换条件。你在说，除非我把这个签给劳伦斯，否则你不会延期。摩西说，好吧，那我就辞去我所有的州政府职务好了。洛克菲勒说，不，我只是想让你辞去公园委员会的职位，这就是我想要的。摩西说，它们都是连在一起的。
And he storms out when Rockefeller says, don't tell anyone about this conversation. And Moses is in his arrogance is like, well, I defeated the governor. He wanted me to hand over this conversation. And Moses is in his arrogance is like, well, I defeated the governor. Yeah. He wanted me to, to hand over this power. And I said, no, I'll resign everything if you
当洛克菲勒说“别告诉任何人这次谈话”时，他冲了出去。摩西在傲慢中想，好吧，我击败了州长。他想让我交出权力。而我说了不，如果你
make me do that. And he gave in cause I didn't do it. Ignoring, I guess, the fact that he stormed out of the building. Like it's not, he's like, I showed the governor a thing or two as if the conversation ended. And he's, I guess, hanging out with a friendly editor at the daily news.
强迫我这样做，我就辞去一切。他让步了，因为我没做。他忽略了一个事实，那就是他冲出了大楼。他就像是，我给州长一点颜色看看，好像谈话结束了一样。他大概是在和《每日新闻》的一位友好编辑混在一起。
And he says, Hey, hey, you should arrange for a news reporter at Rockefeller's next press conference to ask if Moses is keeping all of his jobs. Because that's going to force Rockefeller to say, of course I want to keep Moses, because he doesn't want me to lose those jobs. And he knows I threaten to resign all of them. So if you ask him, it's going to force him to say, of course I want him publicly. And back at Reynolds Island, Moses refusing to answer the governor's calls. He's assuming if the governor is calling me, I've already won. The winner doesn't call the loser calls. He wants me back and I'm not going to go. And Caro says there's every indication that if Moses had just stopped there,
他说，嘿，你应该安排一名新闻记者在洛克菲勒的下一次新闻发布会上问摩西是否会保留他所有的工作。因为那会迫使洛克菲勒说，我当然想留住摩西，因为他不想让我失去那些工作。他知道我威胁要辞去所有工作。所以如果你问他，那会迫使他公开说他当然想要我。而在雷诺兹岛，摩西拒绝接听州长的电话。他假设如果州长在给我打电话，我已经赢了。赢家不会打电话，输家才会打。他想让我回去，但我不会去。卡罗说，有各种迹象表明，如果摩西当时就停下来，
had just let it lie, maybe he would have won. If it wasn't public, maybe Rockefeller would have backed down from this transition idea. He had backed down from it in the past. So maybe Moses thinks, this is just another one of those times where someone asked me to do something, I say I'll resign and they stop and the governor did it before and it'll happen again.
如果他只是让事情平息，也许他就赢了。如果这不是公开的，也许洛克菲勒会放弃这个过渡的想法。他过去曾放弃过。所以也许摩西认为，这只是又一次有人要求我做某事，我说我要辞职，他们就停止了，州长以前也做过，以后还会发生。
But Moses, he pushes things too far. He wants to show Rockefeller how completely in control of the situation he is. He wants to show Rockefeller how completely in control of the situation he is. He wants to force Rockefeller to surrender completely. So he writes a letter. Don't do this. This is, don't do this. He writes a letter saying, I am preparing to resign from all of my state posts. This is what I am trying to do. And he's like, I know Rockefeller, now he's going to call me again. I'll finally take his call. He will say, no, no, don't do it. We don't do it.
但摩西，他把事情推得太远了。他想向洛克菲勒展示他完全掌控了局势。他想强迫洛克菲勒彻底投降。所以他写了一封信。别这样做。这，别这样做。他写了一封信说，我准备辞去我所有的州政府职务。这就是我正在尝试做的事情。他想，我知道洛克菲勒，现在他会再给我打电话。我终于会接他的电话。他会说，不，不，别这样做。我们不需要你。我会击败他。这是我做的。它总是有效的。它总是有效的。这是他的终极武器。它从未让他失望过。卡罗写道，然而这一次，
We need you. And it's going to, it's, I'm going to just have defeated him. It's what I do. It's what it always works. It always works all the time. This is his ultimate weapon. It has never failed him. And Carol writes, this time, however,
终极武器哑火了。在发出那种挑衅挑战30年后，他把它发给了一个会接受挑战的人。在收到罗伯特·摩西辞职信的第二天，纳尔逊·洛克菲勒接受了。洛克菲勒说，我希望你继续担任电力管理局的职务。至于其他的，我注意到你正在安排辞去长岛州立公园委员会的职务。这是一个我遗憾地接受的决定。天哪。
the ultimate weapon misfired. After 30 years of issuing that defiant challenge, he had issued it to a man who would take him up on it. On the day after he received Robert Moses' resignation, Nelson Rockefeller accepted it. I hope you will continue in the power authority post, Rockefeller said. As for the others, I note that you are making arrangements to resign from the Long Island State Park Commission. This is a decision which I accept with regret. Roman. Oh my God.
刚才发生了什么？终于有人接受了他的辞职，认真对待了他。他们面对他的最后通牒说，你知道吗？不。洛克菲勒第一次接受了他的辞职。他接受了。他说，哦不，不，不，我们需要你。
What just happened? Someone finally took his resignation, took him seriously. They just like, they faced his ultimatum and said, you know what? No, no. Walker-Feller accepted his resignation for the first time. He accepted it. He said, oh no, no, no, we need you.
我们不能那样做。他说，哦，那太糟糕了。好吧，我会很遗憾看到你离开，但你知道，别让门撞到你。这是他自耶鲁游泳队以来，几十年来第一次有人接受他的辞职。州长和市长们一直对“他会辞职”的想法感到恐惧。而现在，他只是收到一封回信说，哦，我看到你已经做了那些辞职的安排。我想你会做的。现在，两封信都没有公开。
We can't do that. He said, oh, that's too bad. Well, I'm going to be sorry to see you go, but you know, don't let the door hit you. This is the first time since he was on the Yale swim team that someone has accepted his resignation for decades. Governors and mayors have quailed in fear at the idea that he would ever resign. And now so easily, he just gets a letter back to being like, Oh, I see you've made those arrangements to resign. I guess you'll do it. Now, neither letter has been released publicly.
所以整件事本可以被掩盖，但冲突的传言已经泄露了。摩西想，哦不，我在新闻发布会上安排了那个问题，记者会问洛克菲勒是否希望我继续担任所有职务。现在洛克菲勒会说不，他辞职了，我接受了他的辞职。
So as this whole thing could have been swept on the rug, but there's rumors of the conflict that have leaked out. And Moses is like, oh no, I planted that question at the press conference where the reporter was gonna ask Rockefeller if he wanted me to continue in all my posts. And now Rockefeller is gonna say no, he resigned and I accepted his resignation.
看起来像是洛克菲勒把我挤走了。看起来像是洛克菲勒会说不，他辞职了，我接受了他的辞职，看起来像是洛克菲勒把我挤走了，看起来像是洛克菲勒解雇了我，我不能让那种事发生，哦不，我不能让那种事发生，那是噩梦般的场景，每个人都会知道我输给了他，所以他匆忙发布了一份公开声明，说纳尔逊·洛克菲勒要求我为了他的兄弟而辞职，我拒绝了，我感到非常受侮辱，所以我辞去所有州政府职务，并编造了他与洛克菲勒家族的恩怨。他说，这就是我要做的，我要辞去所有职务。
It's gonna look like Rockefeller pushed me out. It's gonna look like Rockefeller is going to say no he resigned and I accepted his resignation it's going to look like Rockefeller pushed me out it's gonna look like Rockefeller fired me I can't let that happen oh no I can't let that happen I got that's a nightmare scenario that everyone's gonna know I lost to him so he hurriedly releases a public statement saying Nelson Rockefeller asked me to resign in favor of his brother and I refused and I'm so insulted I'm resigning all of my state posts and inventing his grievance with the Rockefellers. And he's like, so that's what I'm gonna do, I'm gonna resign all of them.
他公开说了这些，洛克菲勒再次认为，洛克菲勒会说，不，不，不，不，不，我不能被看作是为了我的兄弟而把你挤走，不，不。洛克菲勒优雅地公开接受了所有的辞职。他显然对提到他兄弟的事有点生气，但我不知道，老实说，我不确定摩西
And he says this publicly, Rockefeller thinking, again, that Rockefeller is gonna be like, no, no, no, no, no, I can't be looked to have seen to be pushing you out in favor of my brother, no, no. Rockefeller graciously publicly accepts all the resignations. He's clearly a little mad about the reference to his brother, but I don't know, I'm not quite sure what Moses
认为州长会怎么做。但无论他认为会发生什么，都没有发生，你知道吗？摩西成功地将自己将死在权力之外，正如卡罗所说，纯粹是因为他坐在办公室里担心会发生什么，你知道，假设最坏的情况，然后让最坏的情况发生。
thought the governor was gonna do, to be honest. But whatever he thought was gonna happen, it didn't happen, you know? Moses has managed to checkmate himself out of power, purely as the way Carol says it, by sitting in his office worrying about what's gonna happen, you know, and assuming the worst and then making the worst happen.
这真的很特别。他只是从没想过会发生这种情况，他一生中安排了所有这些事情，他认为自己受到保护。但在这种情况下，他根本没有。我不知道。我的意思是，我认为其中一个关键部分是它涉及到了纳尔逊的兄弟，你明白我的意思吗？就像，如果换成另一个人，可能他会弯腰或改变主意。
It's really something. He just never thought that this would happen, and he had all these sort of things in place over his whole life that he thought he was sort of protected. And he is not in this situation at all. And I don't know. It's just like, I mean, I think one of the key parts of this is that it involves, you know, Nelson's brother, you know what I mean? Like, you know, like if it was another person, potentially, it would be like he might have bent or changed his tune to this.
但这个家族，没有人会反对这个家族。他当时一定想，不，那就滚蛋吧。你明白我的意思吗？他就像，我不需要你。是的。在他之前的所有人都觉得，我需要这家伙。我负担不起让他离开的代价。而这是第一个说，我真的负担得起让他离开的人。
But this family, no one goes against this family. He must have just been like, no, then just piss off. You know what I mean? He's like, I don't need you. Yeah. Everyone before him has felt, I need this guy. I can't afford to let him go. And this is the first guy who says, I literally can afford to let him go.
就像我真的不需要他。如果金钱就是权力，那么这就像是，你知道，超人对抗上帝。你知道，这根本不够。摩西在那一瞬间，主要是通过他自己的行为，失去了他所有的政府职务。他仍然是部落管理局主席。
Like I literally don't need him. If money is power, then it's like a, you know, Superman is going up against God. You know, like it's just not, it's not enough. And Moses has now in that instant, mainly through his own actions, he has lost every government post he has. He still is the tribal authority chairman.
他仍然是世博会主席。他仍然担任纽约市联邦动脉公路代表的非正式角色。非常令人兴奋。但他失去了大部分权力。罗曼，你在笔记里做了这个评论，回溯到很久以前那个人说“我没有权力吗？”的时候。当范德比尔特准将说那句话时。你就在这里说，他没有权力。它只是消失了。他没有权力，他没有权力。它只是消失了。他没有它。他根本没有它。
He's still president of the world's fair. He still has this informal role as New York city's representative to the federal government on arterial highways. Very exciting. But he's lost most of his power. And Roman, you made this comment in the notes here, hearkening back to very early on when the guy said, ain't I got the power? When Commodore Vanderbilt said that. And you say right here, he ain't got the power. It's just gone. He ain't got here, he ain't got the power. He ain't got the power. It's just gone. He ain't got it. He ain't got it at all.
卡罗说，所以之前，他的权力来自于受欢迎程度和金钱。受欢迎程度早已消失。这没关系，因为钱还在。现在他失去了大部分。他辞去的州电力管理局，尽管洛克菲勒有点想让他留任，那是为了产生数千万美元的收入。是的，来自这些大坝，这些大坝如此重要，以至于我们从不谈论，为什么我们不谈论这些大坝，为什么没有人
And Caro says, so previously, his power came from popularity and money. The popularity is long gone. It didn't matter because the money remained. Now he's lost most of that. The state power authority, which he has resigned from, even though Rockefeller kind of wanted him to stay on it, that was to generate tens of millions of dollars. Yeah from these dams these dams that are so important that we never talk about like why are we talking about these dams how come nobody
谈论这些大坝，现在别人将获得管理这些钱所带来的权力。在公开场合，摩西说我很高兴退休，你知道，我只是想退休，这太棒了。但在幕后，他的盟友正在疯狂地游说洛克菲勒让他回来。在过去，这会奏效的，但洛克菲勒拒绝了。卡罗说，这可能是洛克菲勒让摩西撤回辞职的唯一理由，不是他的公园委员会辞职，也许是其他的，但令他惊讶的是，政治内部人士并没有出现预期的抗议风暴。罗伯特·摩西被
ever nobody talks about these dams ever and now somebody else is going to get the power that comes with managing that money and in public Moses is like I'm glad to retire you know I just want to retire this is great but behind the scenes his allies are furiously lobbying Rockefeller to bring him back and in the past this would have worked yeah but Rockefeller refuses and Caro says for what might have been the one reason for Rockefeller to let Moses withdraw his resignation not his parks council resignation perhaps but his others did not to his surprise and that of political insiders exist the expected storm of protest had not materialized. Robert Moses had been
解雇了，几乎没有人真正在意。摩西就像，好吧，现在这件事公开了，公众会齐声要求他们的冠军回到权力岗位。但这并没有发生。即使是《时报》，你知道，三年前他们还说，你不能让贝比·鲁斯坐冷板凳。即使是《时报》，三年前他们还说，你不能让贝比·鲁斯坐冷板凳。现在《时报》发表了一篇社论。就像，你知道，太糟糕了。摩西很伟大，但没有任何政府职能可以如此依赖于一个人，
fired and hardly anyone had really cared. Like Moses like, well now that this is public, the public will rise up as one voice to demand that their champion be back in power. And it just doesn't happen. Even the Times, you know, three years earlier they had said, you don't bench Babe Ruth,. Even the Times, three years earlier they had said, you don't bench Babe Ruth. And now the Times runs an editorial. It's like, you know, it's too bad. Moses is great, but no government function can be made so dependent on a single individual
以至于他成为不可或缺的人。他们说，是的，我们仍然爱摩西，但你知道吗？也许是时候让他走了。这可能是我整本书中最喜欢的细节，可能吧。那不是真的，但这是我最喜欢的细节之一。卡罗说，你知道，当时有个年轻记者被指派在周末坐在《新闻日报》办公室里，整理从公共官员那里发来的声明，
that he becomes the indispensable man. They're like, yeah, we still love Moses, but you know what? Maybe it's time for him to go. And this maybe is my favorite detail in the whole book, possibly. That's not true, but it's one of my favorites. Caro says, and you know, there was this young reporter who was assigned to sit in the Newsday office over the weekend to compile the statements that were going to come in from public officials
评论摩西的下台，结果只有一个来自小官员的声明。然后在笔记里，卡罗说，那是我。我就是那个年轻记者。在笔记里，虽然不在正文中。它不在正文中。他没说。当我坐在那里时，它在笔记里。你得去看笔记，卡罗说，那是我。我就是那个年轻的笨蛋。在笔记里，虽然不在正文中。它不在正文中，他没说。当我坐在那里时，它在，你得去看笔记。笔记，任何读完这本书最后一行的人，
commenting on Moses Ouster, and only one statement from a minor official comes in. And then the notes, Caro's like, that was me. I was that young reporter. In the notes, though, it's not in the text. It's not in the text. He doesn't say it. And when I was sitting there, it's in the notes. You got to go to the notes, Caro's like, that was me. I was that young blooper. In the notes though, it's not in the text. It's not in the text, he doesn't say it. And when I was sitting there, it's in the, you gotta go to the notes. The notes, anyone who finishes this book with the last line of it,
你还没有读完整本书，因为笔记里有很多很棒的东西。但我只是喜欢它，就像，甚至在他开始写和研究这本书之前，罗伯特·卡罗的职业生涯就在他职业生涯的开始与罗伯特·摩西职业生涯的终点有了交集。这有一种如此美丽的对称性，
you haven't read the whole book because the notes have a lot of great stuff in them. But I just love that it's like, even before he has started to write and research this book, Robert Caro, his professional life has touched for this moment at the very beginning of his career with the very end of Robert Moses' career. And there's such a beautiful symmetry to that,
在他作为记者的职业生涯开始时，他经历了这一刻，他看到了这个人的垮台，而这个人的生活将成为他自己七年、八年生活的研究对象。问题是大多数政治家，他们没有发表声明。他们不会在公开评论中留下记录，因为摩西不是他们需要站在他那边的强大人物。
that at the start of his career as a reporter, he is having this moment where he is seeing the downfall of this man whose life will become the study of seven years, eight years of his own life. And the thing is most politicians, they are not making statements. They will not go on record with public comments because Moses is not the powerful person
洛克菲勒才是那个强大的人。没错。他们不知道在摩西的问题上该采取什么基调。所以他们什么也没说，这就像摩西应该做的那样。是的，完全正确。
that they need to be on the side of. Rockefeller is the powerful person. That's right. They don't know what tone to take, you know, when it comes to Moses. And so they just say nothing, which is like what Moses should have done. Yeah, exactly.
多年来，几十年来，政治圈里有一种错觉，认为摩西太受欢迎了，你无法摆脱他。选民会因为你摆脱这个人而严厉惩罚你。现在州长终于做到了，
And there was this, at Caratop's, there's this illusion for years, decades in political circles that Moses was so popular that you could not get rid of him. The voters would punish you so hard for getting rid of this man. And now the governor finally has done it and
什么也没发生。选民不在乎。他们没有，如果有的话，如果他们想到这件事，他们很高兴看到它发生。这似乎在政治中仍然是这样，某些人积累了不可或缺的神话，然后他们失去了权力。就像，哦，那家伙。是的。好吧。他们可能几年前就应该摆脱他了。所以摩西，对他来说最糟糕的部分可能不仅仅是，哦该死，我意外地辞去了我所有的权力，毫无理由，而且，哦，甚至没人关心。
nothing has happened. The voters do not care. They have no, if anything, they're happy to see it happen if they even think about it. And it feels like this is still the case in politics that certain people accrue the myth of indispensability and then they lose power. And it's like, Oh, that guy. Yeah. Okay. And they probably could have gotten rid of him years ago. And so Moses has, it's almost the worst part of it for him probably is not just, Oh shit, I accidentally resigned myself out of all of my power for no reason, but also, oh, and nobody even cares about it.
就像我习惯于成为这个城市和州围绕其转动的轴心，现在它对人们来说根本不重要了。州公园委员会会议，这是该委员会38年历史上第一次没有摩西主持的会议。他们确实以他的名字命名了三个公园，这是一件大事。接近摩西的人说他很崩溃，特别是失去了长岛公园的角色。那是他开始的地方。那是他第一次开始积累公园权力的地方。但在公开场合，摩西隐藏了这一点。下一次他亲自见到洛克菲勒时，他们拥抱彼此，赞美彼此。他认识到了。这就是现在的权力。他不是权力。几十年来第一次，摩西不得不吞下他的骄傲，因为他没有权力。
Like I was used to being the axle that this city and the state turned around and now it just doesn't even matter to people. State Council of Parks meeting, the first in the council's 38 year history ever to be held without Moses presiding over it. They do name three parks after him, which is a big thing. And people close to Moses say that he is devastated, especially to lose his Long Island parks roles. That was where he began. That's where he first started accruing his parks power. But in public, Moses hides it. And the next time he sees Rockefeller in person, they hug each other, they praise each other. He recognizes it. This is the power now. He is not the power. For the first time in decades, Moses has to swallow his pride because he does not have the power.
他一定在心里知道，天哪，我真的不应该那样做。就像，这是我的错。他们把摩西那种笼罩性的性格变成了一种傀儡。他没有被击倒，然后每个人，你知道，他们没有像墨索里尼那样把他吊起来。他们把他转化成了另一种
And he must know in the back of his mind, boy, I really shouldn't have done that. Like, this is on me. And they take all that sort of looming character of Moses just becomes a kind of figurehead. He isn't like knocked down and then everyone, you know, like they don't string them up like Mussolini or anything like that. They sort of, they transmute them into this other type
元老，你知道，以这种方式受到尊敬，但绝对不值得畏惧。不，他们拔掉了他的牙。他从一个至关重要的、强大的、危险的人物变成了一个像纽约的“建筑爷爷”。你知道，他不重要。你不需要对他有意见。他在那里。
of elder statesman to be, you know, revered in this way, but definitely not to be feared. No, they defang him. He goes from being a vital, powerful, dangerous figure to being kind of like New York's construction grandpa. You know, like he doesn't matter. You don't have to have an opinion on him. He's around.
作为未来的政坛元老，你知道，以这种方式受到尊敬，但绝对不至于让人感到恐惧。不，他们磨去了他的利爪。他从一个至关重要、强大且危险的人物，变成了一个类似于纽约的“建筑爷爷”。你知道，他变得无关紧要了。你不需要对他有任何看法。他就在那儿，仅此而已。
You can revere him without it really meaning anything, or you can ignore him. And it is probably the thing that it would be most painful for him to be not just out of power, but to be unimportant, obscure, unnecessary, just kind of like easy to not even pay attention to. And that's unfortunately eventually going to be
你可以崇拜他，但这其实毫无意义，或者你也可以无视他。对他来说，最痛苦的事情可能不仅仅是失去权力，而是变得无足轻重、默默无闻、不再被需要，甚至让人懒得去关注。不幸的是，这最终将成为他真正的终极命运。
his real ultimate fate. But look, he's still got that World's Fair going on. There's still that. There's still a glimmer out there, the World's Fair. So maybe, maybe, if he manages this World's Fair just right, if he makes it a roaring success, maybe he'll be back in power. Maybe that'll happen.
但你看，他还在搞那个世界博览会。还有那个。那里还有一丝微光，世界博览会。所以也许，如果他能把这个世界博览会经营得恰到好处，如果他能让它大获成功，也许他就能重掌大权。也许这会发生。
Maybe he can do it. This is it, this is his chance. We'll cover that on the next episode. We will also finish the book. We will cover chapters 47 through 50. I cannot believe that we're through, almost through the end of this. This is amazing.
也许他能做到。就是这样，这是他的机会。我们将在下一集讨论这个问题。我们也将读完这本书。我们将涵盖第47到50章。我简直不敢相信我们快要读完了。这太不可思议了。
I can't, it's astounding to me. I look at my copy of the book that has my notes in it and I look where the bookmark is and I'm like, there's not, wait a minute, there's so much book before the bookmark and not a lot afterwards. It's, what an amazing journey and a wild ride this has been, but we'll say, we'll talk about that more. I can't believe it. Finishing the book, we are not going to go through the notes in the podcast. So you'll have to do that yourself. We will end at the last line of the text.
我无法相信，这让我感到震惊。我看着我那本写满笔记的书，看着书签的位置，心想，等等，书签前面还有那么多内容，后面却没多少了。这是一段多么奇妙的旅程，多么疯狂的经历，但我们以后会再谈这个。我简直不敢相信。读完这本书，我们不会在播客里过一遍笔记。所以你们得自己做。我们将以书中的最后一行作为结束。
So that sounds good. Coming up, our conversation with Brennan Lee Mulligan, host of the Dungeons and Dragons show, Dimension 20. And now our conversation with professional Dungeons & Dragons dungeon master, Brennan Lee Mulligan. His D&D show, Dimension 20 on Dropout TV, has a very large and devoted following, and pretty much since we started the show, listeners on our Discord server have been asking us to have Brennan on as a guest, all because of one reason. Our big bad, our villain of season one of The Unsleeping City was none other
听起来不错。接下来，我们将与《龙与地下城》节目《Dimension 20》的主持人布伦南·李·穆里根（Brennan Lee Mulligan）进行对话。现在，让我们欢迎职业《龙与地下城》地下城主布伦南·李·穆里根。他在Dropout TV上的D&D节目《Dimension 20》拥有大量忠实的粉丝，而且几乎从我们节目开播以来，Discord服务器上的听众就一直要求我们邀请布伦南作为嘉宾，原因只有一个。我们第一季《不眠之城》（The Unsleeping City）的大反派，不是别人，正是
than undead Robert Moses. Oh no, here he comes! Just when we thought we were through with him. Finally, with this episode, finally. Robert Caro's gonna have to pop back up Here he comes. Just when we thought we were through with him. Finally, with this episode, finally. Robert Caro's gonna have to pop back up and get that pen out and start writing, baby. There's new chapters, here we go.
亡灵罗伯特·摩西。噢不，他来了！就在我们以为已经摆脱他的时候。终于，在这一集里，终于。罗伯特·卡罗（Robert Caro）得跳出来，他来了。就在我们以为已经摆脱他的时候。终于，在这一集里，终于。罗伯特·卡罗得跳出来，拿出那支笔，开始写作了，宝贝。有新的章节了，我们开始吧。
That's right, Brennan created the Unsleeping City and made the main villain a fictionalized, magical Robert Moses. You see Robert raises his hand, a seam opens in his wrist, and a rope of blood shoots out of his arm around the child, and he rips the child out of the mirror as it skids onto the floor in front of him.
没错，布伦南创作了《不眠之城》，并将主要反派设定为一个虚构的、具有魔法能力的罗伯特·摩西。你看到罗伯特举起手，手腕上裂开一道缝，一根血绳从他手臂射出，缠住孩子，他把孩子从镜子里拽了出来，镜子滑到了他面前的地板上。
When Brennan develops his stories for Dimension 20, he pushes the bounds of traditional D&D campaigns. His first season was called Fantasy High, which Brennan describes as a John Hughes movie with swords and magic. But there's something very different about looking to the power broker for source material. So we talked with Brendan about why he decided to pick Moses as the inspiration for his big bad D and D antagonist and how one goes about creating a fantasy version of a very real, very bureaucratic man. But first, a quick primer on Dungeons & Dragons
当布伦南为《Dimension 20》构思故事时，他突破了传统D&D战役的界限。他的第一季名为《奇幻高中》（Fantasy High），布伦南将其描述为一部带有剑与魔法的约翰·休斯电影。但以这位“权力掮客”作为素材来源，感觉非常不同。所以我们和布伦南聊了聊，为什么他决定选择摩西作为他D&D大反派的灵感来源，以及一个人是如何去创造一个非常真实、非常官僚的人的奇幻版本的。但首先，给那些可能不太熟悉游戏的人做一个关于《龙与地下城》的快速入门。
for those of you who may not be super familiar with the game. Dungeons & Dragons is a storytelling game where one person is the dungeon master who writes an adventure, and their friends are the players and they each have one character. So basically you have a group of heroes, every hero is being played by one person at the table,
《龙与地下城》是一款讲故事的游戏，其中一个人担任地下城主（DM），负责编写冒险故事，而他们的朋友则是玩家，每个人都有一个角色。所以基本上你有一群英雄，每个英雄都由桌边的一个人扮演，
and their job is just to go on the adventure, role-playing as their hero. And the Dungeon Master's job is to be everything and everyone else, all the monsters, all the allies, all the environs. And basically, you're just going on an adventure, it's a group storytelling, you're collaboratively writing this adventure improvisationally in the moment.
他们的工作就是去冒险，扮演他们的英雄。而地下城主的工作是扮演其他所有人和所有事物，所有的怪物、所有的盟友、所有的环境。基本上，你们就是在进行一场冒险，这是一种集体讲故事，你们在即兴创作中共同编写这个冒险故事。
And the game aspect comes in, in moments of stress, risk and uncertainty. So you go into combat, do you slay the dragon or does the dragon devour you? We're going to roll dice to find out. Do you crack the code in the massive spellbook or do you raise your fist to the sky and shake and say, no, I cannot decipher the codex.
游戏的博弈感体现在压力、风险和不确定性的时刻。所以当你进入战斗时，你是杀死了龙，还是被龙吞噬了？我们要掷骰子来决定。你是破解了巨大法术书中的密码，还是向天空挥舞拳头，摇着头说，不，我无法破译这本法典。
That's a dice roll, right? So all these moments of dramatic peak are determined by rolls of the dice, which creates this really wonderful feeling, whether you watch D&D shows or you play D&D, where you are watching a story being told by people who love telling that story, and the intoxicating part is not only do you not know
那是一个掷骰子的时刻，对吧？所以所有这些戏剧性的巅峰时刻都是由掷骰子决定的，这创造了一种非常美妙的感觉，无论你是观看D&D节目还是玩D&D，你都在观看一个由热爱讲故事的人讲述的故事，而最令人着迷的部分不仅在于你不知道
where this is gonna go, the people telling the story are discovering alongside you where the story's gonna go. So we have a Discord server where we talk about the book and stuff, and you came up very, very early in discussions of like, who should we have as potential guests? Because a lot of people listen to us, enjoy your show.
故事会走向何方，讲故事的人也在和你一起探索故事的走向。所以我们有一个Discord服务器，我们在那里讨论书之类的内容，你在讨论我们应该邀请谁作为潜在嘉宾时，很早就被提到了。因为很多人听我们的节目，也喜欢你的节目。
And the idea of Robert Moses, the Robert Moses in this book, morphing into a fantasy villain. And he is morphed quite a bit. Like we should explain a little bit of that. Is kind of genius and it's just sort of fun to sort of bring the real world into this fantasy world and play with that.
而罗伯特·摩西，书中的那个罗伯特·摩西，演变成一个奇幻反派的想法。而且他确实变了很多。就像我们应该解释一下其中的一些内容。这简直是天才之举，把现实世界带入这个奇幻世界并以此为乐，这很有趣。
So let's first talk about who Robert Moses in Unsleeping City is. Let's describe him a little bit because he's a little bit changed. He's, yeah, I would say that he is a very fantasy villain version of the historical figure. He is a very fantasy villain version of the historical figure. And one very much sort of taken up with presumably
所以我们先谈谈《不眠之城》里的罗伯特·摩西是谁。让我们描述一下他，因为他有一点变化。他，是的，我会说他是一个非常奇幻反派版本的历史人物。他是一个非常奇幻反派版本的历史人物。而且很大程度上是基于
the decades of whatever his public historical life was. We're now in the year 2019, after decades of magical shenanigans going on in the fantasy universe. I should also mention that in terms of license with real figures, we did have Stephen Sondheim as an ally of the player characters, who wielded two broad swords, one in each hand.
他几十年的公共历史生活。我们现在是在2019年，在奇幻宇宙中经历了数十年的魔法闹剧之后。我还应该提到，就对真实人物的使用许可而言，我们确实让斯蒂芬·桑德海姆（Stephen Sondheim）作为玩家角色的盟友，他挥舞着两把阔剑，一手一把。
So there is a little bit of creative license with some of our beloved New York limiters. He was usually a one-weapon fighter, Stephen Sondheim. Yeah, in real life, he was a sort of saber or rapier. He was a one-hand fencer, but we thought it would be fun. He took a little license, so we gave him two claymores. But he, Robert Moses, as he's depicted in The Unsleeping City, is the architect of a thing called the Highway Hex.
所以我们对一些我们钟爱的纽约名人进行了一些艺术加工。在现实生活中，他通常是一个单武器战士，斯蒂芬·桑德海姆。是的，在现实生活中，他用的是军刀或刺剑。他是一个单手剑客，但我们觉得这样会很有趣。他进行了一些艺术加工，所以我们给了他两把苏格兰阔剑。但他，罗伯特·摩西，正如他在《不眠之城》中所描绘的那样，是“高速公路咒语”（Highway Hex）的建筑师。
And the Highway Hex is, if you guys are familiar at all with the concept of ley lines, which are basically magical directional veins that can intersect and create nodes of power, and it's sort of based on some real world belief systems. And the idea behind Robert Moses and the Unsleeping City is that the Highway highway hex was him creating a complex arcane rune, a glyph,
“高速公路咒语”是，如果你们熟悉“地脉”（ley lines）的概念，它们基本上是魔法方向的脉络，可以相交并创造出力量节点，这在某种程度上基于一些现实世界的信仰体系。罗伯特·摩西和《不眠之城》背后的想法是，高速公路咒语是他创造的一个复杂的奥术符文，一个字形，
of the intersecting highways and expressways within New York City to repel divination from the forces of good. So he's a, basically remains a master builder, remains someone whose ideology is very rooted in the concrete and building and the creation of an infrastructure with this added level of arcane magical threat on top of it, that all of the traffic in New York
由纽约市纵横交错的高速公路和快速路组成，用来抵御来自正义力量的占卜。所以他基本上仍然是一个建筑大师，仍然是一个意识形态深深扎根于混凝土、建筑和基础设施建设的人，并在其之上增加了这种奥术魔法威胁，纽约所有的交通
is actually casting this elaborate fiendish spell. Right. So this version of Robert Moses, when Robert Caro's interviewing him, would point out to Fire Island and say, don't you see there should be a glyph there? spell. Right. So this version of Robert Moses, when Robert Carrow's interviewing him, would point out to Fire Island and say, don't you see there should be a glyph there? Shouldn't there be a glyph out there? Like that. But it's still, like you're saying it's still rooted in the, in the things we know about Robert Moses, about his, his predilection
实际上都在施展这个精心设计的邪恶咒语。没错。所以这个版本的罗伯特·摩西，当罗伯特·卡罗采访他时，会指着火岛说，难道你不觉得那里应该有一个字形吗？所以这个版本的罗伯特·摩西，当罗伯特·卡罗采访他时，会指着火岛说，难道你不觉得那里应该有一个字形吗？难道那里不应该有一个字形吗？就像那样。但这仍然，就像你说的，它仍然扎根于我们所知的关于罗伯特·摩西的事情，关于他
for slashing roads across everything. But you're giving him, if anything, kind of a more rational reason. I know, exactly. Yeah. Right. We're explaining in retrospect why he was so obsessed with building all these expressways. And I get why his road has to take a sudden curve in through East Tremont if it's because, oh, well, we're drawing some sort of sigil or some sort of a cult sign.
在一切事物上强行开路的偏好。但你给了他，如果说有什么不同的话，一个更合理的理由。我知道，没错。是的。没错，我们在回顾为什么他如此痴迷于建造所有这些快速路。我明白为什么他的路必须在东特雷蒙特（East Tremont）突然转弯，如果是因为，哦，好吧，我们正在画某种符印或某种邪教符号。
And it has to be exactly the right way. It makes more sense than any of the reasons that we got otherwise. I'm very curious about your, so you've read The Power Broker, I believe. This is not, you're not just existing off of the urban legends of Robert Moses. What is it?
而且它必须以完全正确的方式进行。这比我们得到的任何其他理由都更有意义。我对你的，所以你读过《权力掮客》，我相信。这不仅仅是靠罗伯特·摩西的都市传说生存。这是什么？
It strikes me as such an interesting book to use as a foundation text for a fantasy story because it is so grounded in, in many ways, the real kind of minutia and data of urban construction, traffic flow, things like that. What is it about it that planted this into your mind that like, yeah, I could use this for a D&D campaign? It's a great question.
这让我觉得这是一本作为奇幻故事基础文本的有趣书籍，因为它在很多方面都非常扎根于城市建设、交通流量等方面的真实细节和数据。是什么让你觉得，是的，我可以把它用于D&D战役？这是一个很好的问题。
And there's a lot, I mean, especially growing up, so I have an odd biography, right? I went to school a little bit early. I started attending college at SUNY Ulster when I was 14 for philosophy and humanities and was used to, I remember as a teenager reading Howard Zinn, which is a very similar book in terms of like, oh my God, this is 80 pages on like,
有很多，我的意思是，特别是在成长过程中，所以我有一个奇怪的传记，对吧？我上学有点早。我14岁时就开始在纽约州立大学阿尔斯特分校（SUNY Ulster）学习哲学和人文科学，并且习惯了，我记得十几岁时读过霍华德·津恩（Howard Zinn）的书，那是一本非常相似的书，就像，天哪，这是80页关于，
and these many bushels of barley were being exported and they were tabulating kind of the economies of this portion of time. And then it will move to a page where you'll read a chapter that makes you burst into tears, right? Where the human cost of all of this data is rendered very plainly. And to be honest with you, a lot of the Unsleeping City that first season was rooted in and very much dedicated
这些大麦被出口了，他们正在计算那个时期这部分的经济。然后它会翻到一页，读到让你泪流满面的章节，对吧？所有这些数据背后的人类代价被非常清晰地呈现出来。老实说，《不眠之城》第一季的很多内容都扎根于并非常致力于
to in sort of honoring my father. So I'm a New Yorker. My father's lived in New York my entire life. And we would walk around during my childhood and he had this incredible, his name's Joe Mulligan, he had this encyclopedic knowledge of New York history and we'd anywhere we'd go to museums or going up to the cloisters or going downtown. He took me to five points when I was a little kid before Gangs of New York came out and you know he we laugh about it now because he would point somewhere and be like and this is where Bill Poole, you know, or this is where William, you know, like came out and this is what happened. And I would be pointing at a Dunkin Donuts, right? Like this is the, this is the site of ultimate significance. And he prior even to reading anything about Moses, you're right. Like urban legend is
以某种方式纪念我的父亲。所以我是一个纽约人。我父亲在我的一生中都住在纽约。我们童年时会四处走动，他有这种不可思议的，他的名字叫乔·穆里根（Joe Mulligan），他对纽约历史有百科全书般的知识，无论我们去博物馆，还是去修道院博物馆（Cloisters），还是去市中心。我还是个小孩子的时候，在《纽约黑帮》出来之前，他就带我去过五点区（Five Points），你知道，我们现在谈起这个还会笑，因为他会指着某个地方说，这就是比尔·普尔（Bill Poole）出现的地方，或者这就是威廉出现的地方，这就是发生的事情。而我当时指着一家唐恩都乐（Dunkin Donuts），对吧？这就是具有重大意义的地点。在他读到任何关于摩西的东西之前，你是对的。就像都市传说
a good way to put it. My father father as a New Yorker spoke about Robert Moses with this idea of like, this is someone who forever altered the city and explaining the heights of bridges and the discrimination of keeping various groups out from these, these people will have luxury and plenty and these people will not.
是一个很好的说法。我父亲作为一名纽约人，谈论罗伯特·摩西时带着一种想法，即这是一个永远改变了这座城市的人，并解释了桥梁的高度以及将各种群体排除在外的歧视，这些人将拥有奢侈和富足，而这些人则不会。
And in terms of like what drew me to this document and this extremely kind of like, if we're being honest, the, the crimes, the social ills of this guy are so fascinating in that the greatest harm is done through these things that require a kind of pointed attention to understand what's happening, right? Like these, you know, like it's not salacious. It's not this thing where it's like the big harms are done by manipulating authorities and manipulating money and manipulating power. And I think it was looking at a setting set in a magical New York, uh, and specifically dealing with the idea of how do you fight somebody who's not even
就什么吸引我使用这份文件以及这种极其，如果我们诚实的话，这个家伙的罪行、社会弊病是如此迷人，因为最大的伤害是通过这些需要一种专注的注意力才能理解正在发生什么的事情造成的，对吧？就像这些，你知道，它不是耸人听闻的。它不是那种大伤害是通过操纵权威、操纵金钱和操纵权力造成的。我认为这是在观察一个设定在魔法纽约的背景，特别是处理如何对抗一个甚至没有
interacting with you, they are in control of the environment and your con, your conception of freedom or your conception of what individual action can be is totally put up against this guy. Like you're saying from, from source material that is very, very like rooted in infrastructure administration bureaucracy. So you know, you want to have this big fantasy showdown and it felt like the right way to do that was with a guy with this massive history of extremely dense action that was taken at this level that most individuals don't know how to oppose. It's something that ties into the episode we were talking about today. We talked about how
与你互动的人，他们控制着环境，你对自由的构想或你对个人行动可以是什么的构想完全被这个人所对抗。就像你说的，来自非常非常扎根于基础设施管理官僚机构的原始素材。所以你知道，你想要进行这场盛大的奇幻对决，而感觉正确的方法就是用一个有着如此庞大且极其密集行动历史的家伙，这些行动是在大多数个人不知道如何反对的层面上采取的。这与我们今天讨论的这一集有关。我们谈到了
the reporters who were trying to make it clear what Moses was doing were having trouble communicating it to the public because it was so complicated and it was not salacious. And what they finally got traction with was, well, they hired an ex mob guy as a night watchman. So the mob's involved. And it seems like it would be a big challenge in creating that kind of traditional fantasy adventure climax when you are dealing with somebody who himself is not a conniving villain so much as the... I guess he is pretty conniving, but who's not so much a cackling evil villain so much as... I guess he kind of does that too. You know what, nevermind.
那些试图弄清楚摩西在做什么的记者在向公众传达这一点时遇到了困难，因为它太复杂了，而且并不耸人听闻。他们最终获得进展的是，他们雇佣了一个前黑帮成员作为夜班保安。所以黑帮参与进来了。在创造那种传统的奇幻冒险高潮时，当你面对一个本身不是一个阴险的反派，而是一个……我想他确实很阴险，但与其说是一个狂笑的邪恶反派，不如说……我想他也有点那样。你知道吗，没关系。
Nevermind, makes more sense than I thought. I'll say, there's a lot of meat on the bone. You know, he really did give us a lot to work with for sure. I mean, I was actually thinking of, rather than the incongruities of the text and then your storytelling built on top of it, is some of the congruities, which is like the idea of Robert Moses
没关系，比我想象的更有意义。我会说，骨头上有很多肉。你知道，他确实给了我们很多可以利用的东西。我的意思是，我实际上在想，与其说是文本的不协调和你建立在它之上的叙事，不如说是其中的一些一致性，比如罗伯特·摩西的想法
being able to write these laws over the course of the first couple of decades of his life that give him power for the remaining decades almost seems like a wizard. It almost seems like a magic spell that he has done to create and accumulate and build and build and build the same way that you you know you Level up and build in D&D like it has that quality of a wizard, you know in a way, well, there's a you could you could look at the power broker as kind of a a Real world version of all the things that happen with Soran before the Lord of the Rings that all the things that happened in the past where
能够在他生命的前几十年里写下这些法律，赋予他未来几十年的权力，这几乎看起来像个巫师。这几乎看起来像他为了创造、积累和建设、建设、再建设而施下的魔法，就像你在D&D中升级和建设一样，它具有那种巫师的特质，你知道，在某种程度上，好吧，你可以把《权力掮客》看作是《指环王》中索伦发生的所有事情的现实世界版本，所有在过去发生的事情，
he amasses this power because of secret knowledge and because of the Rings, that all the things that happened in the past, where he amasses this power because of secret knowledge and because of the artifacts of that power, and then has this period of dominance, and then has his downfall more because of his own overreaching than because of anything else. I mean, you have to assume that Sauron would not talk himself into resigning because he's worried Nelson Rockefeller is going to make him look foolish at a press conference. But you know, it could have happened that way too. It could have happened that way. As the wizard Gandalf, I call a press conference.
他因为秘密知识和戒指而积累了这种力量，所有在过去发生的事情，他因为秘密知识和那种力量的文物而积累了这种力量，然后有了这段统治时期，然后他的垮台更多是因为他自己的过度扩张，而不是因为其他任何事情。我的意思是，你必须假设索伦不会因为担心纳尔逊·洛克菲勒（Nelson Rockefeller）会在新闻发布会上让他看起来很愚蠢而说服自己辞职。但你知道，它也可能以那种方式发生。它可能以那种方式发生。作为巫师甘道夫，我召开新闻发布会。
The Dark Lord. I totally agree. And I think that there's a part of depicting Moses in this, in the Unsleeping City, which was showing, especially because of who our heroes were. So like the heroes of our party are people, Lou Wilson's character, Kingston Brown, is a nurse in Harlem who is a fixture of his community
黑暗魔君。我完全同意。而且我认为，在《不眠之城》中描绘摩西的一部分，是为了展示，特别是考虑到我们的英雄是谁。所以我们队伍的英雄是人们，卢·威尔逊（Lou Wilson）的角色，金斯顿·布朗（Kingston Brown），是哈莱姆区的一名护士，他是他社区的支柱，
and knows everybody in the city and has tapped into those communities and working people. We have Ali Beards, his character is Pete Conlin, who's like a dream sorcerer, who's like a part-time drug dealer in the art scene in Bushwick. So you have these sort of New Yorker staples that are all from different walks of life.
认识城里的每一个人，并利用了那些社区和劳动人民。我们有阿里·比尔兹利（Ali Beardsley）的角色，皮特·康林（Pete Conlin），他是一个梦境巫师，是布什威克（Bushwick）艺术圈的兼职毒贩。所以你有这些来自不同生活背景的纽约人。
And the idea of you're making this point with this group of characters that become our heroes in this story, they're all magical New Yorkers of the power of not only community, but the power of diverse community, the power of, of, um, you know, what's the word I'm looking for? I'm looking for multi multiculturalism or like that, that idea of a big pluralistic society.
而你通过这群成为我们故事英雄的角色来表达这一点，他们都是魔法纽约人，不仅是社区的力量，而且是多元社区的力量，是，嗯，我正在寻找的词是什么？我正在寻找多元文化主义，或者那种大多元化社会的想法。
Right. And the idea of there being, and there definitely are forces at work against that. And there are definitely depictions in the season and elsewhere of that kind of no nothing nativist where it's meeting a cultural force with an opposing cultural force and saying like, okay, you want a pluralistic multicultural society. We don't, we want, you know, homogenous
没错。而且有反对这种力量的力量，这绝对是存在的。在这一季和其他地方也有对那种“一无所知”的本土主义者的描绘，即用一种文化力量去对抗另一种文化力量，并说，好吧，你想要一个多元化的多元文化社会。我们不想要，我们想要，你知道，同质化的
and this one type of sort of nativist ideal. But that's one way to oppose that. The other way to oppose that is to sidestep culture in totality and go, hey, you can believe what you want. I'll shape the city without any worry about what, in these chapters that you guys are talking about, the funny thing is how long protests had been trivial to him
和这种单一类型的本土主义理想。但那是反对它的一种方式。另一种反对它的方式是完全避开文化，说，嘿，你想信什么就信什么。我会在不担心任何事情的情况下塑造这座城市，在你们讨论的这些章节中，有趣的是抗议对他来说是多么微不足道，
where it's like, if you know how to get around this, if you know how to actually move power around, if people are paying your tolls, if people are giving you this power and energy outside of their belief system, just cause they're driving on your road, how much of their buy-in do you really need on that cultural level? Right? And that's so sinister to me, that idea of
就像，如果你知道如何绕过这个，如果你知道如何真正地转移权力，如果人们在支付你的过路费，如果人们在他们的信仰体系之外给你这种权力和能量，仅仅因为他们在你的路上开车，你在文化层面上真正需要他们多少买账？对吧？这对我来说太阴险了，那种
manipulating, like you're saying, it's a wizardly thing. It's manipulating a system of power where you're like, I don't need to interface with you. I don't need to be in conversation with you. I have mastered a secret language, whether that's law or finance, or in this case, the bonds being issued to the authority.
操纵，就像你说的，这是一种巫师般的事情。它操纵着一个权力系统，你就像，我不需要与你互动。我不需要与你对话。我已经掌握了一种秘密语言，无论是法律还是金融，或者在这种情况下，是发给管理局的债券。
Like you memorize this, again, like lingua arcana, and all of a sudden, it doesn't matter. You have sidestepped that entire frame of reference up to a point, of course, but that's what's so interesting about that metaphor to me of the city authority as wizard, as someone whose power does not reflect interaction with large groups of people, but rather with systems that people are supporting unbeknownst to them.
就像你背诵这个，再次，就像“奥术语言”（lingua arcana），突然之间，这不重要了。你已经绕过了整个参考框架，当然是在一定程度上，但这对我来说是关于城市管理局作为巫师的隐喻中如此有趣的地方，作为一个其权力不反映与大群人互动，而是与人们在不知不觉中支持的系统互动的人。
Yeah, yeah. It's interesting, so the story is that to gain his power, he sort of sells his soul to different factions, to kind of, to hell and to the fairy. And then he builds the highway hacks as a way to kind of insulate him. Because then at that point, they all come in after him, and he's trying to keep them out.
是的，是的。很有趣，所以故事是，为了获得权力，他把自己的灵魂卖给了不同的派系，卖给了地狱和精灵。然后他建造了高速公路咒语作为一种隔离自己的方式。因为在那一点上，他们都来找他，而他试图把他们挡在外面。
That action of being surrounded by highways just disrupts their ability to go get him. So he's basically remaking the city in this selfish way just to protect, he'll put the misery on everyone else to circle this city and circle this city forever just so he can't be gotten at by demons who are, I guess, worse than him in some way.
那种被高速公路包围的行为只是破坏了他们去抓他的能力。所以他基本上是以这种自私的方式重塑这座城市，只是为了保护，他会把痛苦强加给其他人，永远环绕这座城市，只是为了让他不被那些在某种程度上比他更糟糕的恶魔抓到。
Which is, again, it's a nice way to embody this, like put a story on this very sinister thing to remake something without any sort of input from anyone else, just destroy a place just to make yourself safe is diabolical. And the fact that everyone knows in the setting, they're like, oh yeah, like big celestial or fae or infernal forces can't come to the city. Like everyone knows the ramifications, but it's a discovery in the midst of the season that that is because of this highway hex and it's to protect one individual.
这再次是一个很好的方式来体现这一点，给这个非常阴险的事情加上一个故事，在没有任何人输入的情况下重塑某物，仅仅为了让自己安全而摧毁一个地方是恶魔般的。而且在这个设定中每个人都知道，他们就像，哦，是的，像巨大的天界、精灵或地狱力量不能来到这座城市。每个人都知道后果，但这是在这一季中发现的，这是因为这个高速公路咒语，而且是为了保护一个人。
And you go like, so you're saying the entire shape of my cosmology, like how I understand the magical world to work is not some massive, it's not like that's been here, like maybe that's why they built the city here. No, it's one guy's actions that reshaped everything. And I think the moment, obviously again, we have a very fantastical villain in our Robert Moses, who, you know, he's way over the top.
你会觉得，所以你是说我整个宇宙观的形状，我如何理解魔法世界运作的方式，不是什么巨大的，不是像那样一直在这里，也许这就是他们在这里建造城市的原因。不，是一个人的行为重塑了一切。而且我认为那一刻，显然再次，我们的罗伯特·摩西有一个非常奇幻的反派，你知道，他太夸张了。
But as far as villain goes, does attempt a lot of like persuasion and flattery. Really tries to get Ali Beardsley's character, tries to make Pete Conlin into a Moses man. You got fucked kid, I'm sorry. What do you mean? Well, did you sign up for this Vox Fantasma job? Did you weigh the health benefits?
但作为反派，确实尝试了很多说服和奉承。真的试图让阿里·比尔兹利的角色，试图让皮特·康林成为摩西的人。你被搞砸了，孩子，我很抱歉。你是什么意思？好吧，你报名参加这个“幻影之声”（Vox Fantasma）的工作了吗？你权衡过健康福利吗？
Did you get a choice in the matter? No. No. Does it suck to be the Vox Fantasma? What do you think? You're homeless, you got a bunch of problems matter? No. No. Does it suck to be the Fox Pentasma? What do you think? You're homeless? You got a bunch of problems?
你有选择的余地吗？没有。没有。成为“幻影之声”很糟糕吗？你觉得呢？你无家可归，你有一堆问题。没有。没有。成为“幻影之声”很糟糕吗？你觉得呢？你无家可归？你有一堆问题？
That's just New York. I think there's one confrontation towards the end of the season where I was like, if there's anything that feels like a statement towards the historical Moses that feels really pointed, there's a confrontation between him and Kingston Brown at the Temple of Dender at the Met. I hate to say Mr. Moses, but they're all free-thinking adults
这就是纽约。我认为在这一季快结束时有一场对抗，当时我想，如果有什么感觉像是对历史上的摩西的陈述，感觉非常尖锐的话，那就是他和金斯顿·布朗在大都会艺术博物馆的丹德神庙（Temple of Dender）之间的对抗。我很抱歉，摩西先生，但他们都是自由思考的成年人，
who can make their own choices. Ha! As is every person in this city. See, he says, do you think people make choices? I do. No. People think people make choices? I do. No, people think they make choices. They think they're gonna steer right or steer left, but they didn't build the roads.
可以做出自己的选择。哈！正如这座城市里的每个人一样。看，他说，你认为人们会做出选择吗？我会。不。人们认为人们会做出选择吗？我会。不，人们认为他们会做出选择。他们认为他们会向右转或向左转，但他们没有建造道路。
The big choices already got made for them a long time ago. And that to me is like the heart of his sinister philosophy in the Unsleeping City. And the thing that as someone who, you know, I, I come to this as a philosophy major, as someone who studied philosophy, you know, the impact that he had on this country, forget just New York, but the country broadly is so profound and
大的选择很久以前就为他们做好了。对我来说，这就是他在《不眠之城》中阴险哲学的核心。而且作为一个，你知道，我，我作为一个哲学专业学生来到这里，作为一个研究哲学的人，你知道，他对这个国家，别说只是纽约，而是整个国家的影响是如此深远，而且
America, I think has a cultural love for the idea of individual freedom and the idea that like freedom is a substance that lives in the individual and your ability to be a heroic cowboy figure who does whatever the hell you like, no one's going to tell me what to do. Very rooted in the American thing. The rug is totally pulled out from under
美国，我认为在文化上热爱个人自由的想法，以及自由是一种存在于个人身上的物质，以及你成为一个英雄牛仔形象的能力，做任何你喜欢的事情，没有人会告诉我该做什么。非常扎根于美国的东西。地毯完全被从下面抽走了
that philosophy. If you have to reckon with the fact that life is multiple choice, that you are not born on a blank page, you were born into the context that has often been shaped by very powerful people. I want to point out for anyone who's listening, who is not a New Yorker,
那个哲学。如果你必须面对这样一个事实，即生活是多项选择题，你不是出生在一张白纸上，你是出生在通常由非常有权势的人塑造的环境中。我想为任何正在听的不是纽约人的人指出，
when you mentioned the Temple of Dender, I want people to know that that's a real Egyptian temple that's in the Metropolitan Museum, not a fantasy, like, magic temple they're going to. And it makes me think about how there are viewers of the show who did not know that Robert Moses was a real person when they started watching it. And did that, is that a surprise to you? That there, you see, like, on Reddit, people are like, just found out Robert Moses is real. I thought he was just a character in the story. Does that make you feel like you have more
当你提到丹德神庙时，我希望人们知道那是一个在大都会博物馆里的真正的埃及神庙，而不是他们去的什么奇幻的、魔法神庙。这让我想到，有些节目的观众在开始观看时并不知道罗伯特·摩西是一个真实的人。这让你感到惊讶吗？你在Reddit上看到人们说，刚发现罗伯特·摩西是真实的。我以为他只是故事里的一个角色。这让你觉得你有更多
of a responsibility to present it to, or you should have presented more authentically than as a magical monster man, you know? You know, like me and the guy who puts the facts on the Snapple caps, we get together, we get together and kind of commiserate. The other responsibility of it, that comes to that power, yeah.
的责任去呈现它，或者你应该呈现得更真实，而不是作为一个魔法怪物人，你知道吗？你知道，就像我和那个在Snapple瓶盖上放事实的人一样，我们聚在一起，我们聚在一起，有点同病相怜。随之而来的另一种责任，是的。
It comes with that power. Yes, I think that there's a very pointed feeling of anytime you're doing anything connected to like historicity or historical, I think a lot of the players in that season who had not lived in New York also felt like, oh, how do I honor this very real place? And we had, you know, Stephen Sondheim is mentioned there.
它伴随着那种力量。是的，我认为任何时候你做任何与历史性或历史相关的事情时，都会有一种非常尖锐的感觉，我认为那一季中许多没有住在纽约的玩家也觉得，哦，我该如何尊重这个非常真实的地方？我们有，你知道，斯蒂芬·桑德海姆在那里被提到。
We mentioned in the second season, there's like a fight at Ellis Island where people are like jumping into photographs from Ellis Island of like different waves of immigration in the city. You're trying to like honor these things, not only in a fantasy show, but in an improvised fantasy show where, you know, it's show, but in an improvised fantasy show where,
我们在第二季提到，有一个像在埃利斯岛（Ellis Island）的战斗，人们就像跳进埃利斯岛的照片中，关于城市中不同移民浪潮。你试图尊重这些事情，不仅是在一个奇幻节目中，而且是在一个即兴奇幻节目中，你知道，它是一个节目，但在一个即兴奇幻节目中，你知道，
you know, it's like, well, our first priority is to make sure that our story reflects our values and is compelling and interesting and funny. And I think like people finding out that Robert Moses is real through this. I can only hope that it shuttles them on to the power broker and to reading the history. Please don't take the headline from an improvised D&D show. Please, please, please feel free to dig deeper. Uh, there's a lot more information, and there's a lot, and obviously, a lot of our information
它就像，好吧，我们的首要任务是确保我们的故事反映我们的价值观，并且引人入胜、有趣。而且我认为人们通过这个发现罗伯特·摩西是真实的。我只能希望它能引导他们去读《权力掮客》和阅读历史。请不要从一个即兴的D&D节目中获取头条新闻。请，请，请随意深入挖掘。嗯，有更多的信息，而且有很多，显然，我们的很多信息
was very much taking the character as a point of inspiration, and then doing this big arch villain version of him. Um, you know, in the second season, they spring a creature out of this dragon's cave underneath Central Park, and literally the Tammany tiger jumps out, who is a giant,
非常多地将这个角色作为灵感的来源，然后做了一个大反派版本。嗯，你知道，在第二季中，他们从中央公园下面的龙穴里放出了一个生物，坦慕尼虎（Tammany tiger）字面上跳了出来，它是一个巨大的，
who is a giant blind tiger with like cuffs and a top hat with a shamrock on it. And you go like, it's like, you know, but I would hope that people would not see that and then go, oh, Tammany Hall, that's where that tiger is, right? Like, yeah. Colson Whitehead wrote about this,
它是一个巨大的盲虎，戴着袖口和一顶上面有三叶草的高礼帽。你会觉得，就像，你知道，但我希望人们不会看到那个然后说，哦，坦慕尼协会（Tammany Hall），那只老虎就在那里，对吧？就像，是的。科尔森·怀特黑德（Colson Whitehead）写过这个，
that when he was growing up, the Underground Railroad was an actual railroad, like in his mind, like he could not escape that image. It's one of those things, it's kind of funny how you get information like this. And I think it's awesome that people learn about Robert Moses through your show. You know, like, because, I mean,
当他成长时，地下铁路（Underground Railroad）在他脑海中是一条真正的铁路，就像他无法逃避那个形象。这是那种事情之一，当你这样获取信息时，这很有趣。而且我认为人们通过你的节目了解罗伯特·摩西是很棒的。你知道，因为，我的意思是，
there's definitely a lot more to dig into, but it's just the great, like, you take this sort of gestalt of this big book and kind of go, well, these are the things that speak to me about this, this idea of, you know, choice taken away from you and places being shaped for misguided and selfish reasons.
绝对还有很多可以挖掘的地方，但这只是伟大的，就像，你从这本书的整体中汲取这些东西，然后说，好吧，这些是关于这个让我产生共鸣的事情，这个想法，你知道，选择被剥夺，地方因为被误导和自私的原因而被塑造。
It is a way to describe the world as it is. It's also part of the irony of history that Robert Carroll feels the need to write this massive book, this incredibly researched book in order to tear down the myth of Robert Moses. And now 50 years later, there's people who are like, that was a real guy, huh? Like that's like, Robert Moses was so omnipresent in New York that Robert Caro had to marshal so much argument to show that he was not doing good work.
这是一种描述世界现状的方式。这也是历史讽刺的一部分，罗伯特·卡罗觉得有必要写这本厚重的书，这本经过极其详尽研究的书，以推翻罗伯特·摩西的神话。而现在50年后，有人说，那是个真实的人，嗯？就像罗伯特·摩西在纽约无处不在，以至于罗伯特·卡罗不得不动用如此多的论据来证明他没有做好的工作。
And now it's so around the opposite where people just are like, oh yeah, that's that villain on that fantasy show, you know? I mean, that's a fascinating thing, is the idea of Robert Caro, who, people just are like, oh yeah, that's got a bad rap. Like, no, like that book just decimated that guy. It did. It moiterized him. He, the, I mean, Robert Carr is the, is the definitive last word on Robert Moses legacy. And to the degree that if people are unaware of Moses and become aware of him, there is a degree of like the, the, probably the first thing you hear is some apocryphal bogeyman style story that sort of reflects or echoes something from the book. Uh,
而现在情况完全相反，人们只是说，哦，是的，那是那个奇幻节目里的反派，你知道吗？我的意思是，这是一件令人着迷的事情，罗伯特·卡罗的想法，人们只是说，哦，是的，那本书名声不好。就像，不，那本书简直摧毁了那个家伙。确实。它让他变得微不足道。他，我的意思是，罗伯特·卡罗是关于罗伯特·摩西遗产的最终定论。如果人们不知道摩西并开始了解他，在某种程度上，你听到的第一件事可能是某种伪经式的妖怪风格的故事，它反映或呼应了书中的某些东西。嗯，
or at least that's been my experience with people finding out about him as they're like, oh yeah, that's the guy. And like the first thing they'll tell you is one of the excoriating, uh, pieces of evidence from the book, right? Rather, rather than that's the man that built America, you know, Jones beach, Robert Moses? Jones Beach? Yeah.
或者至少这是我与人们发现他时的经历，他们就像，哦，是的，就是那个家伙。他们告诉你的第一件事就是书中那些严厉的证据之一，对吧？而不是那是建造美国的人，你知道，琼斯海滩（Jones Beach），罗伯特·摩西？琼斯海滩？是的。
So this is sort of the end of our series. We're in the fall of Robert Moses, the fall from power. Was it the loss of power? The loss of power. Yeah, I mean, so you have to wait till the evening to know how good the day has been. And we're getting into the evening. Like the sun is sinking down.
所以这是我们系列的结尾。我们正处于罗伯特·摩西的秋天，权力的衰落。是权力的丧失吗？权力的丧失。是的，我的意思是，所以你必须等到晚上才知道这一天过得有多好。我们正在进入夜晚。就像太阳正在下沉。
We have one more real summarizing episode left. And what's so fascinating about his fall is that through some sort of machinations of wanting to control the world's fair, and therefore giving up some of his city posts, and then for the peak resigning as a bluff to his state posts. And then finally, for the first time in decades, after doing that over and over again,
我们还剩下一集真正的总结。关于他的垮台，最令人着迷的是，通过某种想要控制世界博览会的阴谋，从而放弃了他的一些城市职位，然后为了巅峰，作为对他州职位的虚张声势而辞职。然后终于，几十年来第一次，在一次又一次地这样做之后，
Nelson Rockefeller, like, takes him up on it and he actually, you know, gets forced out of his state posts. And it's a pretty, like a whimper, ignominious end to his reign. That is not how your Robert Moses beats his end. So, and in a way, it's satisfying because you see the beats of it. And so as a story, it's really fun to watch,
纳尔逊·洛克菲勒，就像，接受了他的辞职，他实际上，你知道，被迫离开了他的州职位。这是一个相当，就像呜咽一样，对他统治的耻辱性终结。这不是你的罗伯特·摩西的结局。所以，在某种程度上，它是令人满意的，因为你看到了它的节奏。所以作为一个故事，看它真的很有趣，
you know, this resignation tactic finally not work, but it doesn't have the kind of like, sort of oomph that you kind of want. So describe how they, the fight and, you know, how they ended Robert Moses. The big villainous scheme. So it's very, I mean, this is, this is as animated and, and over the top as you can get Robert Moses and his army of vampires, his, his army of vampire financiers, uh, concoct a ritual, the New York Stock Exchange,
你知道，这个辞职策略最终没有奏效，但它没有那种你想要的“冲击力”。所以描述一下他们，战斗，你知道，他们是如何终结罗伯特·摩西的。那个巨大的邪恶计划。所以它非常，我的意思是，这是，这是你能得到的关于罗伯特·摩西和他吸血鬼军队、他吸血鬼金融家军队的最生动、最夸张的描述，嗯，在纽约证券交易所策划了一个仪式，
which our heroes are unable to stop, on New Year's Eve, and a disembodied Sauron-esque Robert Moses retreats to the ball dropping Times Square, where as the ball drops, there's a lot of magic having to do with the Golden Door, Amalazerus, the New Colossus, and the idea that in order to like basically extend his sphere of influence from New York
我们的英雄们无法阻止，在新年前夜，一个脱离肉体的索伦式的罗伯特·摩西撤退到时代广场的落球仪式，当球落下时，有很多与黄金之门、阿玛拉泽拉斯（Amalazerus）、新巨人（New Colossus）有关的魔法，以及这个想法，为了基本上将他的影响力范围从纽约
to the rest of the country, Robert Moses is going to summon the American dream. He's going to summon the embodied version of the American dream. And the danger of bringing a dream into the real world is that the second a dream becomes real, it becomes one thing. When you call a little wish or a figment into the waking world, it can become a spell, a moment, a flash, a joke, a little bit of joy. There are dreams that are so large and important
扩展到全国其他地区，罗伯特·摩西将召唤美国梦。他将召唤美国梦的化身版本。而将一个梦带入现实世界的危险在于，梦一旦成为现实，它就变成了一件事。当你把一个小愿望或一个虚构的东西带入清醒的世界时，它可以变成一个咒语、一个时刻、一个闪光、一个笑话、一点点快乐。有些梦是如此巨大和重要，
that they represent a threat to the cosmos if they are brought into the waking world. And while a dream is a dream, it can be anything. And there's a lot of fairy logic to that, but what I think it means more pointedly for Robert Moses as the master of concrete and steel and the idea of concretizing something is the idea that the American dream
以至于如果它们被带入清醒的世界，它们就代表了对宇宙的威胁。虽然梦就是梦，它可以是任何东西。而且其中有很多精灵逻辑，但我认为这对作为混凝土和钢铁大师的罗伯特·摩西来说意味着更尖锐的东西，以及具体化某物的想法，即美国梦
is at its strongest or best when it is interpretable and where it means something different to everyone who wants to pursue it. And by bringing it into the real world and putting it under his control, he will forever kill every other version of it. You see the tendrils of Robert's spell and the infection set in.
在它可解释且对每个想要追求它的人意味着不同东西时，它是最强大或最好的。通过把它带入现实世界并置于他的控制之下，他将永远扼杀它的每一个其他版本。你看到了罗伯特咒语的卷须和感染开始蔓延。
The dream warps, convulses, has its last moment where it could be anything, and begins to take a solid, stationary form. A tall, clean-cut, square-jawed, blonde-haired, blue-eyed man square-jawed, blonde-haired, blue-eyed man appears hovering in the air above you. It surveys what it can see of the city, the sidewalks, the subways, the buildings, the billboards,
梦境扭曲、抽搐，在它还能成为任何事物的最后一刻，开始呈现出一种坚固、静止的形态。一个高大、干练、方下巴、金发蓝眼的男人出现在你上方的空中。它审视着它所能看到的城市、人行道、地铁、建筑、广告牌，
and then a resonant voice goes, this place is filthy. So that poetry aside, all the good guys jump in a big tornado in Times Square and on a bunch of floating, this is where we move from the poetic into the insane and literal. They jump into a bunch of floating, this is where we move from the poetic into the insane and literal, they jump into a bunch of floating concrete sidewalk platforms,
然后一个洪亮的声音说道，这个地方真脏。所以，抛开诗意不谈，所有的好人都跳进时代广场的一个大龙卷风里，还有一堆漂浮的……这就是我们从诗意转向疯狂和现实的地方。他们跳进一堆漂浮的混凝土人行道平台，
fight the American dream, defeat the spell that Robert Moses is casting and sunder him and break his stranglehold on the unsleeping city forevermore and send the American dream back through the golden door into the land of dreams. You glow with the power of the Chosen One, and the frozen flame flies back into the golden door. Pfft!
对抗美国梦，击败罗伯特·摩西施下的咒语，将他撕碎，永远打破他对这座不眠之城的束缚，并将美国梦送回黄金之门，回到梦境之地。你散发着天选之人的力量，冰封的火焰飞回黄金之门。噗！
Robert screams, no! And that's the final battle. And it is a lot, I will say it is a lot more final than the accepting of a resignation. That's for sure, right? So if you end the book, reading the book, and you're like, I really wanted something, I really wanted a good punch to the nose
罗伯特尖叫道，不！这就是最后的战斗。我得说，这比接受辞职要彻底得多。确实如此，对吧？所以如果你读完了这本书，心里想，我真的很想要点什么，我真的很想给罗伯特·摩西的鼻子来上一拳，
of Robert Moses here. You can read the 51st chapter, which would be the Unsleeping City. Exactly, drop City. Exactly. Dropout.tv, and I will say this, we have a lot more spells. There's also a tiny little fairy mobster called Don Confetti, and he talks like this.
你可以读第51章，也就是《不眠之城》。没错，Dropout.tv。我得说，我们还有很多咒语。还有一个叫唐·五彩纸屑的小精灵黑帮，他说话是这样的。
So where's that, Robert Caro? Where's that in the book, I ask you? Oh, So good. So when you presented Robert Moses to your dream team, who are your players, did they know who Robert Moses was? Or did you know, like, did you know their level of familiarity with the character in the real world? Um, I did not.
那么，罗伯特·卡罗，那段在书里的哪里？我问你？哦，太棒了。所以当你向你的梦之队介绍罗伯特·摩西时，你的玩家们知道罗伯特·摩西是谁吗？或者你知道，你知道他们在现实世界中对这个角色的熟悉程度吗？嗯，我不知道。
I did, the crew knew, obviously, the people that I'd been working with, you know, developing the storyline knew. But yeah, I believe that a couple of them did actually know that Robert Moses was a real historical figure. And did that change the way that different people interacted with him? You know, because you're all telling the story together, and you have a master plan and a guide, not an un-Moses-like master plan for how they're going to navigate this space,
我知道，剧组当然知道，和我一起工作、开发故事情节的人都知道。但确实，我相信他们中确实有几个人知道罗伯特·摩西是一个真实的历史人物。这是否改变了不同人与他互动的方式？因为你们是在一起讲故事，你有一个总体规划和指南，这与摩西式的总体规划并无二致，关于他们将如何在这个空间中导航，
this story that you're telling, but they do have input. And did you notice that different characters interacted with the villain Moses differently? If they were more familiar with New York and what he did and that sort of thing? I just wonder if there was any sort of breakdown of pattern. I think what's interesting is the awareness came out in the midst of the season.
这个你们正在讲述的故事，但他们确实有投入。你有没有注意到不同的角色与反派摩西的互动方式不同？如果他们更熟悉纽约以及他所做的事情等等？我只是想知道是否有什么模式上的区别。我认为有趣的是，这种意识是在这一季中途出现的。
So it was not like a difference between cast members in that some immediately clocked him and some didn't. It was more that as the season was shooting, and it was clear that this was a real historical figure, that pointedness, I think, developed more. To the point where, you know, I think that final confrontation, I think, developed more. To the point where, you know, I think that final confrontation at the Met,
所以这并不是演员之间的区别，不是说有些人立刻认出了他，而有些人没有。更多的是在拍摄过程中，当很明显这是一个真实的历史人物时，那种针对性，我认为，发展得更强烈了。以至于，你知道，我认为在大都会博物馆的那场最终对决，
there's a really great part of it where Lou's character, Kingston, has basically heard enough that there's a sort of silence or gravitas to that scene where knowing how, just again, the sort of horrifying power that this man wielded and his utter remorselessness for the most marginalized communities that were impacted over and over and over again for decades.
其中有一个非常精彩的部分，卢的角色金斯顿基本上已经听够了，那场戏有一种沉默或庄重感，因为知道这个男人所掌握的那种可怕的力量，以及他对几十年来一次又一次受到影响的最边缘化社区的彻底冷酷无情。
I think that there was a degree of gravitas that is added by that. And there's this weird delineation, I think, in storytelling, especially fantasy storytelling, where villains either are misunderstood and they have a point and they're three-dimensional or they're like muahaha, like maleficent, I am arch-evil. And I weirdly think that you get some of both those worlds
我认为这增加了一种庄重感。而且我认为在讲故事，尤其是奇幻故事中，有一种奇怪的界限，反派要么是被误解的，他们有自己的道理，是立体的，要么就像玛琳菲森那样，哈哈大笑，我是大恶人。我奇怪地认为你在这两种世界中都得到了一些，
in an instance where there's nothing more three-dimensional than a real human being, but it almost makes it worse. It may, you know, like the idea that someone had a complex inner life and had emotional wrinkles and depth to themselves and was this heartless for this long wielding this much power is astonishing. And I think that the, so the PCs, as they were clocking that, I actually think it gave them a
在一个没有什么比真实的人类更立体的情况下，但这几乎让情况变得更糟。这可能，你知道，就像那种认为某人有复杂的内心生活，有情感上的褶皱和深度，却能如此冷酷地掌握如此大的权力这么久，这令人震惊。我认为，当玩家角色（PC）意识到这一点时，我实际上认为这给了他们一种
measure of resolve, even as the villain was not a total cartoon, right? Yeah. I'm just going to like add a little annotation here that PCs in this context is player characters, uh, right? So. Yes. A PC is a player character. Yes. a little annotation here that PCs in this context is player characters, right? So, I'm just saying.
决心的衡量标准，即使反派不是一个完全的卡通人物，对吧？是的。我只是想在这里加一个小注释，在这个语境下，PC是指玩家角色，对吧？所以。是的。PC就是玩家角色。是的。在这个语境下，PC是指玩家角色，对吧？所以我只是说。
Yes, a PC is a player character, yes. So that means that that's part of the group of this collective storytelling game enterprise that you're telling me. For folks turning it, and I'm sure, and again, if you're listening to 99% Invisible breaking down the power broker, I'm sure you've played tons of D&D. I'm sure that that is.
是的，PC就是玩家角色，是的。所以这意味着这是你告诉我的这个集体讲故事游戏企业的一部分。对于那些收听的人，我敢肯定，再说一次，如果你正在收听《99%隐形》对《权力掮客》的解析，我敢肯定你玩过很多龙与地下城（D&D）。我敢肯定那是。
I mean, it's a decent crossover. There's probably plenty who don't, who are just like into history stuff. We were debating this of how much to describe what D&D is because obviously there's like, there's different sections of the world who know different things for sure. But for example, when I was talking to my kids,
我的意思是，这是一个不错的跨界。可能有很多不玩的人，只是对历史感兴趣。我们当时在争论要描述多少关于D&D的内容，因为显然世界上有不同的部分知道不同的事情，这是肯定的。但例如，当我和我的孩子们交谈时，
I have twin 17 year olds who are very into D&D and I mentioned that I was talking to my kids, I have twin 17-year-olds who are very into D&D, and I mentioned that I was going to talk to you, and I said, are you familiar with Brendan Lee Mulligan's work? And they were like, he's only the greatest DM in the world, probably of all time. You know, like, you know. Oh, man.
我有17岁的双胞胎，他们非常喜欢D&D，我提到我要和你谈话，我说，你们熟悉布伦丹·李·穆里根的作品吗？他们说，他简直是世界上最伟大的地下城主（DM），可能是有史以来最伟大的。你知道，你知道。哦，天哪。
That's so sweet. That's very kind. And so, yeah, so like like they're the people who know both because I talk about the Power Broker endlessly and they watched Unsleeping City as it came out, like I was aware of it, you know. Wow, wow, wow, that's incredible. So when you're devising something as complex
太贴心了。你太客气了。所以，是的，他们是既了解两者的人，因为我无休止地谈论《权力掮客》，他们看了《不眠之城》的播出，就像我意识到它一样，你知道。哇，哇，哇，这太不可思议了。所以当你设计像
as Unsleeping City, and you have some designs where you want to lead them, but they have their own agency to a certain degree. How do you balance that when you're telling something that's complex? Like the idea of the highway hacks and the American dream and stuff, it's just complex ideas.
《不眠之城》这样复杂的东西时，你有一些想要引导他们的设计，但他们在一定程度上拥有自己的代理权。当你讲述复杂的事情时，你是如何平衡这一点的？比如高速公路黑客和美国梦之类的想法，这只是复杂的想法。
At least they seem to me to be that way. How do you do that? I feel, Roman, that I'm being set up for an analogy where this very much mirrors Robert Moses. And I just want to tell you that I see the trap. I see that you're laying it out here, okay? I'm onto you, man. That was very smart of you.
至少在我看来是这样。你是怎么做到的？罗曼，我觉得我被设下了一个类比，这在很大程度上反映了罗伯特·摩西。我只是想告诉你，我看到了这个陷阱。我看到你在这里布置它了，好吗？我识破你了，伙计。你太聪明了。
That's why you're a good DM. That's why you can see the game behind his DMing in the interview. I see the game, man. No, but you're very right. There is a fascinating, well, I think that the, in the language that Robert Moses uses a lot to talk about, you know, when he's talking about like Long Island
这就是为什么你是一个好的DM。这就是为什么你能在采访中看出他DM背后的游戏。我看到了这个游戏，伙计。不，但你说得很对。有一个迷人的，嗯，我认为，在罗伯特·摩西谈论很多事情时使用的语言中，你知道，当他谈论像长岛
and he's talking about like, what are the kinds of people we want to attract, right? Like, that's the language he uses, but there is a darkness and a cynicism when you understand that individual freedom written over massive populations and a powerful incentive structure is fate. Free will over the aggregate becomes fate when
以及他谈论像，我们想要吸引什么样的人，对吧？就像，那是他使用的语言，但当你理解个人自由在庞大的人口和强大的激励结构上被书写时，这是一种命运，这背后有一种黑暗和愤世嫉俗。当激励足够强烈时，总体的自由意志就变成了命运。
you incentivize strongly enough. And that's really sad. And it challenges a lot of our deeply held ideas about the power of individual freedom. And so you answer your question on a DMing level, sadly, it's the same, it's the same necromancy. It's the same magic where you go, you are kind of building these tracks. You're building this thing where you go, okay, you can do whatever you want, but I know what you want. So if I build, it's like, it's, it's, it's sort of, there's, there's, when people are seeking a stimulus, you know, um, it's like,
这真的很可悲。它挑战了我们许多关于个人自由力量的根深蒂固的想法。所以你回答了你在DM层面的问题，可悲的是，这是同样的，这是同样的死灵术。这是同样的魔法，你说，你有点在建造这些轨道。你正在建造这个东西，你说，好吧，你可以做任何你想做的事，但我知道你想要什么。所以如果我建造，这就像，它，它，它有点，有，有，当人们在寻求刺激时，你知道，嗯，这就像，
it would be, this is such a, this is, I don't mean this as a, as a disparagement of players, but to use a metaphor that there's like, you have cheese at the end of the maze. You don't have to seal off the maze. You don't have to trap anyone in the maze if you know that they're looking for the cheese, right? There's, there's this element of when you're building adventures and you're building even these complex ideas
这会是，这是一个如此的，这是，我并不是说这是对玩家的贬低，但使用一个隐喻，就像你在迷宫尽头有奶酪。你不需要封锁迷宫。如果你知道他们在寻找奶酪，你就不需要把任何人困在迷宫里，对吧？有，有这个元素，当你构建冒险，甚至构建这些复杂的想法
in there, you make something very personal. You make something where it's like, well, this person has this villainous ideology, and that ideology has resulted in concrete harm to a loved one, or it's resulted in something that is very visceral and felt to my character. And the best way, honestly, to create these story structures is in collaboration with your players,
在里面时，你让它变得非常个人化。你让它变得像，好吧，这个人有这种邪恶的意识形态，而这种意识形态导致了对亲人的具体伤害，或者它导致了我的角色非常直观和感受到的东西。老实说，创建这些故事结构的最佳方式是与你的玩家合作，
which doesn't mean that you're pre-writing what the story is going to be. But there's this beautiful, when I talk to like novice dungeon masters about how to construct adventures and flow sheets and sequences of events that your friends will feel compelled to improvise through. It's always the idea of the motivation and heart of your players as they're embodying these characters has force and inertia to it. It's like water flowing downhill.
这并不意味着你预先写好了故事会是什么样子。但有一种美妙的，当我与像新手地下城主谈论如何构建冒险和流程图以及事件序列时，你的朋友会感到被迫即兴发挥。这总是关于你的玩家在体现这些角色时的动机和内心的想法，它有力量和惯性。它就像水往低处流。
You can irrigate a hillside to know where the water is going to go. And it's not a reflection on the water doing what you told it to, it's a reflection on you understand that these people are pursuing their aims rationally. And if they're pursuing their aims rationally, you can create the structures that direct those aims. Brennan, you're not gonna like this,
你可以灌溉山坡以了解水会流向哪里。这并不是反映水做了你告诉它的事情，而是反映你理解这些人正在理性地追求他们的目标。如果他们正在理性地追求他们的目标，你就可以创建引导这些目标的结构。布伦南，你不会喜欢这个的，
but talking about knowing what people want and using that as leverage to get them to do what you want them to, sounds like power brokering, to be honest. No, man, no. Sounds like you're doing a lot of power brokering. Yeah. Come on, man, don't do this to me, dude.
但谈论了解人们想要什么并利用它作为杠杆让他们做你想让他们做的事，老实说，听起来像是权力掮客。不，伙计，不。听起来你在做很多权力掮客的事。是的。得了吧，伙计，别这样对我，老兄。
You can't do this to me. It's almost like DM stands for dungeon Moses. Hold on a second. No! Suddenly I've just, my disguise fades away, curses! And I fly out the window. It was him the whole time. It was him the whole time.
你不能这样对我。这简直就像DM代表地下城摩西（Dungeon Moses）。等一下。不！突然间我的伪装消失了，该死！我飞出了窗户。一直都是他。一直都是他。
It's very, yeah, it's a very, I don't know, it's genuinely a joy and a privilege to be able to write these kinds of stories. And I think too, like, in our first season, Robert Moses was such like a fun, compelling villain for the historicity and how much like history mattered and was important. And I think too in the second season that we did as well,
这非常，是的，这是一个非常，我不知道，能够写出这些故事确实是一种快乐和特权。而且我也认为，在我们的第一季中，罗伯特·摩西是一个非常有趣、引人注目的反派，因为历史性以及历史是多么重要。而且我也认为在我们做的第二季中，
urban fantasy is so interesting in that you're often depicting both at the same time, you're depicting the heightened fantastical reality as well as the, uh, what is actually the mundane reality on the ground, you know, like our second season, we had sort of a large company called Gladiator that was trying to open a campus in Queens. And there was like, this was around, you know,
都市奇幻非常有趣，因为你经常同时描绘两者，你描绘了高度奇幻的现实以及，嗯，实际上地面上的平凡现实，你知道，就像我们的第二季，我们有一个叫角斗士的大公司，试图在皇后区开设一个园区。而且有像，这是围绕，你知道，
this idea of like a big conglomerate shipping, you know, e-commerce company. And it was summoning this extra-dimensional being called null. And that season was very much about kind of the emptiness and urban isolation of hyper-consumerist capitalism, right? And so you're depicting these things where there's
这种像大企业航运，你知道，电子商务公司的想法。它正在召唤一个叫“虚无”的超维度存在。那一季非常多地是关于那种超消费资本主义的空虚和城市孤立，对吧？所以你正在描绘这些东西，那里有
this haunting entity in the dream world that's coming out of it. It's like a faceless, colorless silhouette, very Lovecraftian. But then also you're looking at like an apartment complex with no one living in it because all of the apartments have been purchased as basically asset class investments, you know, like, which I think there's some crazy percentage of apartments on central park that are vacant for like more than 80% of the year, right?
这个梦境世界中挥之不去的实体正从中出来。它就像一个无面、无色的剪影，非常洛夫克拉夫特式。但同时你也在看像一个没有人居住的公寓大楼，因为所有的公寓基本上都被作为资产类投资购买了，你知道，就像，我认为中央公园有某种疯狂比例的公寓是空置的，比如一年中超过80%的时间，对吧？
And so it's a bizarre, it's a fun thing in crafting these stories, especially in any kind of setting like the Unsleeping City that's so contingent on the real world and is very much depicting that, where you're like, here's the metaphor and here's the reality and here's both of them hand in hand. You know what I mean? Like it's not just the analogy.
所以这是一个奇怪的，在制作这些故事时的一件有趣的事情，特别是在像《不眠之城》这样非常依赖现实世界并且在很大程度上描绘了这一点的任何设置中，你就像，这是隐喻，这是现实，这是两者携手并进。你知道我的意思吗？就像它不仅仅是类比。
The analogy is like here with this other component that is real. It's a joy. It's a real privilege to be able to tell these kind of stories. And speaking of New York, we'll be coming to Madison Square Garden in January, which is nuts. What?
类比就像这里有另一个真实的组成部分。这是一种快乐。能够讲述这些故事是一种真正的特权。说到纽约，我们一月份要去麦迪逊广场花园，这太疯狂了。什么？
We, the Dimension 20 is going to be performing January 24th at Madison Square Garden. We sold out the garden. So it's a- Congratulations. That's awesome. Thank you. I appreciate it. Which is a very, as again, like having grown up in New York, it's a very-
我们，Dimension 20将于1月24日在麦迪逊广场花园演出。我们卖光了花园的票。所以这是一个——恭喜。太棒了。谢谢。我很感激。这是一个非常，再次，像在纽约长大一样，这是一个非常——
Yeah, it's amazing. Yeah. Love it. It's Yeah. It's nuts. It's nuts. Well, I mean, thank you so much for being on the 9% Invisible Breakdown of the Power Broker. It's been a real pleasure and it was really, it's just fun.
是的，太神奇了。是的。喜欢它。是的。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。好吧，我的意思是，非常感谢你参加《99%隐形》对《权力掮客》的解析。这真是一种荣幸，而且真的，这只是很有趣。
I hope people like who are interested in D&D or even if you're not, just like check out the season, watch it unfold. It's a really fun take on the underlying concepts and values of the book. It's just great. You add it to the canon. And thank you for using your medium
我希望那些对D&D感兴趣的人，或者即使你不感兴趣，也去看看这一季，看着它展开。这是对书中基本概念和价值观的一个非常有趣的解读。这太棒了。你把它加入到了正典中。谢谢你利用你的媒介
to spread the word of Robert Moses and the Power Broker to those who were previously not aware of it, but are pretty interested in digging into lore. So I think they're gonna enjoy the Power Broker when they finally get to it, yeah. I'll say, if you love lore, Robert Caro's The Power Broker is chock full of lore, my friends. Chock full of lore.
向那些以前不知道，但对挖掘传说非常感兴趣的人传播罗伯特·摩西和《权力掮客》的消息。所以我认为当他们最终读到《权力掮客》时，他们会喜欢的，是的。我会说，如果你喜欢传说，罗伯特·卡罗的《权力掮客》充满了传说，我的朋友们。充满了传说。
Uh, that's how we make a difference. We start referring to history as lore. Um, we're gonna get a bunch of people. Uh, it's truly a pleasure and an honor to be on the podcast today, and I really hope that anyone who is coming here from Dimension 20 digs into not only the rest of the Power Broker, but the rest of 99% Invisible.
呃，这就是我们如何做出改变。我们开始把历史称为传说。嗯，我们会有一群人。嗯，今天能参加这个播客确实是一种荣幸和光荣，我真的希望任何从Dimension 20来到这里的人不仅能深入研究《权力掮客》的其余部分，还能深入研究《99%隐形》的其余部分。
All the things that I talked about that matter to me, it's, I feel very much like, if I can do anything as a comedian and storyteller to direct people towards these things. Learning about Robert Moses as the villainous, arcane architect of the highway hex is hopefully step one on people digging into not only the history of Robert Moses in New York,
所有我谈到的对我重要的事情，我感觉非常像，如果我能作为一名喜剧演员和讲故事的人做任何事情来引导人们走向这些事情。了解罗伯特·摩西作为高速公路黑客的邪恶、神秘的建筑师，希望是人们不仅挖掘罗伯特·摩西在纽约的历史的第一步，
but the people wherever you live, the city that you're in, and who is shaping the environs of your life, and is there a way to get active in resisting whatever highway hex is being implemented in your town right now? Nice, well said. Next month, and I cannot believe what I am saying right now, we are going to be finishing
而且挖掘你居住的地方，你所在的城市，以及谁在塑造你生活的环境，是否有办法积极抵制你所在城镇目前正在实施的任何高速公路黑客？不错，说得好。下个月，我简直不敢相信我现在在说什么，我们将要完成
the book. Forget page numbers, just read it till the end. Read the book till there's nothing left in it to read anymore. We're there, people. It's the homestretch. And if you can't wait till next month to hear my voice summarizing something, why not turn to the Flophouse podcast where we never reach the end. There's always more bad movies to talk about. It's an unending torment. We've got a bunch of 99PI Power Broker merch for you to congratulate yourselves on making it this far. There are t-shirts, there are bags, there are bookmarks, and something that we've been
这本书。忘了页码，读到最后就行了。读这本书直到里面没有什么可读的了。我们到了，各位。这是最后冲刺。如果你等不及下个月听到我总结某事的声音，为什么不转向Flophouse播客，我们永远不会到达终点。总有更多的烂电影可以谈论。这是一种无尽的折磨。我们为你准备了一堆99PI《权力掮客》的周边商品，以祝贺你们走到这一步。有T恤，有包，有书签，还有一些我们一直在
waiting to tell you about. We have a 99PI Power Broker challenge coin. It's a commemorative coin. It's totally Power Broker themed. A prize to get yourself to show to anyone and everyone that you've finished the Power Broker. Because you'll no longer have the Power Broker book as this totem that you're lugging around. And you'll now have this coin to commemorate
等着告诉你的事情。我们有一个99PI《权力掮客》挑战币。这是一个纪念币。它完全是《权力掮客》主题的。一个奖品，让你向任何人展示你已经读完了《权力掮客》。因为你将不再拥有《权力掮客》这本书作为你随身携带的图腾。你现在将拥有这枚硬币来纪念
that you are a true Power Broker nerd. The coins will be in the store soon. If they're not there already by the time this episode comes out, just head to 99pi.org slash store to get one. The 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Power Broker is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by Comiti, music by Swan Real, edited by Comiti, music by Swan Rial, mixed by Dara Hirsch.
你是一个真正的《权力掮客》书呆子。硬币很快就会在商店里上架。如果这集播出时它们还没在那里，只需前往99pi.org/store购买一个。《99%隐形》对《权力掮客》的解析由伊莎贝尔·安吉尔制作，科米蒂编辑，斯旺·里亚尔配乐，科米蒂编辑，斯旺·里亚尔配乐，达拉·赫什混音。
99% Invisible's executive producer is Cathy Tu, our senior editor is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colston is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Artin Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Dawn, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Nina Pautuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his below-goat was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor.
《99%隐形》的执行制片人是凯西·图，我们的高级编辑是德莱尼·霍尔，库尔特·科尔斯顿是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁贝、杰森·德里昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、阿廷·冈萨雷斯、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·雷、拉什玛·道恩、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格、尼娜·帕图克，以及我，罗曼·马斯。《99%隐形》是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。这个系列的艺术是由亚伦·内斯特创作的。
We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server where we have fun discussions about the power broker, about architecture, about bad movies that seem somewhat inspired by the power broker, and all that kind of good stuff. It's where I'm hanging out most of the time. You can find a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org.
我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰上城区。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到这个节目，以及我们自己的Discord服务器，我们在那里进行关于《权力掮客》、建筑、似乎受到《权力掮客》启发的烂电影以及所有这类好东西的有趣讨论。那是我大部分时间待的地方。你可以在99PI.org找到该链接以及《99%隐形》的每一集往期节目。
The banality of evil. That is so goddamn boring. Yeah, he got all the good points. Of course the most evil guy is the guy that built the highways. So dull. Yeah, he's real bad. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
平庸之恶。那真是该死的无聊。是的，他抓住了所有好的观点。当然，最邪恶的人是那个建造高速公路的人。太沉闷了。是的，他真的很坏。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。